hey it's Andrew Brown your favorite
Cloud instructor over here on free Camp
bringing you another free Cloud
certification study course and this time
it's the Azure fundamentals also known
as the
a900 and the way we're going to achieve
Microsoft certification is by watching
those lecture videos doing those
Hands-On labs and as always I'm going to
provide you a free practice exam so you
can go get that certification putting
your resume uh putting on your LinkedIn
and go uh get that a cloud roll you've
been looking to get if you love these
kinds of uh Cloud certification study
courses the best way to support more
free courses just like this one is to
purchase the paid optional materials
it's going to help you uh increase your
odds of passing the exam and it just
helps the production of these courses um
and if you don't know me I'm Andrew
Brown and I've taught a lot of different
Cloud certification study courses here
uh we've done adabs Azure gcp kubernetes
terraform you name it I've taught it uh
but that's about it let's go ahead and
learn some Azure and I'll see you soon
ciao hey this is Andre Brown and welcome
to the Microsoft Azure fundamentals and
we're asking the most important question
uh first which is what is this
certification well uh the Azure
fundamentals is the entrylevel cloud
certification for Microsoft Azure or
Azure uh and you'll see me alternate
between those uh pronunciations they're
both accepted so whichever you prefer um
there is no prerequisite for this
certification uh but you should probably
have a little bit of it experience but
if you don't it's totally fine if you're
totally new to Cloud you still be okay
here uh the key topics that we are
covering is understanding the basics of
cloud computing exploring the benefits
of using cloud services uh and looking
at those core Services the those being
Computing networking storage and
databases understanding identity
security governance so you know one
example for identity would would be
entra ID previously known as Azure ad
something you'll hear again and again
through all the uh Microsoft
certification courses um understanding
how pricing Works things like
subscriptions uh and cost management
tools and uh learning about the tools
available for managing Azure resources
uh such as Azure portal or the SDK or
the CLI and things like that uh
Microsoft Azure is the second leading
cloud service provider in the world the
first being AWS but uh let that not uh
discourage you because Azure is still an
extremely uh great uh cloud service uh
to use and um it's used quite a lot so
Azure fundamentals is a very common
starting point for people breaking the
cloud U similar to the ads Cloud
practitioner so both are really great
entries uh into Cloud who's the
certification for well consider this uh
fundamental certification if you're new
to cloud and you want to learn the
fundamentals and benefits adopting cloud
services in general you are from a
non-technical background such as an
executive management or sales level and
you need to acquire strategic
information about uh Cloud for adoption
or migration you want to understand the
capabilities of azure and how to build
basic Solutions and deploy cloud
services in your organization very very
basic but I mean the the objective of
these fundamental certifications is not
to really teach you how to build Cloud
workloads um that is more at associate
level but we'll talk about that later on
uh or you're a senior Cloud engineer or
solution architect or or Cloud architect
who needs a reset or refresh their
knowledge after working with Azure for
multiple years but maybe you didn't
notice some things change so it's a
great uh revisit to get an idea of what
is going on here so what is the value of
the certification well the fundamentals
is uh provides the most expensive view
possible for um Cloud architecture and
Azure uh I like to say this is going to
provide you a bird's eyee view or the
50,000 foot view so we're going to cover
a lot of stuff uh but it's not going to
be uh as detailed as you would imagine
but uh the idea here is to promote big
picture thinking zooming out and
assessing the cloud and Azure landscape
for changes Trends opportunities uh and
being strategic about the approach and
process for our Cloud Journey okay um
the Azure fundamentals is not a
difficult exam it will not validate that
you can build Cloud workloads um for
technical roles such as developer
engineer devops it's not going to be
enough to obtain those roles but it it's
possible that it could short list your
resume for interview um the exam covers
content not found in other
certifications so strongly recommend
that you take this as your foundational
certification a lot of people like to
skip fundamentals because they they
think that they're easy yes the
certification easy but the exam content
has a lot of stuff in it especially mine
because I pack in a ton of stuff that I
just I'm not going to put it the next
level because I'm going to assume that
you taking this course and getting all
that knowledge there uh the a900 00 lays
a a gr foundation for Specialized or
specialization for Azure certifications
and is a stepping stone for professional
de development in cloud services so
definitely there is value in the a900
let's go take a look at the Azure road
map and this is not all of the Asher
certifications and Microsoft
certifications they just have too many I
cannot fit them all on screen here and
um I think all the course codes are up
to date but they're changing them all
the time so uh it's possible that they
might be incremented by some verions but
the the entry we have the Azure
fundamentals there are other fundamental
certifications um we have the AI 900
which is for AI we have the dp900 which
is for data uh we have the sc900 which
is for security but again I don't have
room for all that so I'm not showing
them on here so I'm showing you the path
that is commonly uh completed after
taking the a900 so you have uh some
associate certifications you have a
couple expert certifications you have
specialty certifications there's
definitely more Associates there's
definitely more Specialties but there's
always the two Pros or experts I should
say so getting my a handy pen out here
very often what people go for after the
fundamentals is the administrator the
a104 this is the most common path uh for
those that are going to their next step
in their Azure journey and a lot of
times people are going for that
Solutions architect expert which is over
here but before you do that you really
want to go and grab that uh uh developer
the a 204 these are the uh this is the
the the most common strategy right here
is uh these but of course it really
depends on what you're doing if you're
doing security you have the sc900 and
then there's three different associate
level security
certifications uh if you are going after
data that's a whole different track so
it's going to really vary based on that
but um again you know this is the most
common track and even if you go uh do
all of this and you want to do something
else that's totally fine because this is
going to lay a very very very strong
Foundation uh and give you really good
skills in Azure so how long does it take
to study for this certification well if
you're a beginner we're looking at about
30 hours and this is someone that's
never written uh or used Azure or any
cloud provider have never written any
code or held a tech role technically the
certification doesn't require you to
code but I really want to make sure that
I set you up really well because in
Azure uh coding and scripting and that
kind of stuff is way more important than
any other cloud provider uh because you
come across it a lot more and so I've
stuck in a bunch of coding stuff and it
is very challenging for beginners but I
want to try to get you um best prepared
as possible because when you go to the
associate level with like the a104 it is
so much more difficult so I made this
much harder than it had to be to prepare
you for the next level despite the exam
okay so uh again 30 hours on that side
if you're experienced uh then you're
already working with that Azure or you
maybe are you've worked in eight of us
in gcp and you are trying to pick up
Azure the it could be as little as 6
hours um so you know generally the study
time is 24 hours and I would say it's
split between uh lectures and labs and
then you have your practice exams so
just make sure that you put your time uh
in with the practice exams practice
exams are very very very very very
important for Azure because Azure has
all these different question types and
we'll talk about that in a moment but
yeah the recommend studies is 1 to two
hours a day for 14 days take your time
let it absorb uh you could finish it in
a couple days but don't do that you know
make sure that you are acquiring the
knowledge for long term and the the best
way to do that is to take your time uh
and and not try to pass it in a weekend
um what does it take to pass the examp
well you got to watch those lecture
videos you got to do those Hands-On labs
and fall alongs within your own account
uh strongly recommend that you do uh
some paid online practice exam
uh we give you a full free practice exam
like a full set uh which is on our
platform there we have a lot of practice
exams you can get that at exampro doco
a900 and really helps support the course
here uh where do you take the exam well
you're going to either take it in person
at a test center or the convenience of
your home um and uh so I would just say
just a second
here sorry about that b is knocking on
my door door beo is the other Andrew uh
who you you'll hear me talk about uh bo
a bit throughout the course but uh he's
the other person that works with me
that's never on camera you never see him
but um he helps uh do a lot of the work
over here uh with uh the platform and um
creating the content but anyway so Azure
uh delivers exams via I got to reclick
here um and the click's not working
there we go uh Pearson view uh is the
proctoring system that Microsoft uses in
the past there used to be a bunch of
ones there's Criterion uh which Google
used to use Google Cloud there's PSI
online which um adab us like to use but
for whatever reason both um adabs and um
Microsoft exclusively only use Pearson
view now and I think um gcp is now using
PSI online and everyone else uses PSI um
for whatever reason but yeah you have to
use Pearson View and you can do it
online or Pearson view has a uh a
network of test centers that uh you can
go to in person personally I recommend
that you go in person if you can because
if there is a test center near you the
whole environment is controlled it's
going to be a lot less stressful whereas
if you do it from home uh you know if
you have family or you have uh the least
ideal place to uh set up uh because you
have to have a non-cluttered room and
they have to inspect your room and
things can go wrong so I'm just saying
if you have that opportunity to go to an
iners inperson test center Center
leverage that if you can't that's okay
do what works for you but understand
that these certifications are proctored
uh so uh when you go sit that exam there
is someone who is monitoring you to make
sure that you are not cheating um in
terms of the content outline there is
three domains I think there used to be
more but they grouped them into three
I'm not sure why uh each domain has its
own waiting and and that determines how
many questions in a domain will show up
so we'll look take a look there
something that's really interesting
about Azure exam is that they um they
don't give you the same amount of
questions uh per person so they'll give
you like you like you might sit the exam
and get 35 and your friend might get 40
so I had to give ranges here in terms of
um uh the the percentage that will
appear on your exam so we have
describing Cloud Concepts which is 25 to
30% so you're going to get about 13 to
15 questions describe Azure architecture
and services that's 35 to 40% that is
the majority of uh the certification
most fundamentals is about learning all
the services uh that the cloud service
provider is providing then we have
describe Azure management and governance
so that's uh 30 to 35% with 14 to 16 uh
16 questions there is uh subdomains
under each of these so of course
security is in there and all those other
things are in there but we'll have to
open up the exam guide uh to see that
okay so um again you know just pointing
out that that domain 2 is the largest
one there so make sure that we we're
going to make sure that we know a wide
range of azure services but we're also
going to make sure we know in depth a a
bit more about those core Services let's
talk about grading you got to get 700
points out of a th000 so um that's about
70% we say around because Azure uses
skilled scoring meaning that it doesn't
necessarily mean you get 70% and you
pass um you could technically pass with
71% or sorry fail with 71% but you could
also technically pass with 69% so just
understand it's not based on percentage
it's based on a point system in terms of
what kind of questions you'll be getting
well first let's talk about the range of
questions but you can get between 35 to
50 I us say 37 to 37 to 50 um it's
confusing because I don't know how they
determine how many you get uh when I sat
my exam I got about 35 questions some
people get more uh it's really really
tricky to to nail that down there so you
know we say about 10 to 14 questions you
have you can afford to get wrong there
are no penalty for wrong questions so
absolutely uh always fill in the answers
in terms of formatting questions uh we
have multiple choice multiple answer
drag and drop yes and no I do need to
point out that uh when you go and take
uh associate level and expert level
certifications with Microsoft they have
way more um question types and
uh just to help prepare you uh for that
level of difficulty and it doesn't
appear in these exams but in our
practice exams we try to put in uh case
studies so case studies is a much more
advanced um exam type question and you
know I really feel that we need to do
that because if we don't uh you're going
to feel like you're ready for the AZ 104
and you're going to get totally
blindsided because again the difficulty
ramp is super hard so again we're
increasing the difficulty for your
benefit uh so if you feel like uh this
course is hard that's good because it's
going to make the next one really really
easy for you uh in terms of duration
apparently it's 45 minutes I cannot
remember how long it was when I sat it
uh and when you search the internet it's
very difficult to determine that number
uh Microsoft does not make it easy to
find out that number you think that they
would other cloud service providers
their certification exams they tell you
right on the same page good luck finding
it on azure but uh 45 minutes would
still leave us with about one minute per
time again it depends if you get the 35
questions or 45 questions so we're going
to have to say about a minute uh so
we'll say the exam time is 45 minutes uh
some people say the seat time is 60 to
65 minutes when we say SE time we we're
talking about the time you should
allocate for the exam that includes
things like time to review instructions
read and accept the NDA complete the
exam provide the feedback at the end now
personally I think that the seat time
should always be 30 minutes on top of
whatever that is so if it's 45 minutes
it really would be um 75 minutes or 70
minutes or something like that so uh you
know anyway if you got a 45 minute exam
show up 30 minutes or 35 minutes earlier
because if you're checking in especially
online you got to uh pull out your uh
government ID you got to make sure the
lighting is right and then it scans it
in if things go wrong uh you know it's
going to cut in your time so give
yourself ample time and don't get
stressed out um uh for that okay so
these certifications are uh for
Microsoft are valid Forever This is
specific for fundamental certifications
so if you take the um any one that has
900 in the name so a900 dp900 AI 900
sc900 PL 900
ms9900 you get in the pattern here if it
says 900 in the name it's a fundamentals
those certifications do not expire um
and so I just want to make that very
very very clear um for the other levels
like associ expert um I think it's two
years it's either two or three years but
uh the interesting thing is that if you
want to get
recertified um you don't have to pay to
take the exam again you can take a
simpler test to U make sure that your
knowledge is up to date and I think it's
free so uh that's a great advantage that
Microsoft has at the associate and
expert level specialty level but uh yeah
there we go and I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one all right so I went on to the
internet and I searched for a900 and
we've ended up on the learn.
microsoft.com the reason I want to show
you this page is to uh get more familiar
with where we actually get the
information um so that you can read up
about about it if we didn't answer
everything or if anything has changed um
but it's good good good to be familiar
with these pages so once you're here
here uh on the
a900 um what they'll have down below
here is the study guide now the study
guide used to be in a PDF format and for
whatever reason Azure has just made it a
website with all the other study guides
here I really don't like this format um
I find that it's very hard to find uh
information and to read it I really
prefer the old PDF but that's never
coming back or if it is it's somewhere
else and I don't know where it is but
what we can see over here um is the
actual breakdown so so we have Cloud
Concepts and so we think see things like
defining cloud computing share
responsibility model the um different uh
deployments of cloud um and a bunch of
other stuff
here um you can see describing the cloud
service types now at one point they
actually removed this and now it's back
so that's really interesting I don't
know why they ever removed it to begin
with but it's good to see that that is
uh returning we have uh I call This
Global uh infrastructure or uh and uh
cloud networking so they call this core
Architectural Components which I suppose
some of these things are but this is
more like a billing thing and this is
more Global
infrastructure then we have Azure comput
and networking services so we're
recovering virtual machines functions
skill sets availability sets uh Azure
virtual desktop now we don't have to do
all these things um and we aren't going
to do all these things because some of
these things are really hard like Azure
virtual desktop is not an easy task but
we need to know what they are we are
going to launch a virtual machine uh and
uh play around with that a little bit we
are going to launch an Azure function um
then we have storage services so we do a
lot with Azure uh storage because it is
uh cheap and easy to use uh then we need
to know how to perform different
operations with Azure um Azure storage
there then we have Azure identity access
and security so um again this is a
subcategory under here or subdomain so
we need to know a bunch of things about
security I'm just going to tell you that
some of the content is going to say
Azure ID some of it's going to say
Microsoft Entre ID um Microsoft for some
crazy reason decided to change the name
of azure ad even though everybody was
fine with it it confuses uh myself and
Boo and everyone else to this day so
just understand that some of it's Azure
ID some of it's Microsoft entra ID but
this is this is really what's going to
be going forward okay we have described
cost Management in Azure so that uh
that's TCO so more pricing stuff here um
a Azure purview Azure
policy we have the Azure portal which is
just the platform which we use
everything Azure Arc which uh I guess
it's okay to know uh we actually do a
lot of interesting coding here so I show
you how to do IC with um arm templates
and Azure bicep and
terraform uh so that stuff's fun there
we look at uh monitoring tools so we
look at Azure service Health Azure
advisor all sorts of fun stuff now there
could be other stuff that appears exam
that's uh uh not on here and so we just
do a very thorough job to show you uh
basically everything and just to kind of
round out your knowledge but again it's
very difficult to um to find all the
details like the time of the exam and
the amount of questions they really just
do not make this easily available here
if anyone finds it please tell me
because I sure can't find it and uh the
only way I know is by Sting the exam and
I have to remember those details
afterwards they do show what kind of
changes that they make um so they're
always making teeny tiny changes but try
not to worry about that too much because
we do ensure to include a lot of stuff
here and this exam is up to date and and
and the fresh and as fresh as it can be
as of this recording but you know I find
that even two years out people are
passing uh like people are passing the
the current exam with the old the old
one um which is which is really
interesting so it just shows you that
not much changes on those exams okay but
anyway that's that another thing I want
to show you is the exam s sandbox so
this uh emulates the Pearson view uh
kind of experience and it'll just show
you some of the question formats now uh
we are under here for the a900 and it
might show us more exam types than what
we'll actually see on the exam so go
here this just has 10 questions it's
going to just show us all the types so
here we have multiple choice then we
have multiple select I'm not looking at
what the correct answers are or reading
any of it I'm just showing you here I
believe that we drag these into these
areas here so that's this
one then this one is your answer area
and you're bringing them over and then
you're trying to uh determine the order
so you're changing the order here then
this one's an answer area so we go here
and it's just an image and this is
draggable we have this one here so we
look at this graphic and we try to match
it based on this information we read it
very
clearly this one here
um uh what is this for a hot area so hot
area is you have a Graphic very similar
to that other one but you click it it's
almost like you're kind of interacting
with it but you're not it's just an
image then we have a case study so this
is something that we absolutely
absolutely give you in our platform and
you will not see this on your exam but
we give you this exam question type
anyway because it's super important uh
to get that kind of experience you
notice this one's a little bit more uh
robust in terms of the information and
so there are other things um yeah
another thing with case studies is when
you do a case study you basically get a
series of questions around this case
study right and it went to the next part
and it's kind of like a mini exam inside
the mini exam I'll show you case studies
in another video so I know I'm going
really quick there but uh we'll come
back to that then sometimes you have uh
these additional tabs so this is kind of
like a minic case study for just a
particular question but they might say
hey uh check out the exhibit and you
have to look at the exhibit come back
and then answer the question so there's
that and then sometimes there's multiple
exhibits so yeah but uh yeah there you
go so that is the um the sandbox there
so hopefully that gives you a good idea
the price might vary based on where you
live so if we go to Canada I'm not sure
what the price is in Canada so we go
here and it still shows
$199 USD we go somewhere else does it
ever show a different price sometimes it
does okay for some reason Canada gets a
bad price but uh some other places do a
little bit better so understand that
that price is going to fluctuate based
on where you live um yeah hopefully that
gives you an idea of the uh exam and
we'll see you in the next one okay
ciao
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are at the start of our journey
asking the most important question first
which is what is cloud computing so
cloud computing is the practice of using
a network of remote servers hosted on
the internet to store manage and process
data rather than a local server or
personal computer and so when we're
talking about on premise you own the
servers you hire the IT people you pay
or rent the real estate you take all the
risks but with a cloud provider uh
someone else owns the servers someone
someone else hires the IT people someone
else pays or rents the real estate and
you are responsible for configuring
cloud services and code and someone
takes care of the rest of it for you
okay so to understand cloud computing we
need to look at the evolution of cloud
hosting going all the way back to 1995
where if you wanted to host your website
or web app you'd have to get a dedicated
server so that would be one physical
machine dedicated to a single business
running a single project a site or an
app and as you can imagine these are
expensive because you have to uh buy
outright the hardware have a place to
store it the network connection having a
person to maintain it um but it did give
you a guarantee of high security um and
they still do as of today so this model
hasn't gone away but it's been
specialized for a particular use case
then came along the virtual private
server so the idea is we still had one
physical machine but now we were able to
subdivide um our machine into
submachines via
virtualization and so essentially you're
running a machine machine within a
machine and so you had better
utilization of that machine um running
multiple web apps as opposed to having a
physical machine per project so you got
better utilization and isolation of
resources and so uh these two options
still required you to purchase a machine
a dedicated machine and so that was
still kind of expensive but then came
along shared hosting and so if you
remember uh the mid 2000s like with
GoDaddy or HostGator or any of those
sites where you had really cheap posting
the idea is that you had this one
physical machine shared by hundreds of
businesses and the way this worked it
relied on uh tenants underutilizing
their resources so you know you wouldn't
have a submachine in there but you'd
have a folder with permissions that you
could use um and so you would really
share the cost and this was very very
cheap um but you were limited to
whatever that machine could do and you
were very restricted in terms of the
functionality you had and there was just
poor isolation meaning that you know if
one person decided to utilize a server
more they could hang up all the all the
websites on that single server then came
along Cloud hosting and the idea is that
you have um multiple physical machines
that act as one system so this is
distributed computing and so the system
is abstracted into multiple cloud
services and the idea is that you
basically get the advantages of a lot of
the things above so it's flexible you
can just add more servers um it's
scalable it's very secure because you
get that uh virtual isol Iz ation you
get it extremely at a low cost because
you're sharing that cost with the users
where in the shared hosting it might be
hundreds of businesses we're looking at
thousands of businesses and it was also
highly configurable because it was a
full virtual machine now uh Cloud
actually uh still includes all of these
types of Hosting they haven't gone away
uh but it's just the idea that you now
have more of a selection for your use
case uh but hopefully that gives you an
idea what cloud hosting looks like and
it really has to come down to
distributed computing okay
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at common cloud
services so a cloud provider can have
hundreds of cloud services are grouped
uh into various types of services and
the four most common types of cloud
services for infrastructure as a service
uh and we'll talk about what that is
later on uh would be compute so this is
where you have a virtual computer that
can run applications programs and C uh
code then you have storage so this is
where you would have uh virtual hard
drives that you could store files uh
then you'd have virtual networking
because you have these computers and
storage so you need to uh put them in
some kind of virtual Network and then
you have databases so uh just imagine um
a database that is running in the cloud
or uh if you're not familiar with
databases just imagine that it's excel
in the cloud but it Powers your web apps
uh and one thing I want you to know
about the term cloud computing is that
you even though it says Computing in the
word uh at this point we just use it as
a catall term so it could refer to all
of these categories so when I say cloud
computing I could be referring to
compute network storage and databases
but you can also say cloud storage Cloud
compute Cloud databases Cloud networking
and people will know what you
[Music]
mean hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at what is
Microsoft so you've probably seen this
logo before and and Microsoft is an
American multinational computer
technology corporation headquartered in
Redmond uh Washington and Microsoft
makes software phones tablets game
consoles cloud services which is uh what
we care about here today and they even
have a search engine uh and we're not
just limited to that list they have tons
of stuff but Microsoft is best known for
uh their oper operating system called
windows and they've been around since
the
1970s so uh they've been around for
quite a while in the tech sphere uh so
now that leads us to the question is
what is azure so Azure is what Microsoft
calls their cloud provider Service uh
and so it's called Microsoft Azure or we
commonly refer to it as just Azure uh
and so here is the logo for it if you're
wondering what is the name behind the
service it means bright blue color of
the cloudless sky so sure that's great
um and so uh you'll hear me say cloud
service provider frequently with
throughout this course and it is
abbreviated to CSP but that's what Azure
is it is a cloud service provider so
there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the benefits
of cloud computing so what are the
benefits well we have a big list here
for you starting with cost Effectiveness
so you pay for what you consume there is
no upfront cost you pay as you go also
abbreviated as P YG uh and you're
sharing the cost with thousands of
customers so that's how you're getting
that uh that low low cost another
benefit is that uh you can go Global so
launch workloads anywhere in the world
just choose your region um and uh you
are now in the global market uh another
benefit is uh the the cloud is secure so
Cloud providers take care of the
physical security and cloud services can
be secur by default or you have the
ability to configure access down to the
granular level so you have a lot of
security controls that you would have
that you you would normally not have or
you'd have to build out on pram
now the cloud is also known for being
reliable so you can have data backups
disaster recovery and data replication
and fault tolerance uh the cloud is also
scalable you can increase or decrease
your resources and services based on the
demand uh the cloud is also elastic so
you can automate scaling during spikes
and and drop the demand when uh there is
no longer the demand for that stuff uh
and it's also current so the underlying
Hardware in manage software is patch
upgraded and replaced by the cloud
provider without interruption to you uh
and I mean the last one there is cases
of interruption but generally fewer
interruptions than you would have on
Prem so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the different
types of cloud computing and we have
this nice pyramid on the left hand side
to help us understand um how each type
builds off the other starting at the top
of our pyramid we have software as a
service also known as SAS and this is a
product that is run and managed by the
service provider you don't worry about
how the service is maintained and it
just works and remains available so you
might not be aware of this but you
probably already are using a SAS product
so examples of that could be Salesforce
or Gmail or Office
365 so those are those are things that
would be considered SAS and these are
really for customers so it's just you
wanting to use uh software um like
General software on your computer but in
the cloud
the next category we have is platform as
a service abbreviated as pass and so
here we focus on um development and
management of your applications uh and
so you don't worry about provisioning
configuring or understanding the
hardware or Os and this is really for
people that are building apps but they
don't but they don't think about any of
the infrastructure underneath services
like this would be elastic beanock on
AWS or Roku which is very popular
amongst um Junior developers which is a
thirdparty service um for launching web
apps and then you have uh the Google app
engine so those are three examples there
and these are really for developers so
platform of service makes it easy for
developers to uh build apps on the cloud
without worrying about all the stuff
underneath and at the bottom we have
infrastructure as a service
IAS um and this is the basic building
blocks of cloud it so provide access to
networking features computers and data
storage space don't worry about the
about it staff data centers and hardware
and this is the true Focus focus of our
course here is focusing on this layer
but um the thing is again on this
pyramid is that I um the infrastructure
service can have platform as a service
and software as service on top of it and
so examples of infrastructure service
would be Microsoft Azure uh AWS or even
Oracle cloud and so this is really
intended for
administrators um so that is the three
types of cloud computing and there you
[Music]
go hey this is this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we were looking at the
types of cloud computing responsibility
so we saw the three categories there um
but we don't really understand what it
is that we're responsible for and what
is the cloud service provider
responsible for so let's uh lay out our
categories and we're going to include on
premise uh into this because technically
on- premise could be uh a private cloud
and should be in the category here so we
have on premise infrastructure is a
service platform is a service and
software is a service so when we're
looking at
applications um it's going to be the
customers's responsibility um for on
pram uh infrastructure pass but when we
have software of service um the cloud
service provider is responsible for that
when looking at the data level it's
going to be the same for software as of
service uh the cloud service provider is
going to be uh responsible but the for
the rest it's going to be the customer
and then on the next level for the
runtime uh it's going to be uh
responsible on the cloud service
provider for the platform is a service
and software is a service for middleware
it's going to be the same for the OS
like the operating system that is
running on the service it's going to be
the same then when we get to
virtualization now it's uh the uh
virtualization is responsible um with
the cloud service provider and above and
then for storage it's or sorry servers
it's the same uh for storage it's the
same and for networking it's the same so
you can see that on premise you're
responsible for everything and the the
farther we move up the types of cloud
computing the less respons
responsibility you
[Music]
have hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we were looking at azure's
deployment models and the first model
we're going to talk about is public
cloud and that's where everything is
built on the cloud service provider
you're not using anything on Prem or in
your own data centers everything is
running within Azure uh and generally
this is known as Cloud native um but for
some reason Azure calls it public Cloud
so that's what we're going to use in the
terminology here and so here I have an
architectural diagram where we have a
network uh on Azure and within that
Network we have a virtual machine
running and a database running so that
would be an example of public Cloud then
we have private cloud and so this is
where everything is built on the
company's data centers also known as on
premise because it's within the premises
of the organization uh like their
physical location and uh it could an
organiz organization could technically
be operating their own cloud
but it would be private cloud and they
could be running some open-source Cloud
software that mimics what um Azure would
do such as open stack so it looks very
similar uh but you just uh put an open
stack in there and it's running a
virtual machine or a server and it's
also running a database and the last on
our list here is hybrid so with hybrid
uh you are using both on premise and the
cloud service provider and they're
connected together and so there's a lot
of different networking services that
you can use that will facilitate the
connection between the two uh in this
case we're using express route Express
rout is a dedicated uh connection it's
like having a fiber optic Line running
from your on premise data center to the
Azure Network so just one of the ways
you can connect and if we wanted to
understand like the pros and cons I have
this nice little table here we'll just
quickly go through it so if you're using
public uh Cloud uh it's more cost
effective security um it it's uh it sced
controls are stronger by default but
some people might not find the cloud
will meet all their security
requirements because of government and
Regulatory um uh regulatory reasons not
because the the cloud is not secure but
it's just those uh those policies uh for
level of configuration it's going to be
limited based on what the cloud service
provider exposes to you um still there's
a lot of configuration there it's just
that if you're if you have your own
servers uh you obviously can do anything
and everything with them for technical
knowledge you don't need to have as much
in-depth knowledge of the underlying
infrastructure because you're not
physically setting up
uh or that networking everything else
now coming down to private Cloud private
cloud is the most expensive option on
our list um so you're going to be paying
uh a lot of money there uh for security
uh there is no guarantee that is 100%
secure because you just don't have the
same kind of visibility that you would
have with a cloud service provider with
all those dashboards it's just so hard
to build out all that software but you
could meet your security compliance
requirements um depending on your
situation U but this is becoming uh less
and less as um more governments and
larger organizations move over to the
cloud uh you can configure
infrastructure exactly how you like
because you literally have uh bought the
hardware and can do anything you want
with it uh and the technical knowledge
you'll have to have a serious amount of
technical knowledge you might even have
a really hard time finding the resources
to uh to maintain all that stuff then uh
down below we have the hybrid model so
this could be more cost- effective based
on uh what you offload to the cloud and
also the cost of actually moving data
back and forth uh for security uh you
know you have more to secure but uh
technically uh some things are easier to
secure on the cloud than it is in uh
private so maybe you have a boost in
security you're going to get the best of
both worlds in terms of configuration uh
and for technical knowledge you're going
to need to know both the cloud and and
uh like how to set things up on premise
so that's the most work there and just
one more deployment model here I just
want to talk about cross Cloud this
isn't something that is listed on the
actual exam but it's something that you
should understand and know and so cross
cloud is when you're using multiple
Cloud providers sometimes people refer
this as multicloud or hybrid cloud and
so I just have an example here so um uh
there's a service called Azure Arc and
what Azure Arc does it extends your
control plane so you can run um
containers kubernetes containers on
different platforms and so you could
have AWS on the left hand side with eks
and gcp kubernetes engine and so you can
be running virtual machines and they're
all treated like they're on the same
network so cross cloud is coming uh very
popular with extremely large
organizations where they they have uh
very unique requirements but I I
definitely want you to know what that is
because it just gets left out uh and
it's definitely something that is uh
part of the industry so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the concept of
total cost of ownership tcco so what is
the difference between on premise so
having your own data centers and then
using Azure and you'll notice above it
it says KAC and Opex we're going to talk
about that in the next slide but for the
time for the time being we're going to
focus on the total cost of ownership so
to really make sense of this uh I always
use this graphic here uh and if you're
wondering what that is those are
icebergs people sometimes think they
look like teeth and so just to make this
drawing a little bit more clear I've
added some penguins and a whale so
there's no mistaking it and the reason
we're using this as a representation is
because we have the top of the iceberg
which are the cloths that we're
generally concerned about but then we
have those hidden cloths those CLS that
we're not really think about that is
underneath the water and if you know
icebergs they can be really big
underneath you don't know so um on the
left hand side the cost that we
generally think of is the software
license fees uh and then uh for the
cloud service provider we look at the
subscription fees and so when you're
comparing these two sometimes the
subscription fees can cost more than the
software license fees so you'd think
well we should really just use uh um on
Prem because it's more cost effective
but when we Tak in the total cost of
ownership all the costs involved we're
going to see a very different picture so
on the left hand side if you uh are on
premise you have to deal with the
implementation the configuration and the
training but you also have to deal with
the physical security of your building
you have to pay for the hardware you
have to pay for the IT personnel you
have to uh deal with maintenance now on
the right hand side on the cloud you
still have to do implementation and
configuration and training but that's
about it so um there's a big difference
in terms of what you have to do and you
might ask okay well what is the amount
of savings well generally people find
that when they move from on Prem to the
cloud they save
75% that's a lot of money okay 75% of
what you generally would spend and so
now all this stuff on the left- hand
side is now azure's responsibility you
don't take care of those anymore Azure
is going to take care of it for you so
that's total cost of
[Music]
ownership hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we are looking at Capital
versus operational expenditure so on the
Le hand side we have capex so Capital
expenditures on the right hand side we
have operational expenditures Opex and
so looking on the left- hand side
capital expenditure is spending money
upfront on physical infrastructure so
deducting the expenses from your tax
bill over time a lot of companies larger
companies are used to dealing with
capital expenses and they know how to
work their tax bill and so that's why a
lot of people are afraid to move over
the cloud because they're used to this
uh this this way of operating but let's
talk about some of the things that would
be considered a capital expanse so again
it's anything that's physical and then
you're buying it with money UPF front so
computers so that would be your server
costs if you were to buy hard drives
that' be your storage cost if you bought
routers cables and switches for your
network if you were uh purchasing things
for backup and archive costs if you had
disaster recovery so like an un
uninterruptible power supply would be an
example of that uh you have your data
center cost so that's your rent cooling
physical security your technical
personnel so you're hiring people to to
do things for you and so with capital
expenses you have to guess upfront what
you plan to spend um now let's look at
operational expenditure so operational
expenditure is the cost Associated when
an on-premise data center has put has
shifted that cost of the service
provider so here in this case it's the
cloud service provider and the customer
only has to be concerned with
nonphysical costs so what's examples of
opec's cost well leasing software and
customizing features training employ
emplo in cloud services paying for cloud
support um building based on the cloud
metrics so compute usage and storage
usage uh and the advantage here is that
with operational expenses you can try a
product or service without investing
equipment so we have flexibility of uh
investment and we also from the previous
slide we saw that we have a huge
reduction cost so there's two reasons
really good reasons to use the
[Music]
cloud let's take a look at Cloud
architecture terminologies before we do
let's talk about some of the roles that
are around uh doing Cloud architecture
so the first is Solutions architect this
is a role in a technical organization
that Architects a technical solution
using multiple systems via researching
documentation and experimentation and
then you have the cloud architect this
is a Solutions architect that is focused
solely on architecting Technical
Solutions using cloud services
understand that in the uh actual
Marketplace a lot of times Solutions
architect is used to describe both a
cloud architect and a Solutions
architect and you know these are going
to highly vary based on your locality
and how companies want to use these
terms but this is just me broadly
defining them here so just don't take
them as a perfect word in terms of what
they're representing so a cloud
architect needs to understand the
following terms and factors uh and
Factor them into their designed
architecture based on the business
requirements so we have the idea of
availability your ability to ensure
service remains available scalability
your ability to grow rapidly or
unimpeded elasticity your ability to
shrink and grow to meet the demand fault
tolerance your ability to prevent a
failure Disaster Recovery your ability
to recover from a failure and there are
a couple other things that uh that
should be considered they're not
terminologies but they're definitely
important to a Solutions architector
Cloud architect and uh these are things
you always need to consider uh as well
and this is just me talking to my
Solutions architect friends where
they'll always ask me these two
questions after presentation they'll say
how secure is the solution and how much
is this going to cost all right and so
for the terminologies up here we're
going to Define these right away and
we're going to figure these out
throughout the course we have two giant
sections just on cost and security alone
uh so there we
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the concept of
high availability so this is your
ability for your service to remain
available by ensuring there is no single
point of failure or ensure a certain
level of performance so here I have a
technical architectural diagram that is
describing High availability so the idea
behind this is that if you have a server
which runs your web application if you
were to run redundant versions of your
server if anything happened to a single
server traffic could always be red to
those other servers and that way your
service would remain available now
having multiple servers is great but
even what's better is having multiple
servers in multiple data centers because
something could happen to a data center
it could become unavailable of a
networking issue so by being able to
Route traffic or uh that way you're
going to remain highly available and and
uh running a workload across multiple
availability zones and availability
zones is what Azure calls their data
centers ensures that if one or two data
center becomes unavailable your service
will remain available very very common
to run uh at least three servers across
three data centers now how would you
distribute the traffic or manage the
traffic to all three and that's where an
Azure load bouncer comes into play that
green triangle with the arrows that is
the representation of a load bouncer so
load balcer allows you to evenly
distribute traffic to multiple servers
in one or more data center and if a data
center or server becomes unavailable so
unhealthy the load balancer will rote
the traffic to only available data
centers with servers so there you go
that is high
[Music]
availability hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam Pro and we are looking at the
concept of high scalability and this is
your ability to increase your capacity
based on the increasing demand of
traffic memory and computing power if
you are a growing company you're going
to have to scale up you're going to have
to get bigger and better servers but the
uh there are different types of scaling
and the first type is vertical scaling
this is the the the most obvious one
people are going to think of and it's
called scaling up and what we do is we
just upgrade to bigger servers we need
bigger hard drives faster computers
that's vertical scaling but there's
another kind of kind of scaling called
horizontal scaling and horizontal
scaling is is described as scaling out
and what you're doing is you're just
adding additional servers because we saw
with the high availability we have a
load balcer we can distribute traffic to
multiple servers and three servers can
equal the same thing as one big server
so um horizontal scaling is when we add
more servers of the same
[Music]
size hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're looking at the concept of
High elasticity and this is your ability
to automatically increase or decrease
Your Capacity based on this the current
uh demand of traffic memory and
computing power so this sounds a lot
like high scalability but the key
difference is that it's automatic and
you can decrease the demand not just
increase it and so the way we would do
that is that we would have a virtual uh
virtual machine or server and if we
needed more servers we would add more
servers and if we need less servers we
would remove less servers and so this is
going to be accomplished using
horizontal scaling so when we say we're
scaling out this means we're adding more
servers of the same size when we're
scaling in this means we're removing
more servers of the same size and
generally you're not going to use
vertical scaling for high elasticity
it's just extremely difficult to um uh
uh to vertically scale because if you H
if you have to increase let's say your
storage Drive um and then you decrease
it you could lose data so it's not a
good idea or or even feasible to do
vertical scaling with high elasticity
now how would you accomplish uh being
elastic on Azure uh well You' use
azure's VM scale set so scale sets
automatically increase or decrease in
the response to demand uh uh b or based
on a defined schedule and we'll talk
about those in Greater detail later in
this course uh and then we have SQL
Server uh or server stretch database
these dynamically stretch warm and cold
trans transactional data from Microsoft
SQL Server 2016 to Microsoft Azure not
something we're going to cover but it's
generally the same concept that skill
sets uh do so there you go that's high
[Music]
elasticity hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we're looking at the
concept of being highly fa tolerant and
this is your ability for your service to
ensure there is no single point of
failure preventing the chance of failure
so when we looked at high availability
we had also said that it was no point of
failure but when we really talk about
that we're really talking about being
highly fault tolerant because there is
the word failure in the word and that is
what being fa tolerant is and so how do
we prevent failure well we use the
concept of failovers so failovers is
when you have a plan to shift traffic to
a redundant system in the case a primary
system fails and so I have a Graphic
here that represents um a primary
database failing over to a secondary
database and I have a bit of a
description here so the idea is that we
have um a copy of our production
database we're going to call that a
secondary system uh and the idea here is
that every time something is ritten to
our primary database it's going to be
synced so it's going to be sent over to
our secondary database so it's up to
date with the latest database and then
if uh the primary database uh happens to
fail for whatever reason whether it's
Hardware or otherwise something's going
to detect that there's something wrong
with the primary and it's going to fail
over to the secondary and the secondary
is going to be promoted to being the
primary instance and the key thing to
understand is that that that secondary
is standby it's not in actual use uh
it's only in use when the failover
occurs so what would you use an Azure to
uh build out a highly fa tolerant system
that's where aure traffic manager comes
into play um so with this uh and this
works with a DNS level um and so the
idea here is that you can uh fail over
from a primary system of the DNS level
to a standby this is really great if you
have Regional failures you could
probably also use a load balancer but
this is the case that I'm showing here
but there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the concept of
high durability so this is your ability
to recover from a disaster and to
prevent the loss of data um so this
could be solution that recover from a
disaster is known as Disaster Recovery
Dr uh and so I'm just going to ask you a
bunch of questions to help you think
about how how to be highly durable so
one question would be like do you have a
backup so do you have a backup in place
how fast can you restore your backup
does your backup still work how how do
you ensure Uh current live data is not
corrupt so that is the concept of high
durability there's a variety of services
to implement it so it's not just a
single service um but there you go that
is is the full list of cloud
architecture
[Music]
terminologies so to understand Disaster
Recovery we need to know more about uh
things around it like business
continuity plans BCPS and RTO and rpos
so a BCP is a document that outlines how
a business will continue operating
during an unplanned disruption in
services so it's basically the plan that
you're going to execute uh if that
happens and so here we have a disaster
and you can see that there's a chance of
data loss and downtime and these two um
uh factors as RPO and RTO are going to
define the length of these durations so
recovery Point objective is the maximum
acceptable amount of data loss after an
unplanned data loss incident Express
this amount of time so how much data are
you willing to lose and then recovery
time objective so the maximum amount of
downtime your business can tolerate
without inuring a significant financial
loss so how much time you're willing to
go go down okay so those are the two
there and now let's go take a look at
the disaster recovery options that we
can use to define in our our
[Music]
BCP so now let's take a look at our
disaster recovery options uh and based
on what you choose they're going to be a
trade of cost versus time to recover
based on the rpos your RTO of course and
so sometimes this is rep represented
vertically like a a thermostat or you
can do it horizontally here um both
valid ways of displaying this
information but I just have it
horizontally here today and so we have
low or high or you could say um even
though I don't have it written here this
could be cold or this could be hot okay
so um on the left hand side we got
backup and restore pilot light warm
standby multiactive sight notice we're
using the like the words like pilot
light warm things that are relating to
temperature so again cold and hot all
right so let's just walk through what
each of these things as conceptually do
uh in terms of architecture so when
you're doing a backup and restore you're
back you basically back up your data and
uh at the time of Disaster Recovery
you're just going to restore it to New
infrastructure uh for a pilot light the
data is replicated to another region
with the minimal Services running to
keep on replicating that data and so you
might have some core Services running a
warm standby is a scaled down copy of
your infrastructure so you basically
have everything that you would
absolutely need to run an application
but the idea is it's not at scale and so
at any time when there's an incident
you're going to scale up to the capacity
that you need and then you have
multi-site active active where you you
have a scaled up copy of your
infrastructure in another region so
basically everything you have
identically in another region and so in
terms of the rpos and the rtos for back
and restore you're looking at hours uh
with the pilot light you're looking at
10 minutes with a warm standby you're
looking at minutes and multi sight uh
active active you're looking at uh real
time so you know hopefully that gives
you an idea of you know the the
difference in terms of scale but let's
just look at more detail so for a backup
and restore this is for low priority use
cases restore data after events deploy
resources after an event and it's very
cost effective uh for pilot light this
is where you have less stringent RTO and
rpos so you're going to be just running
your core Services uh you're going to
start and scale resources after the
event and this is a little bit more
expensive this is uh very good for warm
standby is good for business critical
services so you scale resources after
the event
uh and it's uh almost very it's very
it's costly but it's not as expensive as
a multi-site active active so you get
zero down time near zero loss uh you
have it's great for Mission critical
services and it's just as expensive as
your original uh infrastructure so
you're basically doubling the cost there
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the evolution
of computing and this is going to really
help you to understand the different
layers of compute uh and so we're going
to start from uh on the left hand side
to dedicated and work our way all the
way to functions so what I want you to
know is that uh when we're talking about
dedicated this is a physical server
wholly utilized by a single customer and
so the idea is that this customer has
purchased uh this dedicated piece of
Hardware um but the thing with this is
that you have to guess your capacity So
when you buy it it's like a capital cost
or you're purchasing uh uh for for like
the whole like you have to plan how
you're going to fully utilize it so
you're going to overpay uh and you're
going to have underutilized servers and
the reason why is that when you first
launch your app it might be small and
then you're expected to grow into that
space But you're just not using that
space until you grow into it so it's
considered wasted um if you want to
upgrade Beyond Your Capacity this is
going to be slow and expensive you
literally would have to buy a new server
that's larger and then move everything
over you're going to be limited by your
operating system so whatever operating
system is installed uh that's what
you're going to have uh you're going to
have multiple apps uh if you do install
multiple apps onto a dedicated server
you might have conflicts in resource
sharing but generally it's recommended
to only have a single primary
application on a dedicated server uh you
are going to have a guarantee of
security privacy and full utility of the
underlying resources because that is
what that's the whole purpose of having
a dedicated server is sometimes
dedicated servers where you have full
control of everything is called bare
metal and that's basically mimics what
it was like to have a server on Primus
or back in the day and they still exist
so that is dedicated we'll move on to
VMS so now we're moving on to Virtual
machines also known as VMS and so the
idea here is that if you had a physical
server and you had the capability of
running virtual machines that's like
running a machine within a machine and
so now you're able to run multiple
applications on a single machine uh the
technology that's used to actually run
VMS is known as hypervisor there there
are some other kinds but the ones we
need to know uh is hypervisor so just
know that that's the software that makes
virtual machines work um you are now
sharing the physical server with
multiple customers that is generally a
good thing because you are paying a
fraction of the server cost you don't
have to buy that server outright um you
are still going to be uh uh overpaying
for under underutilized uh uh the
underutilization of a virtual machine
because it still has an issue of wasted
space because you have to choose a
particular size of virtual machine it's
not going to be perfectly fit for your
application uh you are going to be
limited by your guest operating system
so whatever OS that you've chosen that's
what you get um uh so that's that's what
you have there if you want to run
multiple apps on a single virtual
machine they can still result in
Conflict uh resource sharing but now uh
customers that are isolated from you
aren't going to conflict with you so you
can run you could run uh if you had
three apps you could run them as three
virtual machines so you're not going to
have that issue but if they're on the
same VM you still have that issue so
there you go that is virtual machines
and we'll move on to two
containers hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we are looking at the
concept of containers and so this takes
it a step further where we have virtual
machines and we're running multiple
containers so we're even uh we're
further subdividing the way that we uh
run our applications and the technology
that is used to uh run a containers with
within a VM or on a physical server is
called dock Docker Damon if you're using
Docker for containerization that's the
most common in one um but that's going
to let you run multiple containers and
you can maximize the the uh the utility
of the available capacity uh so this is
extremely more cost effective right so
um uh that available space is is always
there for you to launch more servers
within or you can or you can expand uh
the usage for your app to take up that
available space your containers share
the same underlying OS so the containers
are more efficient than multiple VMS um
but the great thing is is that you can
have different uh os's so the idea is
that each container can technically be
running a different uh OS and so now you
have a lot more flexibility it doesn't
seem like you could improve upon this
further but we will when we move over to
function so now we're going to take a
look at the evolution of computing for
functions and I I bet you didn't believe
it but we subdivided it even further and
so uh we've taken our applications that
we're running container and we broke up
the apps into little pieces of code
called functions and now we even have
more uh or or better utility of our
compute so we have a manage a VM running
managed containers so we don't have to
worry about the containers and configure
them ourselves functions are usually
taken care of this is known as seress
compute because you don't set up
anything you just put your code online
and it just works you might choose the
memory and the duration that you need to
utilize and that's all you pay for
you're only responsible for your codee
and data and nothing else and it's
extremely extremely cost effective right
because you are just paying for that
individual function to run and all that
un underutilized space is is the the the
problem of the cloud service provider
it's not your issue the only downside is
that um there is a concept called cold
starts meaning that when you launch a
function or or serverless or a
serverless code It generally has to
provision a server because the the the
cloud service provider doesn't want to
be running servers when they don't they
don't uh they aren't being utilized so
you might experience a cold start where
you're waiting for a server to start
before your code will execute but
there's definitely ways around that so
there you go that is the evolution of
[Music]
compute hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we are looking at uh
regions and geographies uh for Azure so
a region is a grouping of multiple data
centers and for um Azure they call their
data centers availability zones Azure
has 58 regions available across 140
countries one thing Azure likes to
promote is that they have the most
regions out of all uh cloud service
providers uh then we have something what
we call a geography so geography is a
discrete Market of two or more regions
that preserve data residency and
compliance boundaries and the
geographies that are available for Azure
uh we have the United States then
there's Azure government us this is a
geography that's only for the US
government uh so regular citizens cannot
use it then you have Canada that's where
I'm from Brazil and Mexico and I just
want to emphasize that data residency
and compliance boundaries for geography
and I just want to give you an example
so imagine you live in Canada and you uh
and you work for a Canadian company you
want to guarantee that the data will
remain within Canada for whatever
government regul regulatory reasons so
then you'd want to use the canidate
Azure geography because because that
data would never leave Canadian soil um
so that's the case there and I just want
to give you kind of a a visual example
so on the Le hand side we have two
regions we have us East one and we have
the Europe Norway east region and in
those regions I'm I'm not showing it
here because I don't want to make it too
complicated but there would be
availability zones and we could launch
resources so we have some servers
virtual machines those are the images
you see within the regions and generally
the way uh regions work in Azure is that
when you go to launch uh a resource you
choose the region at that time of
creation so if you're launching a
virtual machine it's going to give you
an option to choose a region and you
just choose from that list uh so yeah
there you go so I just made my way over
to Azure so I just typed in um Azure
Global infrastructure because I just
wanted to show you the big map of all
the regions um and uh where Azure is
available all throughout the world
because sometimes it's nice to look here
so we can see we have stuff down in
Australia we have um uh regions in
Africa we have a region in South America
we have a lot in North America we have a
lot in uh Western Europe uh and then we
have some in um Asia here so we have
Japan China all over the place so you
know if if you want to look a little bit
more into that um there's a lot of good
information here on the global
infrastructure pages but that's about it
I just wanted to show you that world
map
[Music]
so now we're looking at paired regions
so each region is paired with another
region 300 miles away and the reason why
Azure does this is so that if one region
is being updated uh then the other one
is still available meaning that if
you're running if you're planning to
make sure that you never have uh
downtime you can uh put your resources
in that paired region uh and you're
going to have higher availability uh so
some Azure services rely on paired
regions for disaster recovery so when
you turn those services on they're
automatically going to launch in that
paired region uh one Service uh which
would help you uh leverage your paired
region would be a service called Azure
well it's a feature of storage but it's
called Azure Geo redundant storage so it
replicate your data to secondary region
automatically ensuring that the data is
durable even in the event the primary
region is isn't recoverable and just to
give you an example of a paired region
uh so let's say we're talking about
Canada so with Canada uh you'd have uh
um Canada Central and then its paired
region is Canada east for North America
and when we say North America we're
really talking about the United States
uh it's East US region paired with the
West us region and then for Germany you
have Germany Central and ger uh Germany
Northeast so it gives you an idea how
far away they are 300 miles that's quite
a distance um but there you
go
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at Region types and
service availability for Azure and what
I want you to know about uh service
availability uh regarding regions is
that not all cloud services are
available in every single region and
there's infrastructure reasons as to why
and there's compliance reasons as to why
so Azure um has two types of regions
they have recommended regions these are
regions that provide the broadest range
of service capabilities um and what that
means is that uh the majority of
services are going to be available in
this region uh and this recommended
region is designed to support
availability zones then you have
alternate regions uh and these are
regions that extends azure's footprint
within a data residency boundary where a
recommended region also exists but
they're not designed to support
availability zones that doesn't mean you
can't launch resources within them it
just means that when you go to launch of
resource you're not going to choose an
availability Zone uh and these regions
are labeled as other when you're in the
Azure portal now let's talk about
General availability so General
availability abbreviated to GA is when a
service is considered ready to be used
publicly by everyone so if you have a a
service or product and it was in beta
and now you're ready to sell to people
that means that it's ga uh uh but it's
but just because it's ready to sell it
there's also the the conversation around
whether it's actually available to use
and that's going to be determined based
on the category that the Azure cloud
service is in so Azure categorizes uh
three different types of availability
for services and the first one is
foundational so a cloud service that is
foundational is going to be available
immediately in a recommended and
Alternate regions when it goes GA or at
least in 5 12 months of the time that it
was announced then you have mainstream
so these are um cloud services that will
become immediately available in a
recommended region or in 12 months when
it goes GA um but for for the alternate
region uh it may become available based
on the customer demand and then the last
one is specialized so cloud services
that in this category will become
available in in recommended or alternate
regions based on customer demand so
hopefully that clears up uh service
availability and region
[Music]
types hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at special
regions for Azure so Azure has
specialized regions to meet compliance
are legal reasons because they might
want they might want to work with
specific governments of uh and to meet
those requirements they basically give
them their own region and so the First
on our list is the us and we have three
regions that we know about so we have
the US Department of Defense Central the
US government of Virginia region the US
government of Iowa region and then we
have an additional three that we just
don't know about it because they're in
Secret locations so maybe they're for
Area 51 we don't know um and so the
reason why they have these special
regions is that if you just want to do
business with the government they need
these kind of regulations um then on the
other side we have China and so they
have a region in China East and China
North uh and these regions are available
through a unique partnership between
Microsoft and 21 vonet uh and so
Microsoft does not directly maintain
these data centers but they work with uh
21 vonet to give you uh accessibility to
these regions um and probably to operate
these regions you'd probably be um a
citizen of these countries and you'd
also be an employee of the government so
it's not going to be for a citizens to
use but there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at availability
zones for Azure and so availability
zones abbreviated to uh short for AZ and
you'll hear me using that abbreviation a
lot in this course and you should learn
to remember that as well is a physical
location made up of one or more Data
Center and so a data center is a secured
building that contains hundreds of
thousands of computers and if you want a
little visual uh here is uh the inside
of a data center um and there's a
technician working on a rack of servers
and there's a dog uh in the data center
uh you should definitely never have a
dog in your data center you'll probably
hear me refer to availab availability
zones as a data center because it's the
easiest way to think of it but it
actually can be more than one data
center now a region will generally
contain three available IL zones I say
generally here because there are cases
where there are less than three but
there's actually very specific reasons
as to having exactly three availability
zones data centers within a region will
be isolate from each other so they'll be
in different buildings but they will be
close enough to provide low latency uh
and that load latency would probably be
in the sub milliseconds I don't know
what it is for Azure but that's
generally uh how it would be designed
because you want it to feel like you're
uh it's on uh the same
network um it's common practice to run
workloads in at least 3 A's and that's
why I I was saying that earlier that's
important to ensure Services remain
available in the case one or two data
centers fail fail and this is called
high availability and we'll definitely
cover this concept again in this course
just to give you a bit of a visual on
the Le hand side what we have is a
region called us East one and we have
multiple availability zones um uh Azure
just labels them one two and three and
so when you go to launcher resource if
you look on the right hand side you
choose your region so we are choosing us
uh East us then we're saying we're going
to use availability Zone and then we
choose which one we want to launch it
into so if we if we choose two it's
going to go into availability Zone 2
that doesn't mean we're going to launch
two instances it just means availability
Zone 2 so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at AZ supported
regions for Azure and so not every
region has support for availability
zones and we touched on this in the
region section but we'll touch on it
here again again so uh we know that
there are regions called alternate
others and these do not have
availability zones whatsoever then you
have recommended regions and these are
supposed to have 3 azs the reason why
they might not have them is because it's
a newer region and Azure is promising to
add more regions within 12 months or
whatever time period that they say uh
but generally what you want to do is
when you have um Cloud resources you
want to launch them where they have at
least three azs so which regions have
three azs and that is Central Us East Us
2 West us2 West Europe France Central
North uh uh Northern uh Europe uh
southeast Asia so that is where you
generally want to run your workloads now
what does it look like when uh you try
to go launch a resource um and they and
you choose a region that doesn't have an
availability Zone what's that going to
look like well it's going to look like
this so you're going to availability
zone is going to be blanked out and
you'll have to choose no infrastructure
uh redundancy required and so that would
be the example for Brazil South where
it's just there are there is a single AZ
but it's described as not having a so
you just don't choose it in the
interface so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at fault and
update domains so an availability Zone
uh in an Azure region is a combination
of a fault domain and an update domain
so a fault domain is a logical grouping
of Hardware to avoid a single point of
failure within an a uh and so basically
it's a group of virtual machines that
share a common power source and network
switch um the reason why Azure does this
is that so if part of the data center
fails then other servers won't be taken
down with it so let's say there's a fire
within the data center in one particular
region it won't affect other Hardware
that is running then you have update
domains and so update domains is when
Azure needs to apply updates to the
underlying hardware and software um but
the thing is is that because Azure is
updating them it takes these machines
offline so the idea is that if you run
your workloads in um another uh like
another domain in the update domain not
neither domain will be updated at the
exact same time and that way you won't
have downtime because of
updates and so the way fault domains and
update domains work is that you use
availability sets so availability sets
is a logical grouping that you can use
an Azure to ensure that your VMS you
place in the availability set are in
different fault update domains to avoid
down time and just to really help with
that visual uh here um what I'm going to
do is just show you this here so each
virtual machine and availability set is
assigned a fault domain and an update
domain and so what you're looking at
here is uh you see those gray boxes
those are racks uh in your data center
aack is just like it it's like a closet
for um servers and all those servers sit
on top of each other and so each of
those servers um uh uh in that is where
your virtual machine might be deployed
so if you are deployed if you have a
server and it's deployed in Fault domain
zero and fault domain one it could be in
any of the the the servers on that rack
uh but then update domains you just
might have very particular servers um in
that rack that are those update domains
so hopefully that makes that a bit clear
I know it's a little bit confusing but
just remember the Conant behind fault
domains and update domains and just to
give you a visual of what it would look
like in the Azure portal uh if you go
ahead and create availability set you
would name it so here I call it
production and you would choose theault
domains and you would choose the update
domains and so I believe that what
you're doing there is that you're
choosing the amount of domains that you
want uh your your virtual machines to be
distributed
across and I keep on saying virtual
machine that's your server okay so if
you say um two fault domains that that
means that when you launch two servers
and you put them into that availability
set they're going to be across two fault
uh two different fault domains and if
you launch Five
servers um and your update domains is at
five that means it's going to be across
five different uh servers that are
isolated from each other so hopefully
that makes sense but that's fault and
update domains so I quickly just wanted
to show you the fault and update domains
that are in uh Azure here so the idea is
if you're launching a virtual machine uh
and you want to uh control the
availability set what you can do is you
can go um to down to here where we have
availability options we're going to drop
it down and choose availability set and
then we don't have an availability set
so I'm going to go ahead and create one
if I just click there and so when we
create a set we can say you know uh
production
set and so we have these two uh these
two um uh dialogues here and so what
what it is is when you say there's three
fault domains that means that if you
were to launch three VMS and you put
them all into this uh availability set
it'll be spread across three different
racks so that if a rack goes out um two
other racks are operational and so your
service will remain available and then
down below it's the same thing on a rack
there might be multiple machines and
certain machines um uh will will be will
be scheduled for updates but they won't
all be updated at the same time so if
you're saying this you'll say spread it
across five machines uh and that's all
there really is to it so I just wanted
to show you where that was uh when you
actually launch it for a virtual
[Music]
machine hey everyone it's Andrew Brown
and welcome to another follow along and
probably the most important one which is
how to create your Azure account so what
I did is I typed into Google uh Azure uh
Microsoft portal and so it brought me to
here um this page might look a little
bit different it really just depends on
where you uh land in but a lot of times
they make it very easy by having this
try aure for free getting started free
account so just find one of the ways in
they probably go all to the same place
so I'm going to go ahead and click Start
free I'm going to get out of the way uh
so that we can do this now um I already
have an existing uh Microsoft account
that's what you need in order to access
Azure so I'm going to go here and say
sign in with another account I'm going
to create another account I go ahead and
create one of course you probably
already have an account or if you don't
you can go ahead and start typing one in
so I'm going to need an alternate email
to utilize for this so just give me a
moment okay so I was just thinking about
it I actually already have another email
called Andrew teer seat.com it's the
name of our platform that runs exam Pro
so I'm going to go ahead and try this
and see if that works you can't sign in
here with a work or school email address
use a personal email such as a Gmail
okay so it's not letting me uh uh do
that there but maybe we can get
ourselves a new email address and that
will be one way in here now of course
you don't need to create an Outlook or
Hotmail you can of course uh use
something else but I'm just going to
create a new account to make my life a
little bit easier uh while demonstrating
this I'm going to type in exam Pro and
your brown and hopefully it will allow
me have that hyphen there and so I need
to choose a password so just give me a
moment also if you're looking for a
password manager or sorry a password
generator I tend to like this one called
uh password generator.net because it
works really well um so that's the one
that I'm going to use but I'm going to
take this off screen here for a moment
and just put a pass in okay so I've just
generated out a password and hopefully
it will let me go ahead and create that
so we're in good shape and so I'll fill
in the next information here so I don't
want to expose all my personal
information so I'm just going to fill
this in and hit next so you'll see me
jump to the next screen okay and so it
is progressing and we're just waiting
for uh new things to happen
here and so now I have a little puzzle
to solve so just give me a moment I just
want to save the password before I lose
it okay I just saved my password off
screen here let's go ahead and solve
this so please solve the puzzle so we
know you're not a robot uh how do I
solve it do I need to put my headphones
on just give me a moment here and take a
look so let's go ahead and hit next so
use the arrows to rotate the animal to
face the direction of the
hands
um well it's already uh facing it so I
guess we're in good shape that was not
quite right oh maybe the direction of
where the hand is pointing okay we'll
try that again so there we
go and we'll try that again very
interesting um challenge that's the
first time I've ever seen that one but
uh that's
interesting and we'll give it a moment
here and so now we can fill in all of
our information so of course again I
don't want to expose all of my
information here so go ahead and fill
this in and what we'll need to do is
verify our phone number so we'll fill in
all this stuff um and then we'll choose
to use a different phone number and all
this stuff and I'll see you back here in
a moment of course if you already have
an email you wouldn't have to go through
all of this process here but I'll be
back in just a moment okay all right so
the next screen that I'm being prompted
with is to add a credit card they say
identity verification by card um of
course this is is so that when you want
to pay uh and go to the pay TI you can I
believe that Azure uh provides you a
Sandbox so you'll be okay but you'll
have limited control within Azure um but
what we'll do is we'll go ahead and I
will fill all this information of course
I'm not going to show you all of this
information um but I'll see you back
here in just a moment okay okay that's
all filled in and so it looks like um
it's still setting up our account up
here uh it's asking for some feedback um
I don't really have any feedback for the
sign up process I'm just going to wait
here till setting up your account is
complete so I'll see you back here in
just a moment okay oh it looks like it's
already done so the account is created I
assume that we can just go ahead and log
in so let's go ahead and sign in
here and we will CH choose this new
account now the cool thing about um
Azure is that normally when you're
logged in you stay logged in so um uh
it's usually pretty pretty convenient I
don't feel like I'm always logging into
my account but we are in here and so
that's all we had to do to get into our
new azure account so there you
[Music]
go all right so in this video what I
want to do is focus a little bit more on
uh resource providers because it's very
important to understand about
registering uh or unregistering resource
providers to get access to particular
Services right now I am still utilizing
the free tier so in some videos I might
be on free tier in other ones I might
not be but what I want to do is make our
way over to our subscription so we'll go
ahead and type in subscription in the
top to and from here we'll go into Azure
subscription one yours might be named
differently if you named it differently
I'm going to go down uh down over here
and look for resource providers and so
in here we have a bunch of uh providers
that we can utilize and if we scroll
through here there's a ton of them and
so if we do not have um a particular
things registered we're just not going
to be able to use those services and the
the type of subscription you have might
determine what you're able to actually
access so uh we can just kind of sort
here on the right hand side by uh just
double clicking and we can see what
resources we have so I'm just looking
through here and we we kind of have an
idea of what they are so Microsoft
storage is probably storage accounts um
I'm trying to look for uh virtual
machines I imagine there is probably one
called Microsoft virtual machines or VM
if we're not sure I can go ahead and
type it up here so VMware what if I type
in Virtual machines so um some of these
are not registered but um you know uh
it's just going to be really dependent
on what we're running into so some of
these are grouped under the same thing
so it could be a bit misleading in terms
of what their names are but uh what I'm
going to do is just take a look and
click into storage and see what kind of
information we can get about it so we'll
go ahead and click into this one
here and I'm again I'm just trying to
see what kind of information we can
get and if we click here in the top it's
showing resource types so that's kind of
showing the kind of operations um that
we can perform and if I hover over them
notice it says like locations or
operations or storage tasks so I imagine
that these um uh these might be
specifically tied to API calls um but
yeah if if it's not very clear what
these do that's totally understandable
uh but I'm just going to say that we are
going to come across resources and
they're not going to work and it's we're
going to have to enable those uh
resource providers First uh one that I
think that might happen would might be
Cosmo DB I kind of remember having to
always activate that one Cosmo
DB so just give me a second I'll go look
for it okay all right so I did a bit of
Googling and in this one they were
suggesting some uh resource providers I
think it's talking about Cosmos DB and I
think that Cosmos DB used to be called
document DB or it was an older version
of it so I'm just curious if we were to
uh type that in here let me say document
DB yeah and notice that it's not
registered so um Cosmos DB is a um it's
a nosql database if you ever heard of um
adabs is equivalent of Dynamo DB it's
something similar uh the question is can
we use this in the free uh tier I'm not
100% certain but it says try for free uh
for up to 30 days and so all I want to
see is is it going to complain that we
don't have it registered that's what I'm
hoping uh to happen here to demonstrate
this uh this thing about registering I'm
going to go ahead and go ahead uh here
and hit create and uh we have a bunch of
different options here so I'm just going
to go ahead and create a nosql database
and I'm going to create a resource Group
so I'm going to say
you know my DB we'll go ahead and say
okay just follow along if you don't know
the stuff that's totally all right again
I'm just trying to get it to prompt if
you don't want to make this you can just
watch and just see what happens uh when
we see that resource provider uh
complaint assuming that this is going to
trigger it I'm not sure and so we need
account name so I'm going just say my
new
DB um and I'm just going to put a bunch
of numbers here on the end these are
Global names so it's treated like a
domain name I have to really figured out
apply the free tier discount absolutely
yes and we'll go ahead and give it a
moment so we'll just wait and we'll go
ahead and
create and so it's initializing the
deployment and I'm not seeing any
complaint uh so far I keep expecting it
to say hey you need a you need a um a
resource provider
here but it seems to be deploying so
this might not be a good example but I
definitely remember having this issue
before but we'll give it a moment I'm
just going to be back in just a second
and we'll see what the result is okay
also while we're waiting I just want to
point out that uh a lot of times when
things are happening you can go up to
the notifications and it will give you
an update here and so while this is
creating I could go ahead and give this
a hard refresh um and just still notice
that it's still showing the deployment
in progress so we can really keep track
of where we are or what
happening um again I don't know how long
this takes to create this might take
quite a while I just kind of forget I
know it's not going to cost me anything
to spin this up but uh we'll wait here a
bit okay all right so that did actually
create so I guess that wasn't a really
good example unfortunately uh but I do
know um I'm going to go ahead to that
Resource Group and I'm just going to go
ahead and delete this uh anytime you
launch a resource in Azure uh you always
have to launch it into a resource Group
and it's a lot easier to tear down all
the resources within a resource Resource
Group so I go ahead and hit delete
Resource Group it has that one database
there I'm going to go ahead and delete
it so I did kind of cheat and I went out
to the internet and I said what service
uh isn't enabled by default uh where
you'd have to register it and one they
said was AKs AKs is uh for running
kubernetes clusters that's a little bit
um out of scope for the the uh this
level of certification but I'm going to
do it anyway I really don't want you to
do this I just just want you to uh watch
and see what I'm talking about here
because kubernetes can be very expensive
um and I don't want to to put you in
trouble here or to make this harder for
you so just watch along and let's see if
we can see what happens when we try to
launch a kubernetes service without
turning on uh turning it on in uh the
reg uh under resource providers so I'm
going to go here and launch a new
kubernetes
cluster and I'm going to create a new
resource script I'm just say my
K8 um uh Resource Group for RG there
we'll say okay and I'm going to choose
something again don't do this I'm just
doing this we'll go ahead and do Dev and
test I'm going to say my uh k8's
cluster and so it likes the name there
that's fine I'm going to go with the
free pricing tier if it's free you can
do it as well but going to tell you it's
not fun to set up kubernetes clusters
it's going to set up at one Noe pool
we'll go ahead and hit review and create
if you're also noticing um there's
always this confirmation step with Azure
I really like this like eight of us does
not do this gcp kind of does this but
you always go through this process of go
through the steps review what it is that
you want and hit create and then it has
a a deployment step um so it's a nice
workflow I really like that about Azure
but we'll give it a moment here to um
get ready to confirm all the information
and we'll go ahead and see if we can
create it it says validation has passed
we'll go down below and hit create I'm
still expecting it to ask me about
container
service
and I definitely confirm that this is
something you're supposed to have turned
on now what we'll do while we're waiting
is I'm going to go over here uh click
back into a new tab and while that is
deploying because that's going to take a
while I'm going to go ahead back into
our subscriptions and I want to check
resource providers because I know this
one is called like container services so
I'm going to type in here
container and it says it's registered
so I feel like Azure is messing with me
because in the past you've always always
always had to manually turn these on and
I feel like it's just turning them on
for me so what I'm going to do
here is I want to see something I don't
have turned on and then I want to go try
and use it and see if it actually just
turns it on because if it does that now
that is great but always in the past
that's not how it worked so just let me
go look for something and I'll be back
in just a moment all right so I just
went over to chat GPT and I asked what
does Microsoft compute give you access
to and it says virtual machines and
scale sets which makes sense that's what
I recall uh it doing but I just wanted
to be 100% sure it's going to do what I
wanted to do I also noticed that uh
coming back to AKs our deployment failed
I'm going to go take a look here um the
resource R operation failed to complete
successfully because it reached terminal
provisioning State failed that's totally
fine I don't even want to deploy a
kubernetes cluster anymore I've given up
on that we're going to go ahead and just
um delete this Resource
Group and if you're thinking this is a
bit messy I'm just going to tell you
this is what Azure is like um Azure is
uh really great in terms of its
offerings but uh out of all the cloud
service providers I would just say that
it is the most uh challenging to learn
but anyway that's going to tear down and
so what I want to find out is if I go
launch a virtual machine this this
automatically going to turn on to be
registered that's what I want to know so
what I'm going to do is go ahead and
attempt to launch a virtual
machine which that that is something
that is a lot more reasonable to learn
at this certification level but we're
going to go ahead and hit create I'm
going to choose an Azure virtual
machine and I'm going to create a new
resource I'm going to say my uh uh
virtual
machine uh
RG and I'm going to go here and just say
my virtual machine
RG or not RG but just put that in there
like that and we're going to go ahead
and choose us East does not really
matter I just want to it
somewhere and I mean this looks all okay
um I'm not going to log into this the
only thing that matters is uh what kind
of image we're utilizing because that's
going to determine uh the spend so that
is free tier I'm going to stick with
free tier let's go ahead uh forward to
our review and create and see what
happens so again I'm kind of
expecting to create this and I wanted to
say that it's not enabled it wants us to
generate a new key pair um
um I don't really want to download a key
pair but I'll go ahead and do that
anyway that's something you commonly do
with virtual
machines I just wanted to create it so
again I have not enabled that service
while we're waiting for this let's go
ahead and click on notifications and
view all the activity I'm just curious
if it's enabling those
subscriptions because usually it tells
us everything in here and so I'm just
carefully looking so
um I'm going to go ahead and
refresh that was four minutes
ago ah look here Register subscription
for container service okay so um we
absolutely do need to turn it on but it
turned it on automatically for us and
I'm just trying to say that in the past
I always had to manually do that down
below here register the the uh uh
storage resource provider so I'm not
sure if this is a problem anymore but I
still think it's important to point out
that you are supposed to register
Services uh before you use them um and
that's the only point I wanted to make
there um so just understand that that is
something that's important to um Azure
but uh now what I need to do is uh get
rid of my
um uh that virtual machine I've been
launching so over here you can see the
latest resources I'm going to go to this
one here and I know it's still deploying
it's creating these resources I'm going
to go ahead and tear that down so I'll
go here and just say um apply for delete
for all everything yep I definitely want
to do that and I'm going to go ahead and
copy this name here and we'll tear that
down so that's the only point I wanted
to make in that video I know was super
complicated but hey that's Azure we'll
see you in the next one okay
ciao let's go ahead and actually create
some users and just before we proceed
forward to create a user I just want to
point out you can tell what tenant you
are in if you look in the top right
corner so here I'm in my Starfleet
tenant and there's actually I think you
can switch between
here yeah that's an easier way to switch
between your directories uh but
generally that's not how I do
it I'll go to the top here and just type
in Azure active
directory and uh when I want to switch a
tenant I just click the Switch tenant
button and click on what I want but
we'll make our way back to the uh
Starfleet tenant that I have here here
you can see my information and I've
obviously activated Azure ad premium P2
um but before we go ahead and create a
user we're going to have to create a
group and I'll show you why if I'm going
to go ahead I'm just going to speed
through this for a second but if I
scroll on down I have this option where
I need to create a assign it to a group
I guess I don't have to but um the
problem is I don't have one and so
before I create my user let's go ahead
and create ourselves a new user group
and so we'll go ahead and create a new
group here and I we have two options we
have security and Microsoft 365 it
explain explains right here the
difference so 365 is really for giving
access to mailbox calendar files
SharePoint we're not doing that stuff
here we're just sticking with regular
security groups uh which is for Azure
stuff we'll name this uh developers and
then we'll name this
developers and notice here that uh the
membership type I have a drop down if
you're on the free tier this is going to
be great out but uh this Dynamic user is
part of P2 and so uh this allows us to
add a dynamic query and the idea here is
that if I start having users and I just
say if a user uh is from
Canada then they'll automatically be
added to this group and so that's the
query that gets outputed but we're not
going to make a dynamic group today uh
we'll just make our way back here to the
new group and we'll just manually
assigned stuff all right I'll go ahead
there and create that user or that that
group there and now that we have that
group let's make our way over to users
so we'll go back here I'm going to make
myself a new user um and and on the top
here we'll go here uh and we'll name
this one
Kevin and we'll have that
lowercase and we will call them Kevin
xxbridge
all
right and you'll notice here it will
autogenerate a password it's four
letters and four numbers I don't find
this personally uh very secure but the
idea here is that uh user is going to
reset that password right away so it's
not a big deal and that's very easy to
remember and now I can go here and
assign uh
groups and if I want to assign them a ro
I can do that here so we'll open that up
we have a bunch of different options
maybe we want these two roles
here and then we have some additional
information I'll go ahead and create
this user and so now this user
exists what's interesting is that I can
go ahead and delete users and then
recover them the groups have this as
well where if you go here and I actually
have a user I deleted previously so it
just takes some time to show up but if
you go ahead you can hit the uh delete
user here
and then uh they will remain in here for
uh 30 days and then they'll
automatically be Del be deleted so if
someone made a mistake this is a great
opportunity to bring them back and so I
can just go checkbox on rishan here and
we can just bring her on back restore
that
user all right and again you know this
is sometimes a bit delayed so we might
have to hit
refresh there she is and so uh you know
that is the whole group and user stuff
there
[Music]
let's take a look at how we can enable
multiactor authentication for our users
and so multiactor stands for MFA you're
probably used to it where it's a
secondary step to confirm your identity
before logging in either via a phone or
a hardware device such as an UB key and
so there's this button here says
multiactor authentication and it could
be disabled for you it very likely is if
you're on the uh the free version of
um your Azure ad just going back up here
one level you can tell based on what
that is here so I'm using Azure ad
premium P2 that's definitely going to
allow me to have MFA so if you just
don't want to turn on P2 or it's trying
to uh charge your money don't worry
about it just watch me do it here you
pretty much learn what you need to know
so we'll just go ahead and click that
button it's going to bring us to a
different screen here and here we have
our users and you can see multiactor
authentication has turned off for all of
them so we can go ahead here and turn it
on for a single one if I click
enable uh and so that enables it for
Kevin then we have some other additional
options like manage user settings and
here you can see we have some extra
options so require selected users to
provide contact methods again delete all
existing app passwords generated by the
selected users restore multiactor
authentication on all remembered devices
so just some additional things another
thing we'll want to check out here it's
not very obvious but we have a service
settings button up
here and this will give us more addition
additional options to enforce for our
users so first we have app passwords so
this allows users to create app
passwords to sign into non-browser apps
so things that are uh not part of the
website here and so you can whitelist
some IP addresses for them uh so that
they are trusted from those locations
then for verification options this is
something that's important we have some
options like call to phone so um it will
actually uh to do the MFA will actually
call your phone and you'll tell you the
letters and numbers that you enter in or
it can send you a text message or it can
notify you through the mobile
application so you can install the
companion app uh from the Android or iOS
store or the Windows store I imagine
there's a Windows store too um and then
there's the verification code and mobile
app on or Hardware tokens so Hardware
tokens could be with an UB key right
then you can say remember a multiactor
authentication on trust devices for x
amount of days that way they don't have
to enter it all the time uh because it
might get annoying for some users
honestly for me I want everyone to
entered every single time cuz that's
just how I am but let's make our way
back here and see how we can do some
bulk assignment so what I'll do is I
want to enable it for a few people here
so if I go up to bulk update I can
download a sample file and uh that's
going to go ahead and download
that and uh you can see I actually did
this previously here so I'll just copy
it and uh what we'll do is just paste
that in there so we're just pasting in
yeah that's fine we're just pasting in
uh their their name right and the MFA
status you can always get the name from
here just back on the list there and so
once we have saved that file we can go
ahead and upload
that uh they're the same here so it's
not a big
deal and we'll just wait a few seconds
here this is pretty darn
quick usually doesn't take minutes
sometimes it takes seconds but we'll
just give it a moment here
and there we go so that was a long wait
I don't know why but I verified the two
there and so if we go next now those
will be now enabled uh there's also this
option to enforce so I just go there uh
after multiactor authentication is en
Force users will need to create app
passwords to use non-browser
applications such as Outlook or links
and so that's a great option to have so
I'll just go ahead enable that as well
so now that's enforced and so that's all
you really need to know about uh
[Music]
MFA hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at Azure
Computing Services starting with Azure
virtual machines so virtual machine is
going to be the most common type of
compute whenever you're launching a
server I would just think of a virtual
machine uh and your virtual machines
could either be running Windows or the
Linux operating system now the great
thing with virtual machines is you get a
lot of configurations so you can choose
your OS the amount of memory the amount
of CPU you can attach storage to it uh
the thing here is that because it's a
virtual machine the uh the hardware is
shared with other customers you can get
dedicated but generally it's shared and
then you get a virtual uh computer um so
it seems like you have like 100% of the
resource okay then we have Azure
container instances so this I would
describe as Docker as a service you can
run containerized apps probably runs
Docker in both windows containers CU I
believe uh Windows has containers as
well but uh runs containerized apps on
Azure without provisioning servers or VM
so makes that a lot easier for you the
next sounds very similar which is called
Azure kubernetes service so it's
kubernetes as a service uh easy to
deploy manag and scale containerized
applications um so the idea here is that
kubernetes is is just another uh way of
uh working with containers
um but it's using an open-source library
kubernetes has basically become the deao
for um uh containers and so we've seen
all the cloud providers uh try to make
their own service or orchestration
service but um kubernetes kind of one
out so you'll see it on all platforms
the next one is azure service fabric
this one can be a bit confusing because
it's described as many things uh but I'm
going to describe it here is a tier one
Enterprise container as a service uh
application or um cloud service so um
it's for distributed system platforms it
runs on on the Azure cloud or on premise
uh and the way they described is easy to
package deploy and manage scalable and
reliable
microservices and anytime you hear the
word microservices think of also
containers so with Azure container
instances and Azure kubernetes Services
that's where you'd also run
microservices then we have Azure
functions so uh this would be event
driven serverless compute uh anytime
we're talking about serverless compute
we're usually talking about serverless
functions which are little B of code uh
that you can just um upload and it just
works you don't have to think about the
servers or provision anything uh and you
only pay for the time that that code
runs so serverless functions generally
run for very short duration as soon as
they're done those uh those underlying
servers are shutting off uh and the last
on our list here is azure batch so you
can plan schedule and execute your batch
compute uh workloads across uh 100 plus
jobs in parallel when I say jobs here
it's just the the code that you want to
run uh you can use spot VMS spot VMS
might not be out at the time of this but
it will be in the future um but
generally it's known as low priority VMS
but the idea here is that there are uh
virtual machines that are being
underutilized and so Azure is allowing
you to uh uh rent them at a more cost
effective cost and so if you're doing a
lot of uh scientific compute or other
things uh and it doesn't matter if these
uh Services get interrupted and you want
to use those low prior VMS that is a
great way to save and that is the
computer
[Music]
Services hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we are looking Azure
virtual machines which makes it easy for
you to choose your own OS compute memory
and storage and launch a server within
minutes all right so let's take a quick
look here at VMS for Azure and this is a
highly configurable server that relies
on virtualization meaning that you're
running a server without having to
actually buy and maintain physical
Hardware that runs it uh you will still
have to manage things at the software
layer so you would have to apply your
own OS system patches and installing the
configuration packages but the nice
thing is that you're not dealing with
that Hardware it's just going to work
for you and some things I want you to
know about Azure virtual machines is
that the size of the virtual machine is
determined by the Azure image uh and so
the image defines the combination of
vcpus memory and storage capacity the
current limit on a per subscription
basis is 20 VMS per region I would think
that if you wanted more you could just
use another sub subscription I don't
know if they have service limit increase
for that but that might be possible as
well Azure VMS are build at an hourly
rate an instance uh or a single instance
that you launch is going to have
availability of 99.9% when you're using
premium disc if you have standard disc I
have no idea what it is um but it's
going to be less than that if you want
to get
99.95% availability you're going to have
to launch two instances within an
availability set and you can attach
multiple manag discs to an azure virtual
machine now just to give you uh like a
quick visual of what's actually
happening when you launch an instance
because when you do launch a virtual
machine there's going to be other
networking components that are going to
be created or associated with you and
you definitely need to know all these
components here so I have this nice
diagram we're going to do a quick run
through with it and I want you to just
know that when you do launch a virtual
machine it actually does give you a list
of all the components that it creates
this is actually very common with most
Azure services and sometimes what
they'll do is they'll put it within a
resource Group for you so that they're
all grouped together which is very nice
um but uh let's just run through these
uh common components that you need to
know such as the network security group
and this is going to be attached to your
network interface it acts as a virtual
firewall with rules around ports and
protocol so that is what's protecting
our virtual machine you have the network
interface that handles IP protocols so
that's how the virtual machine uh talks
to the internet or other things on the
network you have the virtual machine
itself or the instance that's a uh the
version or the um uh instance that is
currently running it's going to get a
public IP address assigned to it so
that's how um people from the internet
can actually access the virtual
machine and then you're going to have to
launch it within a virtual network uh
and so that's you're going to have that
v-net so you'll either you'll either
choose one or you'll be creating one uh
during that wizard process so there you
[Music]
go so now let's take a quick look at the
options for operating systems on Azure
VM and let's just Define what an OS is
uh so the OS is the program that manages
all other programs in a computer and the
most commonly known operating systems
are windows Mac OS and Linux and when
you want to uh launch a virtual machine
the way you determine what operating
system you use is based on the image
that you choose okay and um Azure has a
Marketplace so they have so many
different kinds of operating systems
you're going to have every Poss option
you want and Microsoft is also partnered
uh with specific companies to make sure
that they're providing you images that
are updated and optimized for the Azure
runtime so let's do a quick run through
of these supported or partnered uh os's
so we have Seuss we have red hat Ubuntu
Debian FreeBSD um then you have flat car
container Linux Rancher OS which is for
containerization bitnami bitnami is more
like images that have pre-loaded
software on them they very popular for
their bitnami WordPress you have
mesosphere uh and then you have images
that have Docker with it so you have a
lot of options uh open to you there and
I always forget about Jenkins and
Jenkins is on the end there now if you
want to bring your own Linux version you
can totally do so all you have to do is
package it into a virtual hard disk or a
vhd uh if you've never heard of vhd uh
these are these are just uh virtual hard
disk formats that you can create using
hyperv software which would be on your
Windows machine uh and just be aware
that Azure doesn't support vhdx which is
a newer format it it only uses vhd okay
so there you
go so let's take a look here at Azure
scale sets and these are used to
automatically increase or decrease your
virtual machine capacity so imagine uh
you have a web application behind an
application load balancer and you have
an increase in traffic you want to be
able to quickly add more capacity by
adding another identical virtual machine
or when uh there's a decrease in traffic
remove it to save cost and that is what
Azure skill sets do um so you're
creating uh skill policies to
automatically uh add remove based on
host metrics host metrics could be like
CPU utilization or uh Network in uh
you're going to create health checks and
you can also uh set a repair policy to
replace unhealthy instances you can
associate a load balancer to distribute
virtual machines across uh availability
zones and you can scale to 100 or even a
th000 VMS using scale
sets so one thing you're going to
probably want to do with your scale set
is associate with a load Bouncer and in
honest I don't run any kind of
application workload uh unless it is in
a scale set and behind a load balancer
because it's just good practice to do
that and the reason why you're going to
want a load balancer is that it's going
to help you evenly distribute your VMS
across multiple availability zones and
that's going to give you high
availability uh because you definitely
want to try to run uh 3 VMS across 3 azs
to get that a high availability uh you
can also use a load balancer probe
checks and these are more robust health
checks than what scill set provides you
uh so that's just an added benefit there
uh and when we're talking about um load
balancers we have two different choices
here we have the application Gateway and
so this is for HTTP htps web traffic
load balancer uh and then you also have
Azure load balancer and this is going to
support TCP and UDP Network traffic and
things like that so depending on what
OSI layer you need to operate on is
going to determine what kind of load
bouncer you need to
use so let's take a look at scaling
policies and these determine when a
virtual machine should be added or
removed to meet the current requirements
and you have this uh Little Wizard here
this is what the What wizard you see or
form you see when you're creating a
scale set initially with very simple
features but let's just focus on two
things scaling out and scaling in so
scaling out is when an instance should
be added to a skill set to increase
capacity so you choose your metric uh
which is hardcoded in this case to CPU
threshold so you choose your metric the
duration how many VMS you want to add
and then the scale in is the opposite
that's when you're removing uh uh uh
something from the scale set to decrease
your capacity and again that interface
is very simple uh when you actually go
ahead and create a scale set after you
go and update it you're going to end up
with a lot more options and here are the
options you can see they're extremely
robust and so uh you have the option to
choose one of the built-in host metrics
that are already be being collected on
your virtual machine so uh the most
popular here and there's more than this
but uh the most popular here is CPU
Network in network out dis read and
write uh then you have your Aggregates
so you can decide how you want to group
or uh collect that data uh before you
apply your final operations on it uh
then you have your operator so you can
say greater than or greater than or
equal to then you have your actions you
can say increase the count of so add uh
x amount of servers or you can say uh
increase by percentage so imagine you
had um uh 10 servers and you want to
increase the load by 30% that would add
three additional servers if you want
more metrics than just the built-in host
metrics you can absolutely get more uh
but you're going to have to install a
couple things uh for app uh if you want
more app specific metrics like page
performance or page load performance and
sessions count you would uh install a
small instrumentation package for app
insights and uh if you want to have more
detailed host metrics so you might have
host metrics but you want them in more
detail or more available host metrics
you'd install the Azure diagnostic
extension within your VM um there are a
few other uh scaling policy options that
are well they're not exactly in that
form but they are around or are
associated with them one is the scale in
policy not to be confused with the scale
in options
um and this determines what virtual
machine should be removed when you
decrease capacity so it's just a simple
drop down and you have a few different
options so there's the default option
this is where it deletes the VM with the
highest instance ID and it's going to do
that b uh uh take in consideration uh
the balancing across azs and ads or it
can delete the newest virtual machine so
delete the newest VM again uh this one's
only across uh virt or availability
zones or delete the oldest VM this is
going to delete the oldest VM and
balance across availability zones then
you have an update policy and this
determines how uh how VM instances are
brought up to date with the latest scale
set model so again it's another drop
down and you have a a few options here
so you have automatic so increasing the
start upgrade immediately in random over
uh order or or manual so existence or
existing instances must be manually
upgraded or rolling and so this update
upgrades roll out uh in batches with
optional pause uh and just one other
note here is that if you want to do
automatic OS upgrades you can enable uh
this to help ease update management by
safely and automatically upgradeing the
OS disk for all instances so there you
[Music]
go Health monitoring is a feature with
skill sets you're absolutely going to
want to turn on uh and what it does is
it determines whether your instance your
virtual machine instance is healthy or
unhealthy so you have that option to
disable or enable it and it comes in two
different modes we're going to have the
application Health extension which is
what we're seeing on the right hand side
here and this is where you ping an HTTP
or htps request with a specific path uh
and expect a back a specific status so
the status here would be 200 so the idea
is that you could say ping the homepage
and if the homepage appears then
therefore the server must be healthy or
you can make it your own custom uh page
that's what I like to do I have like a
health check page the other mode is load
balancer probe uh this is only going to
work if you have an associate IED load
balancer and uh here you can check based
on TCP UDP HTP request so this is a
little bit more robust um um so I
generally would recommend using this
mode over um the the first mode because
generally when you have a scale set
you're going to also want to have a load
balancer uh now if you want to replace
unhealthy instances they have an
automatic repair policy so this is an
automatic I mean like it's not turned on
by default so you have to uh explicitly
say you want to turn it on and what that
will do is that if it finds an instance
that is unhealthy it's just going to uh
terminate it and then launch a new
instance all right and so there you
go all right let's take a look at Azure
virtual desktop formerly known as
Windows Virtual desktop Azure virtual
desktop on Microsoft Azure is a desktop
and app virtualization service that runs
on the cloud Azure virtual desktop works
across devices like Windows Mac iOS
Android and Linux with apps that you can
use to access remote desktops and apps
you can use most modern browsers to
access Azure virtual desktop hosted
experiences use Azure virtual desktop
for specific needs like when security is
a concern because all data is saved on
the server and cannot be left on the
device of a user key features and
benefits enable secure and productive
remote work on any device Azure virtual
desktop provides full Windows 10 and
Windows Server desktop and application
virtualization on any personal device
seamless integration with Microsoft 365
apps for Enterprise and Microsoft teams
reduce costs of Licensing and
infrastructure use eligible windows or
Microsoft 365 licenses to access Windows
Virtual desktop and pay only for what
you use protect against outages to stay
productive help keep your team running
during outages by leveraging built-in
Azure site recovery and Azure backup
Technologies simplify it Management
Windows Virtual desktop manages the
virtual desktop infrastructure for you
say so you can focus on users apps and
Os images instead of hardware and
maintenance Heap application and user
data secure easily apply the right
access controls to users and devices
with Azure active directory conditional
access so that's an overview of azure
virtual
[Music]
desktop hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and I'm going to show you how
to launch your own server on Azure uh
and so a server would be considered some
kind of Computing service and the one
we're going to do right now is we're
going to use Virtual machines so go the
uh all the way to the top here to the
search and I want you to type in virtual
machine I know it's on our dashboard
here but just to get the get in the
habit of always being able to find stuff
it's great to use the search and then
once we're here on the left hand side I
want you to click
add and we're going to be presented with
a lot of different options so the first
thing we need to do is choose our
Resource Group uh we have another
Resource Group we that was created here
for us for azure
I wouldn't worry about it let's just
choose the one that we created I'm going
to name this virtual machine I'm going
to call it my VM we're going to launch
it in uh Us East uh if we wanted to
choose an a we could so we go to
availability Zone and choose one I'm
just going to stick to no infrastructure
then we have Ubuntu here it's using the
latest version it might be different for
you I wouldn't worry too much about it
then we need to choose our size this is
going to really determine our cost here
this is $89 Canadian I'm just going to
go ahead and hit select uh here
and we're just going to sort on the
right hand side based on cost and we're
going to choose the most inexpensive
server which is the B1 LS so that's one
vpcu and half a gigabyte of ram um
because this is just an example app
we're not going to do any or a server
we're not going to do anything with it
so we might as well make sure we're not
overspending our free credits uh we have
the option to add a public key this is
what you generally would want to do uh
but that's a lot of work and so uh for
this demo so we're just going to choose
password they're very finicky about the
passwords here that it has to have a
uppercase lowercase special
character um number and it also has to
be 12 characters so I'm going to type in
testing with a capital T testing 1 2 3
exclamation exclamation and then testing
uh with a capital on the T 1 2 3
exclanation exclamation so there we go
uh we don't need um any inbound ports
I'm going to say none because we're not
sshing in I'm just going to click
forward here to show you some of the
other options so we could Cho are are
the type of uh dis we'd be attaching so
it's by default on premium you might
want to choose standard or standard htd
generally when you're launching web web
apps you want SSD if we were to choose
standard it would say hey you should
really use premium so we're just going
to go back to premium you're going to
notice that the uh disk is encrypted by
default so you can't have an unencrypted
dis that's a very good uh default option
if we go over to networking it's going
to automatically select our v-net that
we chose uh and the default sub net that
we uh that it created uh when we created
the v-net and then here we could choose
whether we want an IP address or not um
if it had no I or public IP address it
would still have a private IP address um
and that would that would mean that it
like it's really intended for a private
subnet um it has a network security
group set on to basic here um and that's
pretty much it here you could also put
it behind a load balcer we're not going
to do that let's go over to management
management we have a couple options here
like identity auto shut shut down backup
um these are all fine we're just going
to leave it alone for Advance we could
put custom data in here that means we
could provide it a script that it would
use to initially set up the server we're
not going to do that um and that's about
it so I'm going to go back to basic and
I'm going to scroll all the way down to
the bottom and I'm going to hit review
review plus create and what we're going
to have to do is wait for this
validation step that was very fast it
might take multiple seconds for you or
even a minute um but sometimes it's
faster than others so so now I'm going
to go down below and hit
create and we're just going to wait for
that deployment to be submitted it's
going to say deployment is underway and
then soon it's going to say deployment
is complete so I'll see you back here in
a moment when deployment is complete
great so we had to wait a few minutes
there and now it says deployment is
complete and we can PR proceed to go to
Resource and so here's our virtual
machine we have some CPU some Network
some dis so there's some activity here
um if we wanted to gain access to it
there should be connect button here
we're not going to be able to gain
access to it because we just didn't set
it up in a way that that was the case we
have a few options down the left hand
side such as the diss that are actually
attached to it and maybe the size here
so maybe if we wanted to um resize
change it to a larger size we could go
ahead and do that um but there's nothing
really exciting here to do I just wanted
to show you how to launch your own
virtual machine and now that we have our
own virtual machine uh launched I'm
going to go back to overview we're going
to go ahead and delete that because this
is now costing us money uh it's not
costing us a lot of money but uh again
we're done here so we'll just go ahead
and delete we're going to say yes to
delete and now it says it's deleting the
virtual
machine and so we're just going to wait
until this is uh finished
deleting and a lot of times you can just
look at the progress up here and it'll
say deleting the virtual machine could
take a few seconds it could take a few
minutes um it just depends so I'll I'll
see you here in a little bit when this
is done
deleting so after a little while here it
says it's how it's successfully deleted
the virtual machine if we want to make
sure that it's deleted let's go make our
way over to Virtual machines at the top
here in the search and you're going to
notice that it's still showing up there
but it said it was deleted and this is
the thing with uh Azure is that it takes
time for it to propagate so what we'll
have to do is just hit refresh and now
it's gone so just be aware that um
sometimes the consistency in terms of
what you see in the UI is a bit delayed
and so um if you remember clicking
delete and it says that it deleted it
just uh have a bit of patience there and
hit refresh and just double check to
make sure that's the case so there you
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're looking at Azure app
Services which allows you to quickly
deploy and manage web apps on Azure
without worrying about the underlying
infrastructure and specifically this is
known as a platform as a service so
Azure app service is an HTTP based
service for hosting web applications
rest apis and mobile backends and you
can choose your programming language and
it can either be windows or L Linux
environment and it's a platform as a
service so if you've ever used Heroku is
basically the Heroku of azure and so
Azure app service takes care of a lot of
the underlying infrastructure for you so
can do security patches of the OS and
languages load balancing autoscaling
automated manager uh and then um there's
a lot of things that you can Implement
uh and so for Integrations such as Azure
devops uh GitHub Integrations Docker Hub
uh package management easy to set up
staging environments custom domains
attaching uh SSL certificates so you can
see that it just basically takes care of
everything for you uh if it's really
hard for you or timec consuming for you
to do all this on your own in Azure and
the way it works is you pay based on an
Azure app service plan honestly I find
these really confusing um I really like
how adus does elastic beanock because
you're just paying for the underlying
services but Azure has all these crazy
uh tiers here uh but you have shared
tier which is free and shared doesn't
support Linux you have the dedicated
tier uh which is basic standard premium
premium version two and three and the
isolated tier and so uh another thing I
need to note is that Azure app Services
is not just for traditional VMS for
monoliths you can also run Docker single
or multi containers uh and when you set
up a project you're going to choose your
domain name on the azurewebsites.net
obviously you can override that with
your custom domain name but there you
[Music]
go let's talk about Azure app services
runtimes and so let's define what a
runtime is a runtime is software
instructions that are executed while
your program is running and so runtime
generally means what programming
language libraries and Frameworks you're
going to be using and so uh runtimes for
Azure app services are predefined
containers that has your programming
languages and probably some commonly
used Li
for those languages installed and
probably commonly used languages for web
Frameworks and so the idea is that
you're going to choose your uh runtime
it could be net net core Java Ruby which
I'm very disappointed in Azure because
uh as of shooting this video they do not
support uh Ruby for application insights
but yet they have it here in Azure app
Services node GS PHP Python and there's
all the logos uh if you like seeing the
logos
and so Azure app Services generally has
multiple versions so they have like Ruby
2.6 2.7 for PHP they have a lot of
versions for no J they have a lot of
versions uh but I just want to point out
uh that it's pretty common for cloud
providers to stop or to retire the old
ones at some point to stop supporting
them uh you know that just because they
want to keep things modern um and the
other thing is like it also helps you
keep with your best security practices
because really you should always be
trying to upgrade to the latest version
uh for those security patches and and
things like that so there you
go but now let's say uh you wanted to
use a language that wasn't supported on
um Azure app services like you wanted to
use uh Elixir what you could do is
create your own custom container either
for Windows or Linux uh and so uh you
just go ahead and create your own Docker
container on your local environment you
can push it to an Azure container
registry and then the the idea is you
can deploy your container image to your
app service so I just wanted you to know
that you could do that um if there's
some languages or other things or maybe
you're using a language but you need uh
some bundle or packages that are uh that
are just baked into the uh into the
Container so there you
go let's talk about deployment slots so
deployment slots allow you to create
different environments for your web
application and Associate a different
host name this is useful when you need a
staging or quality assurance environment
or maybe you need just like a developer
environment any kind of environment you
want so think of it as a way to quickly
clone your production environment for
other uses and so down below here you'd
have your deployment slots and there's
your slots maybe you have app staging
beta so that's the different uh host
names there uh and so the idea is that
not only do you have other environments
but there's also this thing called
swapping and the idea is like imagine uh
you decide like you make a clone of your
production environment and then you
deploy the latest version to it and then
when you decide that it's good it's in
good shape then what you can do is swap
it out with your current production
environment and then just retire your
old one and this is called blue green
deployment uh and so that is a great way
to uh do deployments and I just wanted
you to be aware of
that so I wanted to talk about app
service environment because I just
wanted to show you how Azure app service
is not just for little toy apps or your
small startup but they can be really
useful for larger Enterprises so um app
service environment is an Azure app
service feature that provides fully
isolated and dedicated environment for
securely running app Service uh at high
scale and this is going to allow you to
host web or Windows Web apps Linux web
apps Docker containers mobile apps and
functions and app service environments
are appropriate for application
workloads that require very highs scale
isolation and secure network access High
memory utilization and again you know
when you think of platform as a service
you don't think it this kind of scale so
it's really impressive that Azure does
this customers can create multiple asc's
within a single Azure region or across
multiple Azure regions making ASC ideal
for horizontal scaling stateless
application tiers in support of high
request per second RP RPS workloads and
ASC comes with its own pricing tier and
that's the isolated tier and ASC can be
used to configure security architecture
apps running ASC can have their access
gated by Upstream devices such as a web
app application firewall also known as a
WAFF app or s s ases can be deployed
into availability zones using Zone
pinning I don't know what that is a Zone
pinning but that sounds good to me uh
and there are two deployment types for
ASE we have external ASC and ilb ASC
let's go take a quick look at what those
look like so here's a big diagram and
look in the middle there that's where
our Azure uh uh service environment is
it's in our own v-net and a subnet and
the idea is that you if the reason it's
called an external ASC is because it
exposes the ASC hosted app on an
internet accessible IP address and then
down below uh if you wanted to connect
this this is generally what people are
probably using for but what uh you want
to do is you can connect it to your on
premise via a site to site or express
route VPN um so that's something you can
do with it and the other part is like
you can because the ASC is within the
same v-net it also has access to
resources within the v-net without any
additional configuration so that's
really nice and then the second uh
second one here it looks it's exactly
identical but there's one key difference
and it has this ilb there and an ilb
stands for internal load balancer um and
that is basically the only difference so
uh there you
[Music]
go so the way you pay uh when you use
Azure app service is you need an Azure
app service service plan and that's
going to determine you know how much you
pay and what's going to be available to
you they got three tiers which we're
going to go uh through here shortly and
we did mentioned them earlier I honestly
do not like this whatsoever this tells
you this this is a Microsoft product
because it has these uh wonky pricing
tiers I hope in the future they'll
change it but that's just what it is and
so let's go learn it so basically what
you do is you have like this big uh
wizard uh that tells you all the stuff
that you can have it tells you what's
included and stuff like that uh but
let's work our way through through it so
the first thing is the shared tier and
there's two types here we got free and
shared and so there's the free tier that
red one there it's called F1 it gives
you 1 gigabyte of disk space up to 10
apps on a single shared instance no SLA
for availability and each app app has a
compute quota of 60 minutes per day so
there you go you get some uh free tier
there then there's the shared tier this
provides up to 100 apps on a single
shared instance no SLA availability each
app has a compute quota of 240 minutes
per day uh and the thing is is that I
didn't know where the button is for that
so like the next thing right beside it
is the dedicated tier and I thought
that's what it would be because it says
100 total
acus so is it I'm not sure but anyway
the point is there is a Shar tier where
it is I don't know and you can't use the
Shar tier on uh on the on Linux base
system so you're using Windows you're
using Windows you got to use bigger
instances anyway which I don't know I
don't like that too much but that's what
it is uh moving on uh over we're now
into the dedicated tiers and look it's
right beside the free tier that's the
green one it says B1 and if you expand
it it actually has a couple other tiers
there so I just wanted to show you that
there was uh three uh there and so uh
for dedicated TI we got basic standard
premium premium version two premium
version three and we're looking at basic
that's what that is more disc space
unlimited apps three levels in this tier
that offer varying amount of compute
power memory disc usage it must be B1 B2
B3 uh and then the next thing over is uh
the standard and we had we had to switch
tabs there onto the production tab
notice the terminologies don't really
match the tiers uh and so uh with
standard you can scale out to three
dedicated instances has an SLA of
99.95% availability and three levels in
this tier that are offering varying
amounts of compute power memory and
storage dis and so then uh that's that
tier there and we're on to our last tier
which is the premium tier and this
scales to uh 10 dedicated instances it
has availability SLA of
99.95% and multiple levels of Hardware
so that's the dedicated TI then we're on
to the last thing which is isolated and
this is really only to be used I think
for ASC so the uh the isolated tier has
dedicated Azure virtual networks uh full
Network compute isolation scales out to
100 instances availability SLA of 99.95%
and again I think it's just for those
as um but there you go that is all the
tiers and hopefully it makes sense to
you but it is a little bit tricky to
figure out what to choose but you don't
really get to like pick at a granular
level that's what I don't like um but uh
it is a really great service Azure app
uh service it does figure everything out
for you so maybe it's okay for
[Music]
you hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are going to be learning
about Azure app services in this follow
along uh and it's a service that's
supposed to make it easy for you to
deploy web applications I say supposed
to because it really depends on your
stack Azure has more synergies with
other Stacks than others so if you're
like me and you like Ruby on Rails
you're going to find a lot of friction
with rails and Linux but if you're using
something like Windows servers or python
or.net you're going to have a much
easier time still really great service
just wish they'd make it a bit more
broad there but let's hop into it so
before we can go use that service let's
make sure that it's activated and so
we'll go over here and we'll go to Azure
subscription and then down below we're
going to go to Resource provider now you
think what you could do is just type in
app services
uh and you'd be wrong because the the
service is under a particular provider
so if you want to figure out what
provider it is we can go um Azure
resource
providers and they have a page on
documentation here that lists them all
so if I search for Azure app
Services it's under web and domain
registration so we're going to make sure
this is registered if we're using a
custom domain which we are not today we
need this one activated so going back
here I will type in web and you can see
it's registered so if yours is not
registered go ahead and hit that I
believe this by default is generally
registered with new Azure accounts so I
don't think that is an issue for you but
we'll go back up here close these
additional tabs and we will type in
Azure app
services and we will look for that
service so there it is and we'll go
ahead and hit
add um and so I'm going to give it a new
name I just made it a moment ago but I'm
going to try again again and try to use
the same name so we're going to call
this
Voyager Great and then I'm going to go
ahead and name this Voyager and I
already know that that is taken so I'm
going to type in Delta
Flyer and these are fully qualified
domains so they are unique with Azure
app Services you can run a Docker
container we're doing code this time
around and what I like to use is Ruby um
but again you know if I want to use the
cicd I'm not going to be able to use the
deployment center with Ruby so that is
not possible um and so we're going to go
with python and run either a flask or
ajango app I haven't decided yet I am in
Canada so let's go to Canada east and uh
down below here we have the plans
generally the plans will tell you the
cost underneath you'll notice that it's
loading but I just want to show you that
there are some discrepancies in terms of
pricing so if I was to go to Azure app
Services
pricing and we were to pull this up here
we can kind of see the pricing
here okay and if we scroll on down right
now we're looking at a premium V2 uh and
oh no I don't need help I'm okay you'll
notice that it's 20 cents per hour so if
I go here and do that times 730 because
there's 730 hours in the year that's
$146 I believe this is showing me in USD
dollar yeah and in here it's showing me$
103 Canadian which is lower um so it
could be that because I'm running in a
Canada east region it's
the price is different but you could
imagine that if I had this at this cost
at uh what did we say here um at 146
USD to CAD I'd actually be paying
$182 so you got to watch out for that
kind of stuff but I'm pretty sure this
is what the cost is so just be aware
that if you look stuff up in here it's
not necessarily reflective so you got to
do a little bit more work to figure that
out uh if we wanted to go here uh we
cannot choose the free tier when we're
using Linux if we're using Windows I
believe we can use it we're working with
Linux today so that's just how it's
going to be um for the B1 this is
totally fine but we want to utilize
deployment slots deployment slots is an
advanced feature of uh the production
version and that's the only way we're
going to be able to use it here this is
20 cents per hour again so I don't want
to be doing this for too long but I
think what we'll do is before we do that
we can just do an upgrade to Dev to prod
so we can experience that I'm going to
go and just choose B1 okay so we go next
um we do not need any application
insights for the time being and it will
not let us so it's okay we'll go next
review and
create and we'll go ahead and create
this resource here and I will see you
back when this is done so um our
resources is now set up we'll go to
Resource and now that we're in here
you'll notice if we hit browse we're not
going to see anything because we do not
have anything deployed which makes sense
right uh so we're going to actually have
to go ahead and deploy something so we
are going to make our way over to the
deployment
Center and uh it's just going to tell us
that we have yet to configure anything
and that's totally fine we're going to
go to
settings it'll give it a moment and so
the thing is is that we're going to need
something to deploy um I did not create
an app but the great thing uh is in the
Azure documentation they have a bunch of
quick starts here all right and
apparently they have one for Ruby as
well but today we are looking at python
uh and so they actually have an example
repository for us here which is
github.com aure samples python docs
hello world and I mean I could go make a
repo for you but we might as well just
use the one that is already provided to
us so I'm just going to pull this up to
show you what's in it it's a very very
simple application even if you don't
know anything about building web apps
I'm going to walk you through really
easily here okay so we're going to open
up app.py so we are using flask if
you've never heard of flask it is a very
minimal python framework for creating
web apps uh very uninspiring uh homepage
here but it gets the job done it's going
to create a default route for us which
uh we have there we're going to call
hello here and we're going to have hello
world so that's all that's going on here
very very simple and we have our
requirements this is our package manager
I don't know why python uses txt files
it's very outdated to me but that's what
they use and here we have
flask all right so we're going to use
that repo it's a public repo so it
should be very easy for us to connect so
we'll drop down go to
GitHub and uh the next thing we need to
do is authorize GitHub all right so I
ran into a bit of trouble there because
I could not uh authenticate my uh a
GitHub account but you know what I just
made another GitHub account so that made
it a lot easier I'm going to go ahead
here hit GitHub and we're going to try
to authorize it and so now I'm logged
into this new one called exam Pro Dev
and we'll go ahead and authorize this
application and we're now in good shape
this repository doesn't have anything in
it so um if I want to clone something I
guess I'll probably have to Fork that
repo so we'll give it a moment to
authorize and while that's going I think
that's what I'm going to do I'm going to
go and uh Fork the example repo if I can
find the link again here uh
myself uh I
believe it is that's still authorizing
over there I'm still looking for it so
it was like examples or something
samples or
examples all right so I found a way
around the problem I just made a new uh
GitHub account so that's all I had to do
um and I just won't be using my primary
account till I get my phone back but um
so what we'll do is go hit connect I'll
hit
authorize and it didn't prompt me
because it already connected to this new
one called exam prodev you might have to
put your credentials in here and it's
going to ask me to select some things
it's a new account so there are no
organizations there are no repositories
there are no branches totally brand new
so what I'm going to need to do is get a
repo in there so we'll just go ahead and
Fork the Azure samples one so that is
azure samples
python docs hello
world and if I type that right we're in
good shape I'm going to go ahead and
Fork this
repository I'll say got it and then I'll
move this off screen here
this is now cloned you should see it
cloned here and we'll go back here and
this probably isn't live so there's no
refresh button here so we'll have to hit
discard and we will give this another go
here and we will select our organization
which is our name there is the
repository uh should be main branch is
kind of outdated I'm sorry but it's
called Master that's what it is not my
fault that's azure's fault okay um and I
think that's it I don't know if we need
a workflow configuration file I don't
think
so it's going to double check here no I
don't think so and uh what we'll do is
we'll just go ahead and save
that and so now we are set up for
[Music]
deployment hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we're looking at Azure
container instances also known as ACI
and this allows you to package deploy
and manage Cloud applications using
containers or the way I like to think of
it as fully managed stalker as a service
Azure container instances allow you to
launch containers without the need to
worry about configuring or managing the
underlying virtual machines and you're
going to be able to design isolate
containers for simple applications task
automations and build jobs let's talk
about some of the uh reasons why you'd
want to use containers over VM so
containers can be provision within
seconds where VMS will take several
minutes containers are buil per second
where VMS are built per hour so you'll
save a lot more money containers have
granular at uh and custom sizing VPC uh
vpcu memory and gpus where VM sizes are
predetermined uh so those are the
benefits between containers and VMS uh
aciis can uh be utilized for both
windows and Linux containers you can
persist storage with Azure files using
ACI containers and honestly if you have
containers or functions you have to have
an external storage mounted to persist
uh it's just the way you do it aciis are
accessed via fully qualified domain
names which is one of the things I
really appreciate about Azure Services
because most of the services are like
that Azure provides quick start images
to help you start uh launching example
apps but you can also Source containers
from add your container registry Docker
Hub and privately hosted container
Registries it looks like that the choice
option there let's just talk about
container groups because this is pretty
much the only major component you have
to worry about these are ction of
containers that get uh that get
scheduled on the same host and the
containers uh the containers in a
container group share life cycle
resources local network storage volumes
so the idea is that you have these
tightly coupled containers so all of
them act as a service within that
container group uh so here you can see
an example of a couple containers that
are mounting Azure files on different
directories there and underneath all of
that it's running on an Azure virtual
machine container groups are similar to
kubernetes pods
yeah and it says similar to but not
really the same thing multicontainer
groups can currently support only Linux
containers which is kind of a bummer but
that's just what it is and there are two
ways to deploy a multicontainer group
you can use Arm templates when you need
to deploy additional Azure service
resources or just a yamell file when you
want to deploy uh when your deployment
only includes container
instances let's take a look at container
restart policies and what these do is
allow you to change how the policies uh
restart and there's three different ways
we have always uh never and on failure
so the first one here always means
always restart the container and the
idea is to uh keep your container
running as long as possible and the
reason why you'd want that is if you're
running a web server some other
providers would call that a service then
we have never so run only one time this
is great for background jobs and so
other providers would just call this a
task uh then you have on failure so
containers that encounter an error
that's when it should um restart and so
it's as simple as just choosing that
option uh when you uh are creating uh
that
container let's take a look at container
environment variables are also known as
nbars that allow you to pass
configuration details to your containers
and you can do this through the portal
the CLI Powershell which that's always
the case with Azure and so it's as
simple as just putting in your uh key
and your value uh and one other thing I
want to point out is that you can also
pass in secured environment variables so
the idea is that sometimes you don't
want them plain teex so if you have like
so I have that stripe secret key you
don't want anyone ever seeing that in
production so the idea is that through
and I don't think you can do this
through the portal but you can do this
through the CLI or Powershell is provide
the secure environment variables over
the regular one which isn't environment
variables and that way you can pass it
securely so it's never uh exposed to
human
eyes
let's talk about persisting storage and
we talked about that a little while
there when we were looking at Azure
files but uh containers are stateless by
default so when a container crashes or
stops all all state is lost to persist a
state you need to mount an external
volume and there's quite a few different
things we can mount Azure files secret
volumes empty directory a cloud get repo
so you got a few options there and to
mount a file volume you need to do this
via power shell C you're going to give
the following detail so when you launch
the container there's going to be
nothing in the portal so you got to do
it this way all
[Music]
right hey this is Andie Brown from exam
Pro and we're going to take a look at
Azure container instances so here it is
so all we got to do is go to container
instances we'll hit add and the nice
thing is that Azure provides us with a
Hello World one so it's very easy for us
to get started um it's a Linux machine
and it looks like it's pretty inex
expensive there so we'll stick with that
I'm going to create a new group here
we're going to call it banana um and
we'll name the container instance banana
and East Us 2 seems fine to me you'll
notice we're on a quick start image if
we wanted we could use something from
the docker Hub and provide our own link
but we'll just stick with the quick uh
start image for today we're going to go
ahead and hit next to networking just to
see what we have as options you can make
it public or private we'll go to ADV
Advanced hold on here yep those are just
the ports you can expose we'll go to
advance and for the restart policy we
can set on failure always or never we
can pass in environment variables and I
covered this a lot more in detail in the
lecture content so we don't need to
really dive deep into this um and we'll
go ahead and create this
instance and so we'll have to wait a
little while here and I'll see you back
in a moment okay and so after a short
wait our container instance is ready
we'll go to that resource there
and take a look around so on the left
hand side we can go to containers and
there we can see it running we can see
the events down below of what's going on
so you can see that it's pulled the
image it successfully pulled it and it
started the
container some properties nothing
interesting there the logs if we wanted
to see stuff and if we wanted to connect
to the instance we could also go here
and hit connect which is kind of nice um
I don't have any purpose to do that
right now so and it's also not going to
work the way we're doing it but I just
wanted to show you you had those
opportunities uh you can do identity so
that means manage it with role base
access controls but what I want to see
is actually this uh hello world working
I'm assuming that must be a a hello page
I've never looked at it before so we're
going to go here grab the public IP
address and paste it on in the top and
there we go so we have deployed a
instance onto Azure container instances
or a container I should say so nothing
super exciting to talk about here um but
we do need to know the Basics uh there
um if we wanted to deploy other
containers it's just the one there so
that's all you really need to do um but
yeah so yeah hopefully that uh gives you
an idea there I'll just go back to the
list here so we can see it and we'll go
ahead and just uh delete that probably
do it for the vi the resources on the
left hand side like I always like to do
uh and we will go into banana
here and we will delete
banana and there you
go
[Music]
let's talk about networking for Azure
and so everything kind of revolves
around the virtual Network also known as
the v-net and this is a logically
isolated section of your Azure Network
where you launch your Azure resources
and here's a very simple uh diagram of
using v-net but there's a lot of
networking components uh that you're
going to be utilizing and we're not
going to go through the exhaustive list
here but let's just go through some of
them uh just to give you an idea like
all the things you can do within Azure
networking so you have Azure DNS this
manages your your DNS domain then you
have the v-net itself and so underneath
that it'll have like address spaces
route tabl subnets then you have network
security groups this access a virtual
firewall at the subnet or Nick level you
have express route this helps you create
a very fast connection between your
on-prem to your v-net then you have
virtual Wan this is a centralized
Network to Route different network
connections then you have virtual
Network Gateway
this is a sight tosite vpm connection
between v-ets and local networks then
you have your Nicks or your network
interfaces and these are virtual network
devices to allow VMS to communicate
using IP protocols and then you have
like all your load balancers and other
things like that so again not an
exhaustive list uh but just shows you
that there's a lot you can do uh within
networking on
[Music]
Azure one interesting concept is v-net
peering and this is where you connect
multiple v-ets so they act as one
network and there are two types of
peering we have um uh Regional peering
this is when you peer two v-ets from the
same region and then you have Global
v-net peering this is when you peer two
v-ets from two different
regions let's take a look at network
interfaces which are software or
Hardware interfaces between two pieces
of equipment or protocol layers in a
computer network and so network
interface controllers also known as Nyx
um that is the actual piece of Hardware
that connects computer to computer
network and they go by a bunch of
different names such as network
interface card network adapter LAN
adapter physical network interface or
even ethernet interface controller card
so if it was back in the 1990s you
definitely would have had one of these
in the back of your computer and if
you're a gamer uh today then you have
one because you want that wire
connection so you have a super fast
connection uh and so um these cards or
Nicks uh communicate using the Internet
Protocol also known IP that's going to
them to uh communicate on the on Layer
Two the data link layer and the physical
layer of the OSI uh model uh and so the
way these work in Azure is they're
called the Azure network interfaces and
um they have the same initialism and IC
and so the idea is that you're going to
attach a network interface uh to an
Azure uh VM instance and without one of
these your Azure VM just can't
communicate because it's just imagine
not having that card in your computer it
would have no way of of communicating um
and the difference here is that they're
just virtual network interfaces right so
I'm sure um at the data center Azure has
a bunch of these um actual uh cards but
they are abstracted away so you know you
just treat them as virtual and um an
Azure VM it just has to have at least
one Nick but it can also have multiple
Nicks if you want and so here's just a
nice little graphical representation of
a VM that has a Nick attached to it so
there you
go let's take a look at subnets and a
subnet is a logical division of an
address space so we just looked at
address spaces so we're cutting it up
one step further and subnets help you
define different kinds of workloads and
allows you to apply virtual is isolation
within your network so when you launch
an aszure resource you choose the subnet
you want to launch with within and an IP
from that subnet is assigned to your
resource so uh the thing is is that uh
when you create route tables that's how
you are associating uh the subnet so it
can access the inter internet or access
anything uh and then there's public and
private subnets but this thing is
interesting because like again if you if
you're using AWS uh those are very
clearly defined things but in Azure uh
they don't have this concept of public
and private you have to Define it
yourself so really a public or private
subnet is just a subnet that doesn't
have access to the internet and so we
saw that when we had the rote table and
we over over uh Road um the access to
the internet to none that M essentially
made it a private subnet uh another
thing you can do with subnets is you can
associate a network security group and
this is going to help protect protect
your traffic entering and leaving the
subnet so you're making rules based on
the IP address port and protocol uh and
then there's a special thing called a
Gateway subnet so uh it's a specialized
uh type of subnet it's just for Azure
virtual Network gateways and so um it's
interesting you'll go in and there'll be
a separate section just for it and so
you'll create it it's just for that
service
[Music]
to understand Azure DNS let's first
Define what is the domain name and that
is a service that is responsible for
translating resolving a service name to
its IP address and so Azure DNS is a
hosting service for DNS domains that
provides a name resolution by Microsoft
Azure infrastructure so imagine you have
a domain you want it to be M managed by
Azure DNS and then you can make records
like www to point to a specific Azure
resource that's the idea behind there
and there's two types of uh dns's you
can make you got a public DNS an
internet facing one this is the one
you're likely going to be using so this
allows you to manage your domain for
internet accessible domains Point your
domains to your website or creating
records that you uh you own the domain
or that you uh are pointing uh emails to
your email server uh so things like that
then you have your private DNS which is
internal facing this allows you to use
your own custom domain instead of the
Azure provider domains so azure has its
own provided domains which are fully
qualified domains for a lot of services
a great example of this is azure storage
accounts and so that is that link there
is its fully qualified domain one thing
I want to point out is that you cannot
use Azure to purchase domains if you
want to purchase a domain you can
actually do do that through app services
or you use like a thirdparty provider
such as uh name cheep or GoDaddy and
then have Azure manage that
DNS uh
stuff
[Music]
so uh virtual private networks also know
as vpns what they do is they extend a
private Network across a public network
and enables your users to send and
receive data across shared or public
networks as if their Computing devices
were directly connected to the private
Network all right uh and so now we have
to talk about what is a virtual Network
Gateway and so virtual Network Gateway
is the software of VPN device uh for
your Azure virtual Network so that's how
these uh devices are going to connect to
your network so when you deploy a
virtual Network Gateway it will deploy
two or uh two or more specialized uh VMS
in specific subnets you need to create a
Gateway subnet and these deployed VMS
contain routing tables and run specific
Gateway Services you can uh choose the
type of Gateway you want it to be and
this is going to determine whether You'
use something like VPN Gateway or
Express rope Gateway so it's as simple
as an option like that but to really
understand
these virtual Network gateways we should
just look at some VP and Gateway design
so you understand why you're creating
these
[Music]
things so Azure Express routes creates
private connections between Azure data
centers and infrastructure on your
premises or in collocation environments
and so uh connections don't go over the
public internet and as a result offer
more reliability faster speeds
consistent latencies and higher security
so here's a big old graphic here kind of
representing what's going on here and
theide idea is that you're going to have
connectivity from different things like
from any to any so that's ipvpn Network
a pointto point ethernet Network a
virtual cross connection and this is all
going to be going through a connectivity
P provider at a co- location facility so
this example would be a uh an edge
partner and so you would be the customer
Network that' be your on premise or
whatever you want to connect so that you
can make it all the way to your Azure
services and the way you would establish
connection is you create these Express
circuits uh it's pretty common to have
more than one because uh you want to
have high availability just in case the
other one goes out the idea is that you
can route them uh route this traffic to
a couple different places so the first
one would be things like peering to
Office 365 Dynamics 365 or even your
Azure public services so when we say
Public Services imagine you just launch
a um a virtual machine that is in a
public subnet that has a an IP that's
reachable from the internet uh that
could just be to that or maybe you're
using like Cosmo DB or like you have
fully qualified domains for other
services uh so it's just a way that you
can get there and then let's talk about
the other side which is uh um doing
private peering for uh v-net so the idea
is that you have a private v-net so the
subnets are private and so the only way
is going to be access it uh you want a
direct way to access it that way so uh
that's the two ways there uh and just to
note there is express route direct and
so this is like express route with an
additional benefit that has greater
bandwidth connections from 50 megabytes
per second up to 10 GB per second and
this is really ideal if you have hybrid
Solutions where you uh you're removing
massive amounts of uh data or where
latency matters because you you want uh
to feel like these uh cloud services are
right there with your on- premise
environment you're going to need a lot
of speed for
[Music]
that so as your private links allows you
to establish secure connections between
Azure resources so traffic remains
within your Azure Network and so I got
this big old graphic here uh and so
let's just uh Define a few things I'm
going to pull out my pen here and so
imagine you have workloads on your on
Prem or you have your own virtual
Network on Azure and so you have some
VMS doing some stuff and the idea is
that you want to connect them to some
other services over here uh but the
thing is is that if you wanted to
connect them they might try to
transverse the internet so if you're on
Prem it's going out here
and it's going over here and so the
issue with this is that um it's not
necessarily secure uh another issue
could be um you know it's just faster if
it would to stay within the actual
Network because if you're already
connected you you know your stuff over
here then why wouldn't it just go
through uh the actual Network another
thing is like data transfer cost so it's
always going out the internet and coming
back in and that's not a great scenario
uh so I'm just going to erase all that
stuff there
uh the idea with private link is that
it's just keeping everything within the
Azure Network um and so that's what it's
doing so if you want to uh you know um
connect your workloads in your v-net or
your on-prem that connects to a specific
vnet the idea is that you can launch a
private link endpoint which is a network
interface and this is what's
establishing that connection and you're
going to have to give that private
endpoint a private IP address from your
v-net and so then the idea is that on
the right hand side that's what you want
to connect to there's a lot of Azure
Services by default works with private
link so there's no additional
configuration you'll just be able to uh
say use private link and they will uh
same thing with some third-party
providers um in the marketplace uh they
might be powered by private link and
then there's a third case where let's
say you have like a private subnet and
you have some VMS there uh so what you
could do is um if you have a load balcer
and you need to have an internal load
balcer there you can uh launch the
private link service and this is going
to basically make your
uh your workload in that v-net become
compatible or powered by private link so
there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're going to look at making
our own virtual Network so we made a
resource Group but we also need a
virtual Network or v-net so we actually
have some Network to launch our
resources within so what I want you to
do is make your way all the way to the
top here and we're going to go ahead and
type in vnet
which uh we'll get virtual networks and
go ahead and click that and if you
notice you don't have any networks so
we're going to have to go ahead and
create our own so go ahead and hit the
add
button and uh we're going to have a
bunch of options here I'm just going to
name this uh well sorry we're going to
choose that Resource Group so exam Pro
and we're just going to name this exam
Pro
vet and there are some additional steps
here we'll just take a peak here we
don't really need to change anything but
we'll just take a look so for IP address
you can set the IP address space it's
going to default to 10.0.0 416 which is
very good for us you can see that it
supports IPv6 which is great it's going
to create us a default subnet which is
going to be 10.0.0 sl24 that's going to
be a subnet with uh like 256 um IP
addresses which is great we go to the
security tab um we have DOS protection
basic and you definitely want to stay on
that because that is free same thing
with the firewall we don't want it on
because that's going to cost extra money
I'm going to go back to basics we're
going to hit review plus
create we're just going to wait for
validation to complete this could be
instantaneous for you or you can wait a
few seconds it's different for
everybody and now the validation has
completed we'll go ahead and hit
create and so we'll just wait for that
to finish
creating
great so it's created so it's just
saying deployment is underway so we're
just going to have to wait a little bit
here until it says deployment is
complete and it's already done super
fast we'll go ahead and hit go to
Resource and so now we are in our
virtual Network and we have a bunch of
settings on the left- hand side so
address space subnets etc etc nothing we
need to know at this level um we just
need that virtual Network so we can
launch resources in so now that we have
resource groups and virtual networks we
can start launching resources so there
you go I'll see you in the next follow
[Music]
along hey this is angrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at Azure storage
Services starting with Azure blob
storage so um I would describe this as
object serverless storage so if you ever
heard of object storage or seress
storage this is going to make sense to
you so you're able to store very large
files and and large amounts of
unstructured files uh and the idea here
is that you pay for only what you store
uh it's basically unlimited storage you
don't have to resize the volumes you
don't have to worry about file system
protocols you just upload files uh and
that's why it's considered serverless
storage then we're going to move on to
Azure dis storage this is the most
common type of storage uh you'll
encounter um so we can describe it as a
virtual volume so you're just choosing
either an SSD or an htd so it's
basically a hard drive in the cloud it
has encryption by default and uh it's
attached to Virtual machines so anytime
you're spinning up a virtual machine uh
it's probably spinning up also uh Azure
dis storage attached to it then you have
Azure file storage so this is a shared
volume that you can access and manage
like a file server so it's going to use
uh protocols such as SMB the reason
you'd want this is that let's say you
had multiple virtual machines multiple
servers and you wanted them to all share
the same uh uh hard drive drive that's
what You' use it for or if you need to
have users access it using those
protocols that's another way of doing
that uh then you have Azure Q storage
now I put an aster in front of it
because this is just a weirdly named
service um because this is really uh for
a messaging queue this is actually for
application integration but I list it
here because they put the word storage
on it so I just think it's poorly named
um and even the way they describe it is
is just makes you think it's storage but
it's a data store queuing and reliably
delivering messages between applications
so it's just uh uh integrating two
applications together passing a messages
along another one that's confusing is
azure table storage I would put this in
the database categories and it's a nosql
database and specifically it's a wide
column nosql database as they described
it's a nosql store that hosts
unstructured data uh independent from
any schema so just be aware of those two
they're just very poorly worded um then
you have Azure data box and also it's
upgraded version the Azure data box
heavy this is a rugged briefcase
computer and storage designed to move
terabytes or pedabytes of data so
imagine um somebody uh shows up your
door with this uh this Tower that's a
computer and you plug in your USB or
whatever um uh whatever you want and you
transfer all your files locally on your
on- premise Data Center and then they
they ship it because it's faster to ship
the data on a physical piece a device
and it is to send it over the Internet
that's what Azure data box is uh and
then we have Azure archive storage so
this is long-term cold storage for when
you need to hold onto files for years
but you want the cheapest storage
options if you have lots of data and
it's not it's not doing anything you
definitely want to be uh putting on the
cheapest possible uh storage devices
cheap meaning um uh doesn't mean that
they're not reliable just means that
they're not active the discs are not act
actively spinning nobody's accessing the
data on those hard drives the last one
is azure uh Azure data Lake storage and
so this is a centralized reposit
repository that allows you to store all
structured and unstructured data at any
scale when you're working with big data
from multiple different sources and you
need it to be in one place that is the
service for you and so that is the Azure
storage
[Music]
Services hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we are looking at Azure
storage accounts which is used for
containing all your your storage data
objects such as blobs files cues tables
and diss so storage accounts is one of
those Services where it has a bunch of
different storage types uh within it so
it's a quite the multi-purpose uh
service and with each different type of
storage is going to have different
features and their own pricing models
let's just quickly break down uh the
type of storage we have so we have
general purpose uh version one uh
version two blob storage block blob
storage and file storage and so I just
want you to know that when you are using
storage accounts uh I'm saying storage
type but for whatever reason the UI
calls it account kind uh just to be
aware of that small little discrepancy
there but storage accounts are going to
vary based on features and so the common
features we'll see across storage will
be um supported services so where can I
put this storage account and so on the
right hand side you can see uh like if
you make a general purpose version two
what you have access to such as contain
containers cues tables or fur those
options are going to change based on
what you're using all right uh for
performance tiers this is how fast uh
you'll be able to do reads and writs uh
you have standard and premium uh you
have different kinds of access tiers so
how often do I need to quick access
these files and then there's replication
how many redundant copies should be made
and where and the last thing is
deployment models so who should deploy
the supported service resource manager
class CL and in generally most cases
it's going to be resource
[Music]
manager so here I have all the storage
Types on the Le hand side and uh we have
the feature set and how it's going to
vary based on the certain types let's
just quickly look through this to see
where there are some uh standouts and
you might want to actually review this
at the end of the section just so uh
you're a bit more familiar with all
these types of features so it clicks it
better but let's just quick go through
this so you're going to notice for
version one this is the only case where
you're going to have a deployment model
of classic everything else is going to
be the resource manager from a practical
standpoint you're not going to really
notice because you're just going to be
pressing buttons but underneath um
that's the only case where it varies for
replication you're going to notice that
uh version two has the most options with
replication and if these don't make
sense don't worry we're going to cover
all the replication in an upcoming slide
uh for uh blob block storage you can see
it's very limited same with file storage
um so that's there when we're talking
about access tiers how quickly you can
access files you're going to notice that
it's only available for General version
2 and blob storage where we're choosing
these different tiers for these ones it
doesn't really matter um because well
especially with like a file storage
because the drive is as fast as it's
going to be right uh for performance
tiers uh you're going to notice that
with version one and version two we have
standard and premium when you're using
file storage and block blob storage
you're always using premium and with
blob storage which is again a legacy
format there that's going to be using
standard uh blob storage comes in three
different types and you're going to
notice that uh based on what you want to
use there'll be some variation there um
I don't know where pages I think that
they both support page but there are
three types in there I wouldn't really
worry about it too much uh you're going
to notice that file storage only
supports file types and then you have
version two and this pretty much uh
supports everything so you can see
general purpose version 2 is a really
great um uh storage to
[Music]
choose so we were just talking about
storage types now let's talk about the
actual storage services that we can
actually uh launch or utilize Within
These uh storage types under storage
accounts and there are five core
storages available to us the first is
azure blob this is a massively scalable
Object Store for text and binary data it
also includes uh Big Data analytics
through data Lake storage Gen 2 um and
so aszure blob is really great because
you just don't have to think about the
file system you just upload files and
they're treated like objects so that's
really nice then you have Azure files
and this is a file share uh and so the
great thing about Azure files is that if
you want to have a bunch of virtual
machines and have it so like they have
um the same file system sharing all the
same files that's what you're going to
use that for then you have Azure cues to
me this really is a database but for
whatever reason it's under uh storage
accounts and it's a nosql store for
schema storage of structured data this
is another unusual one uh I don't know
why Azure puts it under here but um it's
a messaging store for Reliable messaging
uh between application components to me
that's like an application integration
service but Azure categorizes it as
storage and the last one is azure dis
and this is Block Level storage volumes
for Azure VMS and so the idea is that
when you want to do the top four the
above you're going to be launching
storage accounts and for uh discs you're
going to be launching diss it's a bit
unusual because um one of storage
accounts say that you can uh use or
store diss uh in I think version or uh
general purpose version two I'm not
really sure I understand that uh maybe
it's talking about like backing them up
or something like that but anyway from
practical standpoint and for what we
need to know is that this is the
breakdown here and we do have a full
section on Azure diss um so we will get
into that
[Music]
so now let's take a look at some of the
features that are available on uh
account storage the first being
performance tiers and generally this is
going to be for blob storage and we have
two types of performance tiers we have
standard and premium so it's a simple as
uh just choosing between the two uh and
when we're talking about performance
especially when we're talking about
storage we want to be thinking about
iops and that stands for input output
operations per second so the higher the
iops the faster a drive can read and
write so you can uh definitely assume
that uh premium is going to have a
higher amount of iops and so when we're
looking at the premium performance these
are going to be stored on solid state
drives ssds which we have in the picture
there it's optimized for low latency
higher throughput and the use cases here
is going to be interactive workloads
analytics uh AI or ML and data
transformation on the other side for
standard performance these are running
on hard disk drives and you're going to
have VAR Performance Based on your
access tier and we're going to talk
about access tiers uh very shortly uh
but the tiers would be hot cool and
archive and this is great for backup and
Disaster Recovery media content bulk of
data processing uh and things like that
and so the reason why ssds are uh
generally really really good for uh
premium performance is because they have
no moving Parts within them and the data
is distributed Rand uh randomly so if
you have to do a read and write the
distance between the read and wres are
going to be a lot faster uh and that's
generally why you're going to see Sol
satz with premium performance or things
with higher iops and then for um hard uh
dis drives it does have moving parts so
you see that it has an arm and that arm
needs to read and write data sequential
sequentially to the disk and so it's
very good at writing or reading large
amounts of data that is close together
that is sequential um but you know the
idea is that neither uh format is good
or bad it's just the the use case that
you need so you don't always always need
to go with SSD sometimes you want to
save money and hhds are uh or hdds are
really good for
[Music]
that so let's take a look at access
tiers and there are three types of tiers
uh for standard storage we have cool hot
and archive and so you're going to have
this option between uh cool and hot and
archive archive might not show up
depending how you configure your storage
account uh so for example if you use a
particular type of replication that
might not be available uh uh uh to use
with archives so just be aware if that
option doesn't show up you might have to
change some of your settings let's
quickly walk through the three options
so hot is for data that's access
frequently and has the highest storage
cost and lowest access cost so again
it's for data that's as frequently
access or in active use or data that's
staged for processing an eventual
migration to the cool AIS tier then you
have the cool tier this is data that's
infrequently accessed and stored for at
least 30 days lower storage costs higher
access cost
and the use casee here is for short-term
backup and Disaster Recovery data sets
or older media content not viewed
frequently anymore but is expected to be
available immediately when accessed uh
and I think there's actually a third use
case which is large data sets that need
to be stored cost-effectively while more
data is being gathered for future
processing then we have the archive tier
this is for data that's rarely accessed
and stored for at least 180 days uh it's
the lowest storage cost but it also has
the highest access cost uh and so its
use case would be long-term backup
secondary backup archival data sets
original raw data that must be preserved
even after it's been processed into the
its usable form uh and compliance and
archival data that needs to be stored
for a long time and is hardly ever
accessed so just make use or note of the
cool is at the least 30 days and the
archive is at at least 180 days I should
have highlighted those for you I don't
know why I didn't uh and so just some
other things you need to know so for
account level tiering any blob that
doesn't have an explicitly assigned tier
infers the tier from the storage account
access tier settings so you can set uh
blobs at different um storage levels uh
blob level tiering uh you can upload a
blob to the tier of your choice and
change uh change the tiers happen
instantly with exception from moving out
of archive uh the concept of rehydrating
this is when uh you're moving a blob out
of archive into another tier it can take
several hours uh you have the blob life
cycle management so you can create
rule-based policies to transition your
data to different tiers so after 30 days
we can move it to cool storage and here
is just the option here you see where it
says 30 I think 30 is the minimum days
you have to choose um but I could be
wrong and so you have the options down
below so move to Cool Storage move to
Archive storage delete the
blob uh and just a few other things here
when a blob is uploaded or moved to
another tier it's it's charged at the
new tier rate immediately upon the tier
change so when you're moving to a cooler
a cooler tier the operation is build as
a right operation to the destination
tier and when the right operation per
10,000 and data right per gigabyte uh
charges for the destination tier applies
uh when moving to a hotter tier the
operations is build as a read from the
source tier and where the read operation
again in the 10K and the data retrieval
again in gigabytes charges for the
source tier applies and early detection
uh charges for any blob moved out of the
cool or archive tier May apply as well
uh and just lastly here uh when we're
talking about cool and archive early
detection any blob that is moved into
the cool tier so this is only for
general purpose version two accounts is
subject to a cool early detection period
of 30 days and any blob that is moved
into the archive tier is subject to an
archive early detection of 180 days and
this charge is pro-rated so uh you know
access tiers aren't the funnest thing to
talk about but there is all the
information you need to
[Music]
know so let's take a look at replication
and data data redundancy and so when you
create a storage account you're going to
have to choose a replication type and
the reason why is that uh you're going
to want to have multiple copies of your
data so you're protected from a bunch of
things so maybe uh your data Setter has
a planned outage so you have to make
sure you have a u a backup of your data
if you need to access it maybe there is
a hardware failure or network or power
outage or natural disaster and so that
is the whole point of replication and
the greater level redundancy the more
expensive the cost of replication will
be and talking about cost we can break
it down into three categories and each
uh of these categories have uh two types
of uh replication so let's just quickly
go through the list and then we'll Deep
dive into all of them uh in the upcoming
slide so for the first part we have
primary region redundancy so we have
local redundant storage lrs and Zone
redundant storage zrs and locally
redundant storage is the most cost
effective tier so that's the one I'm
usually going for a lot especially when
I'm running uh using development
accounts that's what I'm always setting
and so the reason or and so the use for
thisa uh this tier is generally disaster
recovery and
failovers the secondary region
redundancy we have Geo redundant storage
GRS and geozone redundant storage gzrs
and the reason you'd want to use this
tier is for also disaster recovery and
failovers but it has a higher level
redundancy uh then the last one here is
secondary region redundancy with read
AIS uh and uh for this case uh we we're
going to have is read axis GE redundant
storage so that's RS and read AIS GE
redundant storage G uh R
azrs uh and that's going to generally be
for read replicas and if you can't
remember all the initialisms don't worry
I don't either um but uh you know there
you
[Music]
go so what we're going to do is take a
closer look at the replication type
starting with the primary region
redundancy and so for this tier all the
data is going to be replicated at least
three times in the primary region and we
got two options we have lrs and zrs and
by the graphic you can tell that they're
slightly different and so for for lrs
it's using um uh synchronous uh
replication for those other pieces of
data so you notice in that region there
are three uh there's three versions
running and so when we say synchronous
we mean that if I want to read from any
of those copies um they're all going to
be 100% up to date so that's what
synchronous means um and so here we have
a durability of 119 and this is the
absolute most cheapest option when
choosing storage accounts so if you're
running this for developer accounts you
do not care about uh replication choose
lrs uh for zrs we have copies of data
synchrony to three different
availability zones in the primary region
and this has a durability of 12 9 so
it's clearly more durable uh and so why
would you want to choose the primary
region over the lrs well the idea is
that if an availability Zone goes out
you still have your data in two other
regions where in the case of lrs if the
uh availabity availability Zone goes out
uh your data is gone okay uh so that is
uh the first uh
[Music]
tier so now we're taking a look at
secondary region redundancy and the
purpose of this is uh if you have your
primary region uh suffers a regional
disaster so all the data centers are out
in your primary region uh you can rely
on that secondary region and your
secondary region is going to be
determined based on your primar pair
region so regions are paired with
another region uh and so you don't get
to pick your twin it's just it is what
you get okay um and so secondary regions
um aren't available for read and write
access except in the event of failover
so basically the uh redundant cop the
second secondary region is uh is just
there on standby but it's not in use and
so let's just talk about GRS and G uh
gzrs and you'll notice again by the
graphic uh they're they look a bit
slightly different but you can kind of
get the idea based on our previous
version or previous uh primary storage
tier and so uh data is copied
synchronously in within the uh the main
primary region and then data is a
synchronously copied to another region
so asynchronous means that if you try to
read from the second region all the data
might not be there okay again
synchronous means if you read from
something there's a guarantee that it's
going to be the same and asynchronous
means that there's not a guarantee that
the data is one: one to the original and
the durability here is
69 going over to
gzrs uh we have data data is copied
synchronously across three availability
zones in a physical region and then the
data is copied asynchronously to another
region and um I believe that the data in
the secondary region is not necessarily
in three other azs at least that's the
graphic I made there so hopefully that
is true um but yeah there you
[Music]
go so now we're going to take a look at
um a redundancy in the secondary region
with read AIS and the whole purpose of
this region is so that you can actually
uh have a read replica in another region
uh and so the the concept of that is
having your data in sync okay and so
down below we have RS and R azrs and
it's going to look very similar to the
last setup but the key difference is
that now um data is synchronous uh
synchronous in both the primary and the
secondary region because if you're going
to be reading from it you want to make
sure that your data is one to one uh
with your primary regions data so there
you
[Music]
go so we keep on mentioning about Azure
blob storage let's actually talk about
it now so blob storage is an object
stored that is optimized for storing
massive amounts of unstructured data and
unstructured data is data that doesn't
adhere to a particular data model or
definition such as text or binary data
and Azure blobs are composed of the
following components so I have this
graphic here so the first thing is your
storage account and I didn't mention
this prior but uh when you create a
storage account you actually get a fully
qualified domain uh a lot of azure
services are like this where you get a
fully qualified domain so that you can
access it from everywhere and this is a
really nice feature but that means that
when you're naming your storage account
or other Azure Services you have to
treat it like a domain name and you have
to choose a unique name uh the next
thing are containers uh and this is a
little bit confusing because when we
think of containers we think of
computing but Azure um uh account
storage has the concept of containers
for blobs and it's just uh what they
call folders so just be aware of that
and then you actually have the actual
data being stored and these are the
[Music]
blobs so there are three types of blob
storage we have blob blocks and this is
what you're going to primarily be using
and so this is when you store text and
binary data it's made up of blocks of
data that can be managed individually
and it can store up to 4.7 uh terabytes
of data then you have aend blocks um and
these are optimized for append operation
so imagine that you have
logs uh from a virtual machine and you
want to write them to blob storage this
is going to be a lot more efficient if
you're using appen blobs because they
just appen to the end of the file and
the last is Page blobs and these store
random access files up to 8 terabytes in
size and these are just for storing
virtual hard drives so vhd files uh and
serves as discs for aure virtual machine
so there's the three
[Music]
types let's take a closer look at a copy
and this is a command line utility that
you can use to copy blobber files to or
from a storage account so the first
thing you're going to need is the
executable file and there you can see
they have it for Windows Linux and mac
and then once you download that file uh
what you're going to have to do is also
uh make sure that you have the the right
level of authorization with for the user
account you're using with it so you
might need to uh for download you'll
need storage blob data reader for upload
storage blob data contributor and
storage blob data owner so just be aware
that you need to have those uh rules
available to you um to your user account
I think that I have access to everything
so I don't think I even I set this it it
just works but if you're in a larger
company and you have more uh permissive
least permissive roles you just need to
know about that and so you can gain
access uh uh via either the Azure active
directory or a shared access signature
so let's just take a look at that right
now so the idea here is that we'll type
in a copy login and it's going to ask us
whether we want to sign into the web
browser so that is uh that should be as
your active directory option one and so
what you'll do is you'll uh enter your
username and password and you'll then
have to enter the code displayed there
and so now you're ready to use uh the um
the CLI and so all you have to do is
type in a copy copy and then you have
the file and then you give it the
endpoint to the storage account uh and
the container and the location you want
it to go in if you want to download
files it's the same command you just
reverse the order you say uh this is the
the location of the file I want to
download it locally all
right let's talk about Azure storage
Explorer so this is a standalone app
that makes it easy to work with Azure
storage data on Windows Mac OS and Linux
and you can create a variety of things
so I just want to show you and here I am
running on a Mac but on the left hand
side you can see I have my subscriptions
my storage accounts my Diss and we have
some options where we can like upload
files download files open stuff uh clone
stuff uh create uh some things and so
this is just an easy and convenient way
to uh access your file or your account
storage and work with
[Music]
them so let's take a look at Azure files
this is a fully managed file share in
the cloud and the idea behind this is
that it's like a centralized server for
storage that allows multiple connections
or the way I like to think about it it's
like having one big shared drive that
every that everyone can use or work on
at the same time and when I say everyone
I mean your virtual machines so here is
a visual representation but let's just
talk uh quickly about it uh so the idea
is that you're going to be using a
network protocol uh in order to uh
facilitate communication and so the two
most common ones is server message block
which I believe uh was created by
Microsoft and network file system NFS
which is very commonly used on Linux
files or Unix based file systems and
what you're going to be doing is you'll
have to establish a connection with your
file shares file system uh and what
you'll be doing is making it accessible
within a specific directory so a folder
within your um within your drive okay
and this is called mounting so you
notice there uh it says Z X and Y so on
Windows you'd actually have the option
uh when you mount it to say I want to
mount it to zed and so anytime you
access Zed on your Windows Server uh
it's actually going to be using um Azure
files
okay so let's talk about all the use
cases for Azure files normally they have
a spiffy graphic here um but because
Azure files has so much utility uh all I
have room for is a bunch of text uh but
we do need to learn it all because it is
such an important service so the first
use case is that it can serve as a
replacement or supplement uh for your
on- premise file servers network
attached storage your Nas devices if
you're performing a lift and shift and a
lift and shift is when you're
moving data in the cloud we'll describe
it in a second here uh you can use um uh
Azure files for that and so we actually
have two different kinds of lifts we can
do that Azure defines we have a classic
lift and a hybrid lift so in a in a lift
and shift this means when you you move
workloads without re architecting so the
idea is like you used to use on premise
you want to use app meure uh but you're
trying to keep things as as similar as
you can very commonly lift and shifts
for uh um from on premise to the cloud
will just be taking your virtual
machines and then just uh copying and
bringing them onto the cloud with
nothing else right uh but anyway in the
case here for storage we have the
classic lift this is where both the
application and its data are moved to
Azure and then in a hybrid lift this is
where the application data is moved from
uh moved to Azure files and the
application continues to run on PR
premise uh so clearly classic lift is
bring everything over hybrid lift is
like leave the application behind uh
another reason you'd want to be using as
your files is that it's going to
simplify your Cloud deployment so
imagine you have shared application
settings so you have multiple virtual
machines and workstations and they all
rely on the same configuration fils you
can just go ahead and mount that drive
and share that information uh if you're
doing do diagnostic tests so let's say
you have a bunch of virtual machines and
they're logging uh to those
machines uh and you want a developer to
go in and quickly debug them maybe
there's a reason why you don't want to
use a third party provider because of
compliance or security reasons but the
idea is that all these DMS can just log
uh to the um uh to the file share and so
now you have centralized logs across
many machines uh another uh use case is
that you need to quickly share
development tools so you could put all
your tools onto the on to the drive and
so they developer would mount it and now
they can set up a local environment a
lot faster when we're talking about
containerization we have a few options
here so if you are using containers
generally by default containers are
stateless and so you need to purist
volume somehow and so that's what you're
going to do you're going to be using
Azure files to do that um and also
another question is why would you why
would you use Azure files instead of
setting up your own file share server
because that's definitely an option that
you can do and the reason why is that
shared access so it already has the
standard protocols so you don't have to
configure them it's already uh baked
into to uh the service it's fully
managed uh and this is something that I
should I don't think should be
underlooked but because it's very
difficult to um scale a file server so
it they will uh apply patches for it and
it will just automatically um scale
another thing is that it already has a
lot of scripting and tooling built in so
if you want to use the Azure API or
Powershell you can automate the
management and creation of files and
things like that and it's also extremely
extremely uh resilient so uh you can be
sure that it's going to stay remain
running so there's a lot of use cases
there but definitely worth our time so
there you
[Music]
go all right so we heard of azure files
but there's also another service called
Azure file sync and so the idea behind
this service is that it allows you to
cash Azure file shares on an on- premise
Windows server or Cloud virtual machine
and so here is the uh visual graphic
here where you can see on Prem Azure VMS
and your Azure backups and so the idea
here is that you can use any protocol
that's available on the Windows server
to access your data locally including
SMB NFS and even ft FTP um and you can
have as many caches as you need across
the world so I mean like this is kind of
like having a one drive right for your
file share uh because it's keeping uh or
like any kind of cloud storage it's just
keeping your files in sync and the nice
part is like you can have files in the
cloud and uh they're they're referenced
on your computer but you only um you
only need to access them when you when
you need them so you don't have to have
all these files locally
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown and in
this video I'm going to show you how to
set up blob storage and so if you
remember uh through the actual course
blob storage is like serverless storage
so you don't have to worry about um
running out of space or resizing your
discs let's go to it um at the top here
I want you to type in uh blob storage
and you're going to go to storage
accounts
and this is where you end up creating
all of your storage accounts you can see
that we have a couple storage devices
from the virtual machine and when we
created the um serus uh the serverless
function there so go ahead and hit
add and what we're going to do is choose
exam Pro or whatever you called yours
when we were at the resource Group step
then we're going to have a storage
device I'm going to say my
blob uh
storage oh has to be all lowercase my
blob storage
and that's already taken so we'll
say uh exam blob
storage and it can have
hyphens there we go and so we're going
to launch it in Us East we have the
difference between standard and premium
I think we'll stick with standard uh we
have storage type V2 or V1 or blob
storage we want blob storage uh we have
some replication options here I'm just
going to leave it alone uh we have
access here hot or cool we're just going
to leave it
hot and we can just look at networking
here for a moment uh we're going to
leave this alone we're just going to
look Advance at a moment so nothing
exciting there we'll go back to basic
hit review plus create we'll have to
wait for validation we'll go ahead and
now hit
create and then it should say deployment
underway we're waiting to see the St
deployment complete uh you might be
getting into the rhythm of how creating
Services now it's almost always the same
process and we'll just wait here till
this is
complete okay great so I just waited a
minute there and now um that's all set
up so let's go ahead and hit go to
Resource and then we have a lot of stuff
around here um so what we want to do is
we want to start uploading files but I
think we have to create a container
first so go all the way down here left
inside and go to
containers and we're going to create a
new container I'm going to call this
start track it's going to be a private
container so it's only just for me we'll
hit
create and now we should be able to
click into that
container all right so now we uh now
that we have that container what we can
do is go ahead and upload our first file
I just happen to have a file on my
desktop here so I'm just going to go
select that there and
upload um all the options by default are
great here we'll just hit
upload and there we go so we just
uploaded a file into our blob storage
brige um yeah so that's all there really
is to it um so now that we're all done
there we can just go ahead and delete
this container so I think we'll just go
back to storage accounts not sure if we
have to delete the containers first I
guess we'll find out and we'll just go
here to blob storage we'll go ahead and
hit delete and we'll hit
yes we'll go to
delete and there you go so we'll just go
back to Microsoft Azure there and back
on our desktop and I'll see you in the
next fall
along
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and in this section we'll be covering
the Azure Cloud adoption framework Cloud
adoption framework is a white paper that
is a step-by-step process to help
organizations plan and migrate their
workloads to Azure the image outlines
the Microsoft cloud adoption framework
for Azure a systematic approach to
transitioning to the Azure Cloud the
process is categorized into stages
Define strategy here the focus is on
understanding motivations grasp in the
reasons for cloud adoption business
outcomes identifying the desired results
business justification validating the
moves reasons first adoption project
kickstarting the cloud Journey plan this
stage includes rationalizing digital
estate evaluating current digital assets
initial organization alignment ensuring
everyone is aligned with the migration
goals skills Readiness Plan equipping
teams with necessary Cloud skills Cloud
adoption plan laying out a road map for
the cloud transition ready this phase
ensures preparedness Azure Readiness
guide preparing the environment for
Azure First Landing Zone setting up an
initial secure Azure environment
expanding the blueprint broadening the
Azure setup as per requirements best
practice validation ensuring adherence
to Azure best practices adopt the
actionable phase where migrate existing
workloads or moved to Azure this entails
the first workload migration
understanding expanded scenarios
validating best practices and making
process improvements
innovate transform services in the Azure
environment using Innovation guides
exploring new scenarios validating best
practices and furthering process
improvements govern this is about
oversight and management establish a
methodology and Benchmark for governance
Implement initial best practices
standards for Azure use measure
governance maturity how well governance
rules are followed manage the deals with
ongoing operations ensure business
commitments are met during the
transition set and assess the operations
Baseline determine operations maturity
gauge the efficiency of cloud
operations now let's take a look at the
security roles and responsibilities of
the Azure Cloud adoption framework
Business and Technology outcomes goals
and results expected from security
functions security outcomes results an
organization aims for including
governance prevention and response role
types security leadership provides
security Direction and strategy
security architect designs and
implements security blueprints platform
app security Engineers ensures security
of platforms and applications security
operations manages real-time security
threats
responsibilities security leadership set
security strategy security architecture
design secure systems security
compliance ensures adherence to
regulations policy and standards set
security policies posture management
manages over all security stance phases
of security implementation plan identify
security needs build Implement
strategies including access control and
asset protection run manages ongoing
operations including prevention and
response feedback loop continuous
Improvement cycle and security
operations in summary the framework
offers a structured way to transition to
Azure ensuring strategy alignment
preparation adoption governance and
effective
management
the next topic we'll be covering is
azure migrate Azure migrate offers a
streamline service for migration
modernization and optimization on Azure
it simplifies the pre-migration
processes like discovering assessing and
appropriately sizing on premises
resources for infrastructure data and
applications with an extensible
framework Azure migrate easily
integrates with thirdparty tools
broadening its range of supported
scenarios here's what it offers Unified
migration platform a centralized portal
to initiate execute and monitor your
Azure migration Journey diverse tool set
Azure migrate provides a suite of tools
for both assessment and migration it
features tools such as Azure migrate
Discovery and assessment in migration
and modernization furthermore it
seamlessly integrates with other Azure
Services tools and thirdparty offerings
from independent software
vendors comprehensive migration and
modernization capabilities in the Azure
migrate Hub you can assess migrate and
modernize servers databases and web apps
assess and migrate on premises servers
web apps and SQL Server instances to
Azure databases analyze on premises SQL
Server instances and databases and
migrate them to Azure SQL on a VM Azure
SQL managed instance or Azure SQL
database web applications evaluate on
premises web applications and transition
them to the Azure app service or Azure
cubern service virtual desktops review
your onsite virtual desktop infr
structure and move it to Azure virtual
desktop data transfer efficiently and
affordably transfer vast data volumes to
Azure using Azure data box products by
using Azure migrate organizations can
streamline and simplify their migration
process reduce downtime and improve the
overall efficiency and cost
effectiveness of their Cloud
migration the next thing we'll be
covering are the integrated Tools in
Azure migrate the Azure migrate Hub
includes these tools
Azure migrate Discovery and assessment
discover and assess servers including
SQL and web apps discover and assess on
premises servers running on VMware
hyperv and physical servers in
preparation for migration to Azure
migration and modernization migrate
servers migrate VMware VMS hyperv VMS
physical servers other virtualized
servers and public Cloud VMS to Azure
data migration assistant assess SQL
Server databases for migration to Azure
SQL database Azure SQL managed instance
or Azure vm's running SQL Server data
migration assistant assesses SQL servers
identifies potential migration problems
unsupported features and suggest the
best path for database migration Azure
database migration service migrate on
premises databases to Azure vm's running
SQL Server Azure SQL database or SQL
managed instances Azure databased
migration service is a managed service
for seamless migrations to Azure data
platforms with minimal downtime nuver
assess servers nuu is a SAS platform
that enhances business intelligence by
accurately depicting it environments
within a day web app migration assistant
assess on premises web apps and migrate
them to Azure Azure app service
migration assistant is a standalone tool
to assess on premises websites for
migration to Azure app service Azure
data box migrate offline data use Azure
data box products to move large amounts
of offline data to Azure so that's an
overview of the integrated Tools in
Azure mic
great the next migration solution we'll
be covering is azure datab box the
Microsoft Azure datab box Cloud solution
lets you send terabytes of data into and
out of azure in a quick inexpensive and
reliable way each storage device has a
maximum usable storage capacity of 80
terabytes and is transported to your
data center through a regional carrier
it is designed to help customers with
slow or limited internet connectivity to
move large volumes of data to the cloud
let's take a look at some of azzure data
Box's use cases data boxes used to
import data to Azure for onetime
migrations moving large on premises data
transitioning offline tapes relocating
VMS SQL servers applications and
transferring historical data for Azure
based analysis initial bulk transfers
large scale transfers using data box
followed by incremental Network
transfers for example moving vast
backups with Partners like convolt
periodic uploads transferring large
volumes of data generated periodically
like video content from oil rigs or
windmill farms for exporting from Azure
data boxes used for Disaster Recovery
restoring Azure data on premises quickly
security requirements meeting mandates
that require data extraction from Azure
storage tiers Like Us Secret migration
moving data back to on premises or to a
different cloud provider here's how
Azure data box works customers order a
data box from the Azure portal when the
data box arriv arrives customers connect
it to their Network and configure it
using the Azure portal customers copy
data to the data box using standard file
transfer protocols such as SMB or NFS
once the data transfer is complete
customers ship the data box back to
Azure Azure copies the data from the
data box to the customer's Azure storage
account so that's an overview of azure
datab box its use cases and
workflow hey this is Andrew Brown and
and before we get into Azure ad I need
to point something out it's not called
Azure ad anymore it's called Microsoft
entra ID Microsoft decided to change the
name of
azuread why nobody knows but I can tell
you no customer likes this particular
change um somebody just had a lot of
time on their hands over at Microsoft
but we do need to address this and I
need to point out that I'm not refiling
all of the content that I made just to
change the name because that's crazy I
will will at some point when this when
the content is stale but the content's
not stale they just change the name on
us um but I wanted to just go over that
quickly here so uh the names here we
have Azure ad is now Microsoft entra ID
then the Azure ad tiers is from P1 P2
still P1 P2 the Azure ad external
identities is now called Microsoft entra
external identities and if we scroll on
down we have a logo change so instead of
this which by the way I really like the
old
logo they didn't need to muck with it
but anyway we have uh the older ones
here and so this is the new one
here and so there are some name changes
here Azure ad single sign on now
Microsoft entra entra uh single sign on
we'll go down below here and you can see
well more name changes okay so um anyway
yeah they renamed it and you know
customers are just going to take a while
to get used to it I still like calling
Azure ad I know a lot of other people
like still calling it Azure ad but it's
at some point we'll get moved over to it
and we're just going to use both names
okay now coming over to uh uh the portal
I need to show you that if you type in
Azure ad it's still going to pull up
Microsoft ENT okay now you don't want
Azure ad B to C which is interesting
they didn't rename that U which is a it
is part of azure ad kind of in a sense
but it's more for um if you're building
applications and you want to um have
authentication into it so just
understand that there's not consistency
all over the place especially even their
documentation the marketplace still says
Azure ad all over the place um even down
below uh you know Azure ad notification
so you know there's just going to be
that Legacy of azure ad but anyway yeah
what you want to do is go go over to
Microsoft Entre ID it all looks the same
it's just some name changes okay but
yeah there you go see you in the next
one
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at Azure active
directory and this is a cloud-based
identity and access management service
to manage users sign-ins and access to
ad related resources so as your active
directory is Microsoft's cloud-based
identity and access management service
which helps you your employees sign in
and access resources so that could be
external resources like Microsoft Office
365 azer portal SAS applications or
internal resources so applications
within your internal networking or
access to workstations on premise and
you can use Azure ad to implement single
sign on so you can see that Azure ad is
basically like the the the one solution
to log into everything and uh we
actually use it at exam Pro we use it
with Microsoft teams or uh you know for
the exam pro pro platform our mid panels
tied to it so when we want to log into
the mid panel with credentials we have
it there uh we use it with AWS to log
into there and we use it to log into
azure so it has a lot of flexibility and
if you're building out applications for
Enterprises they're likely using ad and
so this is the reason why everybody
adopts it or needs to understand it so
it's a service I really really do want
you to understand and know as your
active directory comes in for additions
we have the free tier and by the way
each uh uh uh tier that goes up has the
features before it but uh free has MFA
SSO basic security usage reports and
user management then you have the Office
365 apps which is uh revolves around if
you're using that Suite so you have
company branding SLA two sync between on
premise and cloud and then the premium
tiers which really comes into Enterprise
or or or on premise hybrid architecture
so hybrid architectures Advanced group
access conditional access premium 2
identity protection and identity
governance only thing I don't like about
Azure ad is that uh you can't really
create your uh custom access controls
unless you have premium one or premium 2
but that's just how they do it so there
you
go
so let's take a look at the use case for
Azure ad and we basically covered it in
the introduction but I just want to
reiterate it in a different way with a
bit of a visual uh so that it really
helps uh it sync into your uh brain
there so Azure ad can authorize and
authenticate to multiple sources so it
can authenticate to your on- premise ad
to your web application allow users to
log in with uh ipds uh so identity
providers could be like use Facebook or
Google login uh you can use it with
Office 365 or Azure Microsoft and so
just a visual here notice that uh we
have Azure ad and using Azure ad connect
we can connect to on premise through uh
app registrations we're able to uh
connect our web application to Azure ad
with external identities we can um uh
use Facebook or Google uh uh uh uh login
and then for cloud applications we can
connect to Office 365 or Microsoft
azure
[Music]
so active directory existed way before
Azure and so let's just do a quick uh uh
rundown of the history so we have an
idea of what we're looking at so um
Microsoft introduced active directory
domain services in Windows 2000 to give
organizations the ability to manage
multiple on- premise infrastructure
components and systems using a single
identity per user so it's been around
for 20 years and as your ad takes this
approach to the next level by providing
organizations with identity as a service
so idaa
solution for their apps across uh cloud
and on premise and both versions are
still used today because they just have
different utility and so we have active
directory which is for on premise and
then you have azuread which is just the
cloud hosted version and many regards
these can also be connected together um
but there you
go so I want to cover some active
directory terminology and the honest
truth is that uh for a you're not going
to be uh uh too worried about these
things but they're going to come up in
the documentation you're going to kind
of wonder what they are and so I just
wanted to uh uh tell you about these
upfront even though they're not core to
study uh so that it just really rounds
out your active directory knowledge
because active directory is such a core
service to Azure Microsoft products you
you should know these things uh so the
first thing is all about domain so a
domain is an area of network uh
organized by a single authentication
database an active directory domain is a
logical grouping of ad0 objects on a
network so just think of it way as you
know how you have resource groups to
logically group your Azure resources
domains are a logical grouping for your
ad objects then you have a domain
controller a domain controller is a
server that authenticates user
identities and authorizes their access
to resources very common to have
multiples of these uh because you want
to have redundant uh domain controllers
so you can log in or availability or
launching domain controller uh nearby so
people can log in different places uh so
definitely uh very core to active
directory then you have the domain
computer this is a computer that is
registered with a central authentication
database uh and a domain computer would
be uh an ad object uh so then you have
ad objects so this is the basic element
of active directory so you have users
groups printers computers share folders
Etc then you have a group policy object
a GP this is a virtual collection of
policy settings it controls what an ad
object has access to you have your
organizational units this is a
subdivision within active directory into
which you can place users groups
computers and other organizational units
so it's just another way of um doing
logical
grouping then you have a directory
service and this is this provides a
method for storing directory data and
making this data available to network
users and administrators a directory
service runs on a domain controller so
there you go that is the rundown of
active directory terminology and again
hopefully when you see it in the
documentation you can refer back to this
or you'll have a better understanding of
all the components I would have loved to
have made a diagram but just couldn't
find an example of one and so uh I mean
I feel like there could be a really good
picture for all this
[Music]
stuff so remember that the domain
controller is the server that users are
going to be using to authenticate to the
directory Service uh and so when you
create an active directory Azure sets
one up for you but there's some cases
where you might want to set one up
yourself and the reason why is that you
could be like an on like an Enterprise
where you already have your own active
directory on premise but you've decided
that you want to move it over to Azure
ad uh because you just want a fully
managed active directory and uh you want
to tap into the cloud but uh the thing
is that some domain Services those are
features on your domain controller just
might not be available and that's where
you're going to need to set up your own
domain controller and that's where Azure
active director domain Services come
into play because these provide managed
domain
services and so they have manage domain
services such as domain joins uh group
policies
ldaps uh curb B Ross Never Can Say That
properly ntlm authentication and so the
great thing is here is you can have
these domain services but you're not
going to have to deploy them manage them
patch them they're just going to work so
there you
go the next topic we'll be covering is
single sign on an enter ID single sign
on an enter ID is a feature that allows
users to authenticate once with enter ID
and then access multiple applic ations
and services without having to
authenticate again when a user signs
into enter ID with their credentials
enter ID creates a security token that
can be used to access other resources
within the same organization this token
can be used to authenticate the user to
other cloud-based or on premises
applications that have been integrated
with enter ID SSO supports a wide range
of applications including cloud-based
applications such as Microsoft 3065
Salesforce and Dropbox as well as on
premises applications such as SharePoint
and sap
SSO can also be used with custombuilt
applications using industry standard
protocols such as saml open ID connect
and
oth there are several ways you can
configure an application for SSO
choosing an SSO method depends on how
the application is configured for
authentication Cloud applications can
use open ID connect ooth saml
password-based or linked for SSO single
side on can also be disabled on premises
applications can use password-based
integrated with Windows authentication
header based or linked for SSO the on
premises choices work when applications
are configured for application proxy
this flowchart can help you decide which
SSO method is best for your
situation the main SSO protocol
supported in Azure include open ID
connect and oath open ID connect is an
identity layer built on top of oath 2.0
it allows for authentication and
authorization of users in a secure and
standardized manner it is saml ml is an
xml-based protocol used for exchanging
authentication and authorization data
between an identity provider and a
service provider it is commonly used for
Federated authentication
scenarios password-based authentication
this refers to the traditional username
password authentication method where
users provide their credentials directly
to authenticate linked authentication
Azure provides the ability to link
multiple accounts from different
identity providers to a single user
identity this allows users to
authenticate using any of their linked
accounts
integrated Windows authentication it
will let users access applications using
their Windows domain credentials
utilizing their current Windows session
for
authentication header base
authentication in this method the
application accepts an authentication
token in the form of a header in each
request the token is validated by the
application to authenticate the user
you'll need to be familiar with these
SSO protocols as there will be questions
asking you which SSO protocol is best
suited for a specific
application what is multiactor
authentication a security control where
after you fill in your username email
and password you have to use a second
device such as a phone to confirm that
it's you logging in MFA protects against
people who have stolen your password MFA
is an option in most Cloud providers and
even social media websites such as
Facebook so that's an overview of single
sign on an enter
[Music]
ID let's talk about external identity so
external identities in aad allows people
outside your organization to access your
apps and resources while letting them
sign in uh and use whatever identity
they prefer so your partners
Distributors suppliers vendors or other
guests can bring their own identities
such as uh Google or Facebook uh you can
share apps with external users that's
for B2B stuff uh if you develop apps and
tender for Azure ad tenants uh for
single tener multitenant you can do that
as well uh you can develop white label
apps for consumers and customers so this
would be like azure ad uh B to C so
there you
go the next topic we'll be going over is
conditional access conditional access
provides an extra layer of security
before allowing authenticated users to
access data or other assets conditional
access is implemented via conditional
access policies which are a set of rules
that specify the conditions under which
signin are evaluated and allowed for
example you can create a conditional
access policy that states if the user
account name is a member of a group for
users that are assigned The Exchange
user password security SharePoint or
Global administrator roles require MFA
before allowing access this policy
enables MFA enforcement based on group
membership simplifying the process
compared to configuring MFA for
individual users when roles
change conditional access policy
analyzes signals including user and
location device application and
real-time risk and verifies every access
attempt via access controls this
requires MFA block access and allow
access signals or metadata associated
with an identity attempting to gain
access user or group membership policies
Target specific users and groups giving
admins find grain control over access
named location information IP location
information IP address ranges are used
to permit or deny access based on
geographical locations device policies
can be applied based on the platform or
status of a user device application
users attempting to access specific
applications can trigger different
conditional access
policies realtime sign in Risk detection
signals and Azure ad identity protection
detect risky sign-ins if risks emerge
policies can prompt actions such as
password resets multiactor
authentication or block access pending
admin
intervention Cloud apps or actions can
include or exclude Cloud applications or
user actions that will be subject to the
policy user risk for customer numers
with identity protection user risk can
be evaluated as part of a conditional
access policy user risk represents the
probability that a given Identity or
account is
compromised common decisions Define the
access controls that decide what level
of access based on Signal
information block access most
restrictive decision Grant access least
restrictive decision still require one
or more of the following options require
multiactor authentication require device
to be marked as compliant require hybrid
ENT ID join device require approved
Client app and require app protection
policy conditional access policies are
available and can be utilized with the
following licensing plans Microsoft 365
business premium Microsoft 365 E3 and E5
enter ID premium P1 and enter ID premium
P2
licenses overall conditional access acts
as a robust security measure in Azure
ensuring that authenticated users can
only Access Data under specific
conditions
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are starting our journey for the
sc900 talking about zero trust
methodologies or the zero trust model in
particular uh and this is super
important because it really lays the
foundation of the way we should be
thinking about uh all of the security
that we're going to be doing with an
Azure and actually in any cloud service
providers because the zero trust model
is really uh what is being adopted today
and we'll talk about why that is so the
zero trust model operates on the
principles of trust no one and verify
everything so if you have malicious
actors and they're being able to bypass
conventional access controls and
demonstrates traditional security
measures that's no longer sufficient we
need to come up with a new way uh to
protect ourselves and so that's where uh
Azure or Microsoft in particular has
come up with their version of a Zer
trust model called the Microsoft's zero
trust model and this is based on three
principles and six pillars so in the
three principles we have verify
explicity least privileged access assume
breach for our six pillars we have um
identities endpoints uh an easier way of
thinking about end points is just think
of them as devices apps data
infrastructure and networks and I would
say that if you wanted to put an
emphasis on anything it's going to be
identities which comes down to Azure ad
that seems to be um the largest Focus
here in this entire course and to really
ensuring the zero trust methodology
works the zero trust model is not unique
to Microsoft gcp has its own uh zero
trust model adabs has its own zero trust
model but the one here is just going to
really work for Azure
[Music]
okay okay so let's review the three
principles we said that are in the
Microsoft zero trust model the first is
verify explicity and so this always
authenticates and authorizes based on
all the available data points um the
next one is least privilege access so
limit user access with just in time and
just enough access for risk-based
adaptive policies and data protection
assume breach so minimize blast radius
and segment access verify end to end
encryption and use analy to gain
visibility Drive threat detection
improve defenses now you see me
highlighting things in red uh and I'm
not telling you what they are because we
have a whole section on these things so
don't worry if you see a bunch of terms
and you're just getting overwhelmed uh
we're going to cover them multiple times
uh and so you just understand that we're
going to front load you with a lot of
terms you don't know but you will know
them by the end of this course
[Music]
okay let's take a look here at defense
and depth and so there are seven layers
of security that Azure wants you to know
it kind of maps up to the share
responsibility Model A lot of times we
see these things when um uh
organizations or or CL Cloud providers
are talking about their um security
centers like the actual data centers and
how they're secured but this is more
General uh it doesn't necessarily have
to apply to a data center but uh let's
go and work our way through inside out
okay so the core we have data uh so
access to business and customer data
encryption uh to protect our data then
we have applications so um applications
secure and and free of security
vulnerabilities then you have compute so
access to VMS ports on premise and Cloud
the network limit communications between
resources using segmentation and access
controls the perimeter so uh distribut
Den of service protection to filter
large scale attacks before they can
cause the denial service for users
identity and access so control uh
controlling access to infrastructure and
change uh controls and then you have
physical security so limiting access to
a data center to only authorized
Personnel so the idea is that if you
really want to like if you want to get
to data you got to go through all these
steps here these are all the layers of
Defense um and so I just want to give
extra emphasis to
um this one here identity and access
because this one's like the besides the
physical security this one's the
outermost one so they they will say like
your your your perimeter like the modern
perimeter is defined based on your like
your identity okay we'll see that more
here in this
[Music]
course hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we are taking a look here
at Azure Defender so Azure Defender
provides Advanced protection for your
Azure in on premise workloads and Azure
Defender can be found in the Azure
security Center So within the security
Center there'll be a tab called Azure
Defender and that's the way you find it
so Azure Defender is composed of
coverage security alerts insights and
advanced protection so talking about
coverage it allows you to see the
resource types that are in your
subscription and eligible for protection
by Azure Defender so here take note that
we can see things like virtual machines
kubernetes Services container registry
app Services SQL ver uh VMS Vault uh uh
key vaults SQL servers and storage
accounts for security alerts they
describe details of the affected
resources such as remediation steps and
in some cases an option to trigger a
logic app in response so here you can
kind of see security alerts over time uh
then there are insights this is a
rolling pane of news suggested reading
and high priority alerts uh that give
security centers insights into pressing
security matters that are relevant to
you in your subscription for advanced
protection Within Fender are additional
security features that is driven by
analytics so VM vulnerability
assessments just in time VM access
adaptive application control container
image scanning adaptive Network
hardening SQL vulnerability assessment
file Integrity monitoring Network map
iot security and so down below you can
see all these options here whether
they're turned on or not let's take a
we'll take a look at Network map here in
a moment um so scope of azure Defender
so there it has a lot of different plans
for specific Azure resources so we have
Azure Defender for servers app service
storage SQL kubernetes container
registry key volt resource manager DNS
uh open source relational databases and
when you turn on as your Defender all
plans are activated we saw that under
the advanced protection uh tabs then
just to kind of highlight Network map
because this one's really cool uh it's a
network map that provides a graphic
graphical view with with security
overlays giving you recommendations and
insights for hardening your network
resources is so uh using the map you can
see the network topology of your Azure
workloads uh connections between your
virtual machines and subnets and the
capabilities to drill down from the map
into a specific resource uh resources
and the recommendations of those
resources uh then just the last thing I
want to touch on here is hybrid uh Cloud
protection so Azure Defender can protect
VMS residing in other cloud service
providers such as AWS and gcp Via Azure
Arc so Azure Arc if you've never heard
of it is a control plane that can manage
compute resources across cloud service
providers on premise and at the stage or
at the edge and so for infrastructure
you'll notice that it can handle uh VMS
uh kubernetes clusters SQL servers and
Azure sack
[Music]
hcis hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at multiactor
authentication so what is MFA so MFA is
a security control where after you fill
in your username or maybe it's your
email and password into a login portal
so this login portal could be the Azure
portal this could be you logging into
Facebook uh the idea is that you have to
use a second device such as a phone to
confirm that it's you logging in and so
why do we use MFA well MFA protects uh
against people who have stolen your
password because they might have your
password but they don't have your phone
or whatever device that they're uh
you're using for MFA so um MFA is an
option most Cloud providers have and
just as I said before most social media
uh websites have it so Facebook Twitter
uh they all have it so just to give you
a visual example uh we have a form where
I'm entering my email and password then
we have a phone which is our MFA in this
case and then we get authorization so in
the first case that is one factor right
so if we didn't have to use a phone or
another device that'd be considered one
factor and then multiactor or two Factor
authentication would be the uh the
addition of another uh device to confirm
that that it's you and pretty what
pretty much what's common is to use your
phone and to install an app on your
phone and then what that phone will do
is it will give you a random number that
expires like every I don't know 10
seconds you have to enter that in uh uh
with your username and password or as
the second step and then you gain access
to Azure
[Music]
portal hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we are looking at Azure
security Center so azure security Center
is a unified infrastructure Security
Management System it strengthens the
security posture of your data centers
and provides Advanced threat protection
across your hybrid workloads in the
cloud that sounds really fancy but let's
take a look at what that is so that's
what it is down below it's a bunch of
graphs and it's going to tell you uh if
you are compliant with particular
policies it'll tell you about your
security hygiene all sorts of security
stuff so you have a good visual about
your security within Azure so there you
you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at Key Vault so
Azure key Vault helps you Safeguard
cryptographic keys and other Secrets
used by Cloud apps and services and So
within key Vault it has a bunch of
functionality in it so one thing it can
do is manage your secrets so store uh uh
store and tightly control access to
tokens passwords certificates API keys
and other secrets
it also has Key Management so it it can
create and control encryption Keys used
to encrypt your data then we have
certificate management so easily
provision manage and deploy public and
private SSL certificates for use with
Azure and internal connected resources
uh and then it also is a Hardware
security module so secrets and keys can
be protected either by software or fips
142 or 140 hyphen 2 level two validated
HSM and I told you uh that we would be
talking about fips again and we are
right now so to understand uh um HSM the
last thing we're talking about which
stands for Hardware security module it's
a piece of Hardware designed to store
your encryption keys and it literally
looks like something like that so um uh
Azure would have bought one of these or
tons of these and that is what is
storing your cryptographic keys and this
um piece of Hardware is special because
uh when you store keys on it they're
stored in memory meaning that they're
not ridden to disk if that thing shuts
down uh the the keys are gone and nobody
can steal your data it's just a security
measure and that security measure has to
do with fips okay so fips 1405 and 2 is
a us and Canadian government standard
that specifies the security requirements
for cryptographic modules that protect
sensitive information so for hsms that
are multi-tenant they're generally going
to be 140 hyphen 2 compliant
multi-tenant meaning that um that
there's more than one customer that is
using that piece uh piece of Hardware
but they're virtually isolated from each
other uh and then if you have a single
tenant HSM they're generally going to be
fips 140 hypen 3 compliance so a single
customer on a dedicated HSM um it's
better to be fips 140 hyphen 3 compliant
um but fips 140 hyphen 2 is pretty good
for most people so there you
[Music]
go hey this is and Brown from exam Pro
and we're taking a look here at dos so
this stands for distributed denial of
service attack and it's a malicious
attempt to disrupt normal traffic by
flooding a website with large amounts of
fake traffic so the idea is you have an
attacker and a victim and the attacker
is utilizing remote machines and uh with
a with some software that's going to
generate out traffic uh directed towards
your virtual machine over the cloud and
the uh problem here is that what it's
going to do is it's going to make uh
your website unresponsive
or just not work at all for the regular
user but by having your compute within
the Azure Network you're going to get
free dos protection and that's going to
mitigate uh these attacks so let's talk
about the types of um dos attacks that
frequently happen the first is
volumetric attacks so these are volume
based attacks that flood the network
with legitimate looking traffic these
will exhaust the available bandwidth and
legitimate users cannot access the
website these are measured in bits per
second so BPS then there are protocol
attacks and these are exhausting server
Resources with false uh protocol
requests that exploit weakness you're
looking at UDP and TCP flooding on the
layer three and four measured in
packages per second so PSP then you have
application layer attacks these are
attacks that occur at the application
layer uh that's B layer 7 so you're
looking at HTTP floods SQL injection
cross-site scripting also known as xss
parameter tamping Solus attacks here
you're going to be wanting using a w web
application firewall as a means of
protection WS are generally uh paired a
lot a lot together with DOs Services
across the cloud service provider um uh
offerings okay so Azure offers two tiers
of Dos protection the first is uh the
the basic tier this is free it's already
turned on uh it's part of the global
Network and then you have the standard
that starts at about
2,900 uh about 3,000 USD you get metrics
alerts reporting dos expert support
application and cost protections SLA
there's probably a difference in terms
of the tier protection I cannot remember
off the top of my head but you know one
will protect more likely against certain
types of attacks like like three and
four and the other one will do all all
the layers 3 four and seven
[Music]
okay Azure firewall is a managed
cloud-based network security service
that protects Azure v-ets resources and
it's a fully stateful firewall as a
service so you're going to get built-in
High availability and unrestricted cloud
scalability and what you can do is uh
essentially create enforce and log
application network connectivity
policies across subscription and virtual
networks so Azure firewall uses a static
public IP address for your v-net
resources allowing outside firewalls to
identify uh originating from your
virtual Network and the service is fully
integrated with Azure monitor for
logging and analytics so here is a
representation of azure firewall and so
the idea is that you're going to launch
an Azure firewall into its own v-net and
then other v-net and you're on premise
or other things are going to pass
through that Central v-net onto wherever
they want to go and the idea is that
we're going to be able to uh do things
like utilize Microsoft threat
intelligence this is going to block
known malicious IPS in
fqdns that stands for fully qualified
domain names and by default the traffic
is uh set to deny uh but you can set
connectivity policies to filter out
traffic in a variety of ways to make
sure that you are protected uh there so
yeah that's all there is to
[Music]
it so Azure has uh a few different kinds
of load balancers and one in particular
is the application Gateway and this is
for application Level routing and load
balancing service so application Gateway
operates at the OS I layer 7 uh which is
also known as the application layer and
the idea here is that when you're
working about applications you're
working with HTTP requests that's what
it is uh and so the idea is that it can
look at the contents of the HBU request
and do some interesting things so maybe
it's looking at the path and saying okay
you're uh if you have a path um and it's
payments go to the VM that has their
payment system and then if it's for
admin go to the VM that does that uh
maybe it has to do with something with
cookies or um maybe you want to apply a
WAFF policy to it and so you can look at
those HB requests and determine if it is
malicious traffic and filter it out uh
so uh yeah it's all about the
application which has to do with HP
requests to configure this thing you
need to set up a front ends uh Runing
rules and backend pools and there are
two configurations for the front end you
can either have it with a private IP
which makes it now an internal load
bouncer or a public IP which makes it
either we would call a public or
external load bouncer uh and there's a
both I've never used that option before
um but I mean you just really need to
know the public and private for the
backends you create create backend pools
and a backend pool is just a collection
of resources to which your application
Gateway sends traffic uh and so a
backend pool can contain virtual
machines virtual machine scale sets IP
addresses domain names app
Service uh and I think you can also send
it to like on Prem uh so let's just talk
about routing rules which connects the
front end and the back end together and
so uh here is a more complex example
gives you a better idea of the service
uh uh at full uh and so the idea is that
you have your application Gateway it's
going to send uh traffic or sorry like a
DNS is going to send to application
Gateway and then you have these
listeners and they they listen for
incoming traffic uh and then what it
will do it will pass on that to a rule
and a rule just really says who should
we pass the data to uh and then if you
are defining a backend pool then you
need to have um an HTP setting that says
how do we handle the HTTP requests okay
and so now we'll just look at more
granular detail about requests or
routing rules
[Music]
let's take a closer look at routing
rules this is where all the magic
happens so a listener listens on a
specified Port an IP address for traffic
that uses a specified protocol if the
listener criteria met the application
Gateway will apply the routing Rule and
these come in two flavors we got basic
which fors all requests for any domain
to back in pools and multisite forward
requests to different backend pools
based on host header and host name so
the thing is is that uh you uh you can
have multiple listeners and you can have
an order of them and the idea is that
you really want the basic to be on the
uh be in last in priority because if
it's a first it's going to capture
everything because that's its job it's
like a catch allall uh so just make sure
that um if you're using multiple
listeners you put basic last uh so
that's just something you need to know
then for those backend Targets this is
where we either Define a backend pool or
redirection redirection is just an HTP
redirection like uh 403 or whatever you
have their temporary or permanent very
simple uh but for backend pools you have
to create HTP settings uh and this tells
us a little bit more about how we want
to handle HTTP you know cookies cook uh
connection draining Port request Etc
let's talk about that a little bit more
so here are the actual options that we
can configure for HTP settings so you
have your backend Port uh so generally
it's either Port 80 or 443 it just
depends on where you're doing your SSL
termination uh but generally um if you
need end to end encryption it'll be 443
or uh and then if you are doing connect
or if you're doing SSL termination at
the blow balcer then it's
80 um then you have cookie base Affinity
this allows you to keep a user session
on the same server so if you need to
persist cookies and use them for
authentication you'll want to enable
that you got connection draining this
gracefully uh removes backend pool
members during plan service updates so
the idea is that you know when there is
an update it's not just going to
abruptly cut over it's going to wait
until a connection disconnects from a
server before uh not no longer sending
more requests there cuz you don't want a
a connection dropping in the middle of
an update it's not great for a user then
you have request timeouts this is the
number of seconds the application
Gateway will will wait to receive a
response from the backend pool before it
Returns the connection timeout error
message and last our um oh sorry we
still have override backin path these
allow you to override the path in the
URL so the request for a spe a specific
path can be red to another path the idea
is imagine you want to send it to um
bananas and you want bananas actually
internally route to oranges I don't know
why you want to do that or maybe to
plantains that make a lot more sense so
something you can do uh and the last one
is the override the host name so
application Gateway normally leaves the
host name alone uh but you know if
you're using multi-tenant services like
apps uh like app service or API
management it needs very specific host
header set so this is where you can
override them and change them for those
services so hopefully that really gives
you a good picture of application
Gateway but I feel that that's all you
really need to
know
so let's take a closer look here at
Azure ro-based access controls because
this is something we're definitely going
to be using a lot and so Ro based Access
Control helps you manage who has access
to Azure resources what they can do with
those resources and what areas they have
have access to and the idea is that you
have a user and you want to assign them
a role so you're going to use a role
assignment and a role assignment is made
up of three elements you have the
security principle the RO definition and
the scope and we're going to look at
those three things in a little bit more
detail here in a second and there are
four fundamental Azure roles which we
are going to learn and then Azure rbac
also includes over 70 built-in roles
which we definitely do not need to go
into great detail uh so let's take a
look at uh one of those three elements
first which is the security principle
and this represents the identity
requesting access to an Azure resource
and when we say identity that's just
like a loose term for something and that
something could be a user in your Azure
active directory a group uh which
defines a set of users in your Azure
active directory a service principle so
a sec security identity used by
applications or services to access
specified Azure resources or a managed
identity an identity in your active uh
Azure active directory that is
automatically managed by Azure so
service principle basically an Azure
service and then managed identity is
something in your Azure active
directory then we'll move on to scope
and a scope is just a set of resources
that um access that uh assess um the
role uh the RO assignment applies to and
so scope access controls at the
management subcription or Resource Group
level so what does that mean and we we
have another slide on this I can't
remember what section it's in but you
have this breakdown of scope where you
have management groups subscriptions
resource groups or resources so when
you're saying I'm setting a scope you're
saying what is a scope is it on a
management group is it on a particular
resource is it a resource Group and
that's what we're trying to say there
and then last the last element there is
a role definition and this is a
collection of permission
so role definition lists operations that
can be performed such as read write and
delete and roles can be highle like
owner specific or like a virtual machine
reader and so Azure has uh built-in
roles and we said there were four
fundamental built-in roles and here they
are it's owner contributor reader and
user admin uh administrator so you want
to know those four and then across the
board you have those three um operations
read Grant
and then create update delete so you can
see the owner can do everything the
contributor can uh both read and create
stuff they just can't Grant access other
people the reader just has readon access
and then a user access administrator is
granting other users uh privileges but
themselves are not creating anything all
[Music]
right hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and let's look at Azure management
groups so Azure management groups is a
way of managing multile multiple
subscriptions and when you hear the word
subscriptions in Azure just think
accounts um because that's an easier way
to think about it into a hierarchial
structure so each directory is given a
single top level management group called
The Root Management Group all
subscriptions within a Management Group
automatically uh inherit the conditions
applied to the management group and so
this is a graphical representation so at
the top you have your Root Management
Group and then you can create management
groups underneath so Human Resources it
marketing production
developers whatever you want and
underneath you have those individual
subscriptions again just think of them
like an account so that is azure
management
[Music]
groups hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we're looking at Azure
service health so this is about
information about current upcoming
issues such as service impacting events
planned maintenance and other changes
that may affect your availability so
going down the list we have Azure status
which informs you of uh service outages
in Azure Azure service Health a is a
personalized view of the health of the
Azure service and regions you're using
and then Azure resource health is
information about the health of the
individual Cloud resources such as your
VM so if you're ever wondering uh the
state of your health you can use Azure
service health and if you noticed it was
an option under Azure monitor so if
you're looking for it that's where you
go to find
it
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're looking at Azure advisor so ad
Azure advisor is a personalized Cloud
consultant that helps you follow best
practices to optimize your Azure
deployments the a the advisor uh
dashboard displays personalized
recommendations for all your
subscriptions for the following five
categories High availability security
performance cost and operational
excellence and since we are in the
security category that's what we mostly
care about is security but it would also
be important for the uh pricing section
there as well so the first one we're
going to look at is actually um the
Azure advisor recommendation for cost so
here you can see that it's telling you
uh where the most impact can occur and
leav tell you how much money you can
save if you follow its
recommendations then you have security
and so here it has 21 recommendations if
we were to click into it it would tell
you what kind of things that you could
improve in your system uh to improve
your security so there you go that's
Azure
ad
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at Azure database
Services starting at the top of list is
azure Cosmos DB this is a fully managed
no scoll database it's designed for
scale with guarantee of
99.999% availability uh Azure loves
talking about this database it's their
Flagship database because it works at
incredible scale and an incredible
performance so whenever you're thinking
about like uh like super large databases
think of azure Cosmos DB next on our
list is Azure SQL database and even
though it doesn't have it in its name
this is for the mssql uh engine so if
you're running Microsoft SQL uh you're
going to want to use this it's fully
managed with autoscale integ uh integral
intelligence robust security so has a
lot of great features built around this
for mssql databases now if you're not
using mssql and you're using something
like MySQL postgress or Marb they have
Azure database so it's fully managed and
scalable uh with high availability and
security
then you have SQL server on VMS uh again
it doesn't have it in its name but it's
Microsoft SQL uh engine okay anytime uh
it says SQL servers just assume that
it's the Microsoft flavor of SQL um and
and the idea for this one is that if you
already have SQL servers running on
premise uh within your data center and
you want to move them onto Azure uh this
is where You' use a lift and shift so it
takes those virtual machines and
directly moves them onto the cloud you
don't don't get all the functionality
that you would with Azure SQL database
but it's the easiest way to get onto the
cloud then you have Azure synapsis
analytics previously known as Azure SQL
data warehouse It's because they added
an analytics component to it um but it's
a fully managed data warehouse with
integ uh integral uh security at every
level of scale at no extra cost then you
have as your database migration service
so migrate your databases to the cloud
with no application code changes so
there's that service then you have Azure
cache for Reddit so if you need an
in-memory cache that is using the open
source redus you can use that and last
on our list is azure table storage we
mentioned this in the storage services
but to me this is a database it's not a
storage service um even though it's
named as such so wide column no s
database a noq store that hosts
unstructured data independent of any
schema so there you go that's the
Azure database
[Music]
Services hey this is Andre Brown from
exam Pro and we are looking at
application integration services on
Azure now I didn't have room on the
slide for this but just to tell you what
application integration is these are
services that are designed to help apps
or Services talk to each other so it's
basically the glue of services the First
on our list here is azure notifications
Hub this is using publisher subscription
technology underneath and this is for
sending push notifications to any
platform from any back end next we have
Azure API apps so this is essentially an
API Gateway so you can quickly build and
consume apis in the cloud and then th
those apis will have API endpoints and
you can route them to Azure services or
maybe functions or containers uh but
it's a way of building an API in the
cloud then you have Azure service bus
and as the name implies it is a service
bus uh so reliable Cloud messaging as a
service Maas and simple hybrid
integration I know that's not very clear
uh that is the language that Microsoft
uses to describe it but just what you
need to know is that it is a service bus
then you have Azure stream analytics so
this is serverless realtime analytics
remember that world word real time and
think of this service uh from the cloud
to the edge then you have Azure logic
apps so you can schedule automate
orchestrate tasks business processes and
workflows and it integrates with
enterprise sassin Enterprise
applications then you have Azure API
management this can be confusing because
we have another service called Azure API
apps I don't know what we would
generally call this service uh they say
it's a hybrid multicloud management
platform for apis across all
environments whatever that means but the
when I looked at it what it does is you
can put this in front of an existing API
to add additional functionality so if
you have an API you put it in front of
it and it and it's a basically proxy to
your API and you get all this additional
stuff then last on our list is azure Q
storage we saw this in our storage
service sections and I had said that I
don't really consider this a storage
service I consider it an application
integration Service uh and this is a
messaging queue so it's a data store for
queuing and reliably delivering messages
between applications so there you go
that is the application integration
services on
azure
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at developer and
mobile tools uh that are commonly used
with Azure the first on the list is
azure signal R service and this is a
real-time messaging service not to be
confused uh with Azure notification
service this is for easily adding
real-time web functionality to
Applications so if you ever heard of
Pusher it's just like Pusher so um that
is the equivalent there the next we have
is azure app service so easy to use
service for deploying and scaling web
applications with net nodejs Java Python
and PHP I'm a bit sad I don't see Ruby
in there but what are you going to do um
so it's for developers who want to focus
on building their web apps and not worry
about the underlying infrastructure so
if you've ever used Heroku think of it
like that but for Azure next you have a
a visual studio um and visual studio is
a code editor it's it it's basically an
IDE an integrated development
development environment designed for
creating powerful scalable applications
for Azure you might have heard of Visual
Studio code um which is similar but
different um but I just wanted to make
mention of Visual Studio here then you
have uh zamarin I think I'm pronouncing
it right and it's a mobile app framework
um it's for creating powerful and
scalable native mobile apps andet and
Azure um and yeah so that is the
developer in Mobile tools for
[Music]
Azure hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at Azure devops
services so Azure devops is really just
an umbrella service for a bunch of
modern Dev services and we'll jump into
them right away first being Azure boards
if you've ever used a can band board
that is what Azure boards is and if You'
ever use GitHub projects it literally is
that because Azure uh and GitHub are
owned by the same company Microsoft and
so they brought over that technology to
Azure so deliver value to your users
faster using proven agile tools to plan
track and discuss work across your teams
then you have Azure pipeline so build
test and deploy cicd that works with any
language platform and Cloud connect to
GitHub or any other git provider and
deploy continuously so if you need
automatic deployments that's what Azure
pipelines is for then you have Azure
repos and this is exactly like GitHub
repos so get unlimited co uh Cloud
hosted private G repos and collaborate
to build better code with pull request
and advanced file management I really
mean it's just like GitHub repos because
it's just that technology moved over to
Azure then you have Azure test plans so
test and ship with confidence using
manual and exploratory testing tools so
this is just a way of setting up test so
if you ever use like um what's it called
Cypress or any other like uh or any
other testing tools it's just built into
Azure it'll open up a browser and it'll
literally test your app and make sure it
works as expected then you have Azure
artifact so create host and share
packages with your team so this is just
package management but specifically for
cicd pipelines so cicd pipelines they
have to set up these servers and you
have to have pre-installed packages
that's just going to make it a lot
easier for you last is azure Dev test
Labs so this is just an easy way to
create Dev test environments for your
developers and that is the Azure devops
services
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at the cloud native
networking Services now these networking
Services aren't super uh super important
for the exam I like to go through them
generally I would make an architectural
diagram for this but it's just a bit too
complicated so I thought we'll just go
through and list them so first is azure
DNS and we do describe this service uh
later in uh the course here but this
provides an ultra fast DNS responses and
ultra high domain availability so if you
have a domain name and you just want it
to be managed by um Azure you can
associate it with Azure DNS then you
have Azure virtual network uh we talked
about this prior but we'll talk about it
again um short for v-net a logical
isolated section of your Azure Network
for customers to launch Azure resources
within then you have Azure load balancer
and as the name implies it is a load
balancer but this one is at level four
transport um so it doesn't really
understand requests like what a web
application would send it's more lower
level
um and so that's what that is then you
have Azure application Gateway and this
is an HTTP load bouncer so it does
understand um like requests coming from
a web server and what you can do with it
is you can actually route um based on HP
request to specific services but it also
you can apply a web application firewall
because it is an application load balcer
that's why you can apply that web
application firewall which is a separate
service then you have network security
groups so uh this is a way of protecting
your subnets so it's a virtual firewall
around your subnets where you can say
allow these um allow these ports to be
open um and and from who and and and
such so there you go that's the cloud
native networking services and the
reason why they're Cloud native
networking is because you wouldn't use
these with Enterprise or on uh or uh or
in Hybrid models is just what you
normally use and most startups would be
using all these Cloud uh these
networking
services
[Music]
so next we have Enterprise or hybrid
networking services so this is when
you're using a networking that is going
to bridge on Prem to the cloud so the
first is azure front door so this is a
scalable and secure entry point for fast
delivery of your Global applications so
just making sure you have a secure entry
point into Azure from outside then you
have Azure express route you want to
remember this one definitely for the
exam it probably will show up as a
question this is a connection between
your on premise to Azure cloud and it
can be between 50 megabytes per second
to 10 gigabytes per second I'm pretty
sure it's also secure um but the point
is that if you need a super super fast
connection uh from your on-prem uh data
center to Azure you'd use this service
express route remember it it's going to
be on your exam then you have virtual
Wan so a network service that brings
many networking security routing uh
functionality together to provide a
single operations operational interface
I know that sounds complicated but a w
is just a way of making networking
Easier by creating like a hub spoke
model uh then you have Azure connection
so a VPN connection securely connects to
Azure local networks via IPC so that's
just a way of uh creating a secure
connection uh with Azure then you have
virtual Network Gateway a site tosite
VPN connection between Azure virtual
Network and your local network so this
just way of connecting with azzure um so
there you go that is um the networking
[Music]
Services hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we are looking at Azure
traffic manager so this service operates
at the DNS layer to quickly and
efficiently direct incoming DNS requests
based on the routing method of your
choice so what you do is you'd um choose
a routing method so we got performance
weighted priority geog Geographic
multivalue subnet um and You' be able to
reroute your traffic so you could Route
traffic to servers geographically uh
nearby to reduce latency fail over to uh
redundant systems in case primary
systems become unhealthy or route to
random uh virtual machines to simulate
AB testings I think like the best use
Cas is failovers um for DN at the DNS
level I think that's a great one uh and
just a visual example here imagine we
had exampro doco and we had a production
and a beta server and we only wanted 20%
of our users to see the beta server so
we could use um I guess we' use weighted
there and we'd say 80% on prod 20% there
and that's how that would work so there
you go that's Azure traffic
[Music]
manager hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we are looking at iot
services on Azure and so before we get
into it what is iot so iot stands for
internet of things so a network of
Internet connected objects usually
Hardware able to connect and exchange
data so here is a graphical
representation of iot devices maybe you
recognize some but let's just go through
a quick list of things that could be iot
devices so you have Smart bulbs so maybe
there's light bulbs in your house that
are controlled by the internet smart
fridges who doesn't want one of those
smart light switches narrow band or
wideband Hardware this is just a way of
connecting to the internet it's just
like uh it's kind of like Wi-Fi um then
you have security cameras then you have
voice command speakers so think of like
Alexa then you might have temperature
pressure or imunity sensors if you're in
the farming industry you can you you can
Le leverage iot devices for that maybe
uh you have drones uh maybe you have
phones that could be an IT device and
even buttons so uh AWS had these things
called AWS or Dash buttons uh they
weren't popular but the idea was you
could like press a button and like
purchase something um so like if you
always had to get like soap for your
washer you can have that button right on
your washer um but let's actually talk
about the iot services here um so the
first one here is iot Central so this
allows you to connect your iot devices
to the cloud then you have iot Hub so
this is this enables highly secure and
reliable Communications between your iot
applications and devices it manages uh
then you have iot Edge this is a fully
managed service built on the Azure iot
Hub it allows you allows data processing
an analyst near the iot devices so this
is really Edge Computing I really should
have highlighted that for you but this
is where you are able to offload your
compute from the cloud to local
Computing Hardware such as iot devices
phones or home computers so it's just a
way of saving money or utilizing your
local network for compute then you have
uh Windows 10 iot core services so this
is a cloud services subscription that
provides the essential Services need to
commercialize a device on Windows iot or
10 iot core so basically it's long-term
OS support and services to manage device
updates and uh assess device health all
right so there you go that's your iot
[Music]
services hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we are looking at Big Data
and analytics services on Azure so
before we jump into it let's talk about
what is Big Data so it is a term used to
describe massive volumes of structured
and unstructured data that is so large
it is difficult to move and process
using traditional database and software
techniques so we need spe
Services just to handle them the First
on our list here is azure synapsis
analytics formerly known as SQL data
warehouse so it is Enterprise data
warehousing and big data analytics so
it's intended to run SQL queries against
large databases to generate things such
as
reporting um then you have HD Insight HD
is short for Hadoop um but anyway it
runs open source analytics software such
as Hadoop kofka and sparkk I imagine it
was called HD Insight because it only
supported Hadoop and then they added
additional services but that's just what
it's called then you have Azure data
bricks so uh we have an Apache spark
based analytics platform optimized for
Microsoft aure cloud service platforms
so thirdparty data bricks cloud services
support with Azure so data bricks was
made by the uh creators of spark and yes
of course you can run sparc on hdnight
but uh data bricks is its own cloud
service provider and as you're partnered
up with them so that you can use it
within uh the Azure platform then you
have data Lake analytics so an OnDemand
analytics job service that simplifies
big data uh and we saw what data Lakes
were when we looked at storage services
but we'll describe them here just in a
diff a little bit different way a data
lake is a storage repository that holds
a vast amount of raw data in its native
format until it is needed so there you
go that is the big data and analytic
Services we need to
know
hey this is angrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at artificial
intelligence and machine learning
services on Azure so a great way of
describing that is to always have this
graphic here where we have this kind of
like onion thing where each is dependent
on the other and we'll start with
artificial intelligence so what is
artificial intelligence or AI this is
where machines that perform jobs that
mimic human behavior now that doesn't
mean that uh the the technology behind
it has to be complex it could be FL
statements but it could be utilizing
machine learning it could be utilizing
deep learning but the point is that it
mimics human behavior then you have
machine learning and this is where
machines that get better at a task
without explicit
programming um so they are smart enough
to learn on their own then you have deep
learning and so deep learning is where
machines that have an artificial neural
network inspired by the human brain to
solve complex problems so literally it's
like the power of the human brain uh
maybe not as not as great as is the
human brain but quite quite close there
and AI could be leveraging ML and uh
deep learning and so that's why it is
like that so when we want to do uh
machine learning on Azure they have a
service called Azure machine learning
service so this is a service that uh uh
that simplifies running AI uh ml related
workloads allowing you to build flexible
pipelines to automate workflows so you
can use Python and R you can run your uh
deep learning workloads using
Technologies such as tensor flow um and
so that's what you'd use now there was a
service called Azure machine Learning
Studio I think it's still around if you
uh if you're still using it and that's
the classic version of the service and
it does basically what Azure machine
learning service does but there's some
limitation so does not have uh like a
pipeline and other functionalities and
if you're wondering if you could easily
migrate from classic to the other one um
it's not easy to migrate um so basically
you definitely always want to start with
Azure machine learning services there's
no reason you'd want to use Azure
machine Learning Studio unless you're
using it for legacy
[Music]
reasons hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we're still looking at Ai
and ml Services specifically just AI
Services because Azure has a lot of them
and I'm just going to quickly go through
them and they're pretty
self-explanatory so first one is
personalizer it delivers Rich
personalized experiences for every user
using AI then you have translator it
adds real-time multilanguage text
translation to your apps websites and
tools you have anomaly detector detects
anomalies and data to quickly identify
and troubleshoot issues Azure bot
service intelligent serverless bot
service that scales on demand form recog
uh uh recognizer automate the extraction
of text key value Pairs and tables from
your documents you have computer vision
easily customized computer vision models
for Unique use cases language
understanding so build build a natural
language understanding into Apps Bots
and iot devices we have Q&A maker so
create a conversational question and
answer bot from your existing content
text analytics extract information such
as sentiment key phrases named entities
and languages from your text content
moderator so moderate text and images to
provide a safer more positive user
experience face so detect and identify
people and emotions in images Inc uh uh
uh recognizer recognize digital ink
content and such as handwriting shapes
and document layouts so there you go
they have a lot of services and they
haven't even made time to make all icons
for them that's how many they
[Music]
have hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at servess
services on Azure so what is serverless
this is one the underlying server
servers infrastructure and Os is taking
care care of by the cloud service
provider it will generally be highly
available scalable and coste effective
so serverless is event driven at scale
so uh a seress function can be triggered
or trigger other events allowing you to
compose complex application and just
scale so with serverless technology it's
like playing with Lego blocks um then
you have abstraction of servers so
servers are abstracted away your code is
described as functions these functions
can be running on different compute
instances so if some people like to use
python or some people like to use
JavaScript you can mix and match um uh
there then you have Micro billing so
when you have traditional servers you
probably build by at least a second some
build by the hour but the thing is if
you're not using the server for the
whole second or hour you are paying for
a compute that you are not using so
serverless functions will bill you in
the microsc so you're saving money
because you're not paying for unused
computation uh now we'll just quickly
walk through uh some of the Serv
Services I'm sure there's more than this
but this is what I think are worth
highlighting so the first is azure
functions so run small amounts of code
known as seress functions in your
favorite languages so you got C Java
JavaScript Python and Powershell and if
Azure is listening please can you
support Ruby because I love using Ruby
then you have blob storage so this is
seress object storage just upload your
files don't think about the underlying
file systems resizing uh basically
unlimited space and and you can upload
pretty darn large files then you have
logic apps allows you to build seress
workflows composed of azure functions
building a I would say this is you
building a state machine for seress
compute then you have event Bridge which
seems a bit similar but it's not it uses
Pub sub messaging systems to allow you
to react to events and Trigger other
Azure cloud services such as Azure
functions so there you go that is
serverless
[Music]
Services hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and I'm going to show you how
to create resource groups and the reason
why we're going to make one is because
without one we're not going to be able
to launch pretty much any resource until
we do so because you always have to
choose a resource Group when launching
uh Azure resources so even though it
shows up here on our dashboard um if it
doesn't I want you to go up here at the
top and type in Resource Group and we'll
go ahead and click Resource Group here
and then all the way on the left hand
side I want you to click on
ADD and uh we're just going to have to
use our R trial which is the our type of
subscription I'm just going to type in
exam Pro as the resource Group we're
going to stay in Us East uh because that
is where the most uh most of the
services are available in Azure and
that's what I'm going to be using
throughout um this course is always
using Us East so we'll go down here and
hit create plus uh review plus create
because there's really nothing else to
check and once validation passed this
might happen instantaneously for you you
might have to wait a few seconds go
ahead and hit create
and so um now we have created our
Resource Group and there is no cost
resource groups so there's no worry
about uh having this or whether you uh
keep it around don't delete it uh you're
going to notice that the group hasn't
showed up just yet you're going to have
to hit refresh and sometimes Azure is a
bit slow about uh showing resources when
you create them initially and when you
delete them so I'm just going to wait a
little bit here and I'm just going to
keep on refreshing and I'll see you back
in a few minutes all right so waited a
couple minutes and if you just go ahead
up here and hit refresh now we can see
that we have our Resource Group so
that's all there really is to it nothing
super exciting there I'm just going to
click Microsoft Azure at the top here to
get back to my dashboard and I'll see
you in the next follow
[Music]
along okay great so now that we've uh
done that let's actually go learn how to
do a different kind of compute which is
serverless functions so uh if we want to
launch our own serverless function uh by
the the way if you're not at the screen
just click on Microsoft Azure here at
the top and we're going to go to our
search and we're going to type in
functions and so on the left hand side I
want you to click on
ADD and then uh what we're doing is we
need to create a function app so we're
going to be on our free trial we're
going to choose our Resource Group we
created earlier we're going to name this
I'm going to just call this um this is
the function app name so I'm going just
say my my
app uh my app is not available these all
unique names I'm just call it exam Pro
app you might have to change this a few
times before you get what you want um
and then for publish we're going to use
code we don't want to use a Docker
container that's too much work and we're
going to just choose nodejs which is
just JavaScript version 12 sounds great
to me we're going to change this to make
it sure that it's Us East to make our
lives a little bit easier there's
nothing wrong with Central it's just I
want everything to be consistent so
everything is very predictable in these
um uh in these follow alongs here we'll
go all the way to the top and look at
hosting just quickly here we're going to
see that we have a storage account okay
nothing exciting here it's going to
either be Linux or Windows this doesn't
really matter to us we can let it be
Windows we're going to go back to basic
I'm going to go ahead and hit review
plus
create so we're going to wait for this
validation to uh step to complete here
so again it could take a second or it
could take a minute just depends on the
day with Azure so we'll just wait here a
little
bit there we go it's just finished
validating I'm going to go ahead and hit
create
and now we're waiting for that initial
deployment so we're going to see that
deployment is on its way and then we're
going to have to wait for deployment to
be
complete so it's in progress It's
underway this shouldn't take too long it
should say that it's complete here in a
moment great so after waiting a few
minutes here our deployment is complete
we'll go ahead and hit go to resources
so now what we need to do is we need to
go create ourselves a function so on the
left hand side make your way to function
and then in here we're going to add
ourselves a new
function and so we have a lot of presets
here for us it's not going to matter
what we choose well it does um and I'm
going to say let's choose HTTP
trigger we're going to leave it with a
default name that's fine uh we'll have
it uh stay as function for authorization
level we'll go ahead and create that
function so once that function is has
been created here and it's already done
let's start adding our code because
again the whole point of server list is
that you don't have to worry about
servers you just add your code and it
works and so here's some code it already
has for us what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to add myself a console log
uh console log is just like saying hello
world so we're going to say hello
world and then I'm going to hit
save and now it's just connecting to
application insights I don't know if
it's actually running yeah it's
connected great and now let's go ahead
and hit test and so we have a bunch of
options here I'm not going to fill in
anything I'm just going to hit run and
we're going to see what the output
is okay great so you know I'm just
looking at how this actually works and
um I think what we need to do is we need
to actually pass a name into the uh to
the query string here so what we'll do
is we're just going to go ahead and type
in query here and we'll put a name and
we'll say
Andrew
um and so that should do it so let's
just hit
run
okay great and so it's saying uh hello
Andrew so there you go that's all you
have to do to uh create a serverless
function um and it doesn't cost us
anything to keep this around so we don't
necessarily have to delete it uh if you
did want to go delete it I guess we can
go back here uh we'd have to go back to
functions
here and I would just click
delete and we'll type in yes and we'll
hit delete
and there you go so that's that's all
there is there uh there to it for uh
serverless compute I can go back to
Microsoft Azure here back to the
dashboard and we'll see you in the next
fall
[Music]
along hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at slas for Azure
so SLA stands for service level
agreement and this describes azure's
commitment for uptime and connectivity
that uh that means like if you have a
web server Azure is going to say yeah we
we guarantee 99.9% of the time it's
going to remain uh running throughout
the year it's not going to go down so
that's kind of the idea behind an SLA um
for Azure slas are indiv individualized
per Azure service so they don't have
broad uh slas you're going to have to
investigate each service to figure out
um what uh the commitment of azure is
for that service um and the way we
describe um uh these slas in terms of up
time and connectivity is through
performance targets now a performance
Target is just a representation in the
form of a percentage so if somebody were
to say to you um you know this service H
uh is 99% likely of not failing that's
called two NES and then you have the
three nines and then you have five NES
and then you have nine NES and and the
higher this number goes up the more uh
reliable uh the the uh better coverage
this SLA is going to give you so you
want something that has a higher number
of nines and it's not always just nines
it could be
99.95% um but just understand that when
someone says 9 N they're talking about
that last value there and it is like one
of the highest um one of the highest
guarantees that SLA can give I can't
remember if there's like 119 there might
be 11 9 uh but generally 9 N is the
upper limit uh and just to uh uh mention
is that for Azure if you are using the
free tier or shared tiers you do not get
SLA because they just do not provide
support for those because you're
consuming everything for free so you
have to be paying to get the advantage
of that SLA garantee so I did say that
the slas are uh service specific um and
so if you want to actually go
investigate all you got to do is type in
Azure SLA into Google and you should be
able to make your way to this page and
what we can do is we can click into uh
any of these here so if I go to database
and we choose uh Cosmos DB and we just
expand our information here we get tons
of information about their slas and then
our performance targets are down here so
we have this for availability this is
for read availability um so they have a
lot of information uh and as I said it's
for basically any service anything you
want just click into it and they have
all that SLA information so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at service
credits for Azure so a service credit is
when a custom customer would get a
discount on their Azure bill as comp as
compensation for an underperforming
Azure product or service based on the
SLA so those guarantees that Azure gives
if they don't meet those guarantees then
they owe you money uh and the way they
do it is through credits right so
credits is just like virtual money uh I
actually don't know what a uh like what
a service credit is worth but I just
know that you know if they if they do
not meet those slas they're going to
back it and give you your money back in
some sense
uh so um just an example here if we have
Azure virtual machine remember a virtual
machine is a server uh if you had uh
monthly uptime percentage of 99.9 so if
it was under that then you'd get a
service credit of 10% if it was under 99
then you get a service credit of
25% and if it was under 95 you get a
service credit of
100% so um I guess what that means is
maybe it's the cost of what you spend
spent uh but anyway I'm not exactly sure
um but I would take a guess that if if
let's say the up time was under 95% and
they're going to give you a service
credit of 100% maybe it's 100% of your
resources given back to you so if you
spend $100 you get that $100 back so
there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at composite SLA
so we had said earlier that um different
Services have different
slas uh and the problem with that is
that when you have different servers
different slas it's kind of hard to
understand what the actual guarantee is
when you use them uh in combination so
composite slas is just a way of
understanding what the actual uh SLA
guarantee underneath is for the
performance Target so imagine you have a
web application and that web application
uses an SQL database so the web app has
a guarantee of
99.95% because maybe that's the um the
performance Target for the virtual
machine and then the SQL database is 99.
99% so what is it is it 95 99.95% or is
it 49 we don't know so if we had to
calculate that calculate that for the
SLA with the web app and SQL database
that would uh come out to
99.94% don't ask me on the math that is
the example that we are given but just
understand that that's what it would
come out to be it would come out to
99.94% and so you'd have an overall
reduction of the SLA whereas the SQL
database would have 9 99.9% so how could
we improve our SLA and consider that in
our design so we get the uh the SLA that
we want and so what you can do is you
can add in fallback systems that will
improve the overall SLA and if you
logically think about it it makes sense
why that would work so imagine you have
that SQL database and it goes down but
if you had a que uh and that Q was
saving all the transaction attempts that
the web app was trying to write to the
database and saved in the queue it
wouldn't matter if the database went
down because once the database went back
up all those transactions would be there
and then those transactions would then
complete and so by using the Q which has
a
99.9% up time uh based on the math down
below again don't ask me how the math
works but the the the outcome would be
an SLA of 99.95% and so that's uh an
improvement over 99.94%
so that is comp composite slas and there
you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the TCO
calculator for Azure so if you remember
uh earlier in the course we talked about
the total cost of ownership that's what
TCO stands for it's about uh uh showing
an enterpr Enterprise that that operates
on premise how much money they would
save if they moved onto Cloud onto Azure
so that's what the TCO calculator does
it estimates the cost savings you can
realize by migrating your workloads to
Azure so what it can do is it can gener
generate out a detailed report and
Export as a PDF to send to your decision
makers now you have to input all the
information in but it's going to help
you convince your boss uh convince the
executive level uh that it's time to
move over to the cloud because they'll
be saving tons and tons of money and so
if you want to use that calculator you
just got to go to
azure.com
pricing calulator and it's going to give
you an idea of how much you'll save and
now this is only a little bit of what it
generates out because it's a it's a very
detailed report but in this example it
would compare on premise uh to the cost
Savings of azure and in this case this
person would be saving
$130,000 over 5 years and it's going to
vary on uh use case but uh yeah that is
the TCO calculator so I just wanted to
quickly show you the TCO calculator in
action if you want to find it yourself
just type in um Azure TCO calculator
into Google and you should be able to
find your way here uh so what I've done
here is I've defined my workload so in
my workload I've defined some servers so
we have some Linux servers we have 10 of
them four processes four cores 8 GB of
RAM and then here I've added uh four
servers that are databases running
postest then I added uh some HDD drives
so I said three terabytes two terabytes
backup Etc and then I defined some
Network bandwidth so Going On To The
Next Step we're going to adjust our
assumptions this helps us to um make it
even more accurate the estimat so we can
choose our our currency some other
additional features we might want to
consider where we might save money like
using Azure hybrid benefit uh and then
down below we can tweak some of our
costs that we do know about for our on
Prem uh so there's a lot here to tweak
it to make it more accurate and then if
we go to next we're going to get our um
our savings here so just wait a moment
and so over a 5year period we should
save $666
and18 um and you can drop it down if you
want to do one year we'll go to one year
so here it says
$381 and we have a lot of Graphics here
as you can see uh and then down below
you should be able to download it so you
can just go ahead and download the
results there and that is the TCO
[Music]
calculator hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we are looking at the Azure
Marketplace so the Azure Marketplace is
a place where there are apps and
services made Available to You by
third-party Publishers to quickly get
started on Azure and so the apps
available uh
the apps and services that can be
available could be free they could be
free trial they could be pay as you go
or they could be bring your own license
so just an example of what that looks
like if you were logged into uh the
Azure portal and you uh searched for
Marketplace what you could do here is
you could type in a variety of things so
like here I'm typing in WordPress and
here I have a bunch of Wordpress that
are provided by thirdparty uh um
Publishers that have been vetted by um
Azure and and again they they could call
cost money they could have a free trial
they could be 100% free but whatever you
need it's generally in the marketplace
um it's a great place to go check out so
just be aware of that so I just wanted
to quickly show you the Azure
Marketplace uh so you'd have to have an
account to actually see it um but we do
show you that in this course but anyway
I'm just going to go up here to the top
and type in
Marketplace and uh this will pull up the
marketplace and here you can see we have
a a huge amount of categories of uh
things that we can launch so whatever we
need and I think I show before WordPress
but we'll type that in there so enter in
WordPress and there's all these servers
so you can click into there um it might
it might have plans associated with it
if there's any price but you just go
ahead and hit create and then that would
start the process of creating a virtual
machine and you go through that and you
subscribe to whatever the underlying
cost would be but you can see there's
just tons of stuff in
here so and you can sort by Price sort
by operating system so there you
go
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at Azure hybrid
benefit so many customers have invested
already in Windows servers licenses and
they want to repurpose their investment
on Azure this happens because
Enterprises had been working with
Microsoft servers even before Azure
existed or they were on premise
originally uh and so they wanted to use
the software so they purchased the
licenses but now they're ready to move
on to Azure um and so since they've
already got a special deal with um
Microsoft because they purchased those
licenses they want to keep those deals
and bring them to the cloud so that's
where the Azure hybrid benefit comes
into play also abbreviated as Hub uh
sometimes it's called asure hybrid use
benefit uh uh in Microsoft documentation
but for some reason Azure they just dro
the word use but the abbreviation is Hub
so this gives customers the uh the right
to use these licenses for virtual
machines on Azure and so uh such types
of virtual machines would be Windows
servers or SQL servers uh and I would
imagine this would probably happen with
a lift and shift which I think we
described uh somewhere in this course so
Hub can be turned on and off at any time
for existing virtual machines and hub
can be applied at deployment time for
new VMS and I just wrote bring your own
license down here just because um we are
talking about licensing and I just want
to get you more exposure to that term
bring your own license B Yol L and so uh
that just means that someone's purchased
a license and they want to apply it um
uh they want to bring it onto Azure uh
so there you go that is azure hybrid
benefit so I just wanted to quickly show
you this page here which is the Azure
hybrid benefit page if you were to type
into Google Azure hybrid benefit you
definitely make your way here what I
wanted to show you is that they actually
have this nice little calculator down
below so if you do have licenses and
you're bringing them over and you want
to run workloads on Azure you can fill
this stuff out and it'll give you an
idea of what you might save um so I just
wanted to make you aware of that so
there you
go
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at Azure subscription
so an Azure subscription I would
describe as uh the equivalent of saying
my Azure account uh I don't know why
they use the term subscription because
to me it's just confusing um but I
always just try to reinforce that it's
just your account and there are four
tiers of azb subscriptions the first is
the free subscription so when you first
sign up this is the the account that you
or subscription you're going to have you
have to provide a credit card to
complete the process you're going to get
200 USD credits free for 30 days and
certain Azure products will be free for
12 months now um the whole point of this
free subscription is to help you avoid
charges and there are some limitations I
remember when I was trying to add
another user um I couldn't grant them
access so there was definitely some uh
some limitations here to uh to prevent
you from being charged but it's not a a
complete sandbox so it is possible to
get charg in this account if you start
using things outside uh the free tier or
if you burn through your credit so just
be careful there and then once you are
ready to switch or or to upgrade and
unlock everything then you can switch to
pay as you go subscription also reved to
p a YG um some people might call that on
demand and so uh for this you still need
a credit card required but since you've
already entered it into the free
subscription stage no problem here uh
and you're going to be charged at the
end of the month based on on consumed
Cloud resources is then you have an
Enterprise agreement so if you are an
Enterprise you can uh make a deal with
Azure and agree to receive a discounted
price for licenses and cloud service but
I bet you're paying a lot of money um
like compared to the uh uh a normal
person but the deal is worth it for you
so just be aware if you're an Enterprise
go talk to Azure they want to make a
deal uh and the last is the student
subscription so with the student
subscription you do not require a credit
card you get $100 USD credits for 12
months but it requires a valid student
email so there is a bit of a vetting
process there so uh you you definitely
have to be in school to get that but it
is a very nice option to have so there
you go that is the Azure subscription
[Music]
Models All right so what I want to do in
this video is show you how to keep track
of your spend uh within your Azure
account so I just created a fresh new
account uh this one's exam Pro Andrew
Brown outlook.com this is not my primary
one so you'll see some videos where I'm
I'm doing labs in this one and other
ones in my primary account um so just be
aware that there might be um some
discrepancies uh between the videos but
anyway um where we're going to keep
track of our spent is within
subscriptions so up here in the top if
we uh type in
subscriptions okay we can see
subscriptions that are attached to this
uh tenant so understand that there is a
relationship between tenants and
subscriptions and your uh your directory
and subscriptions is how you pay Azure
and you can create multiple
subscriptions um and there's good reason
for that um but the point is is that you
start with a default subscription so
here I have the Azure subscription one
notice there is no current cost because
I have yet to launch any services in
here but we'll go ahead and click into
here and eventually something should
appear here yep so it says you uh your
remaining $200 of free credits expire in
30 days so the idea is that we have $200
or uh we have 30 days to utilize uh this
a free free account here so I'm going to
go ahead and just click into this
upgrade I'm not upgrading right now I
just want to show you what it looks like
so in here we have some options you can
rename your subscription if you want I
think for my even my primary account I
just left it as as your subscription one
the name doesn't really matter it's just
for your reference but uh we do have
some options and this is for additional
um support if you want to have technical
support from Azure when you upgrade you
can just stick with basic because of
course we don't need to pay an
additional fee on top of what we're
doing here cuz we have these
instructional videos to learn but that's
how you're going to go ahead and upgrade
later when we do have some spend we'll
come back and revisit it here but we do
have a lot of options to uh track our
spend and usage so there's spend and
usage which are uh two different things
but you know hopefully that makes things
very clear when you want to figure out
what your spend is go over to your
subscription I'll just go back to the um
dashboard here and I'll see you in the
next one
ciao
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we are looking at Azure pricing
calculator so configure and estimate the
cost of azure products you don't have to
sign in to use this tool and and what
you can do is download Excel spreadsheet
and share that uh those costs with your
boss so to get there you go to
azure.com
pricing calculat uh and from there you
can you can go in here and you can fill
out different things so there's a bunch
of different categories the most common
one would probably be a virtual machine
so you go in there and you say what
region it's going to launch in what OS
um and all the types of configuration
it's going to give you an estimated cost
so this one down below is an upfront
cost of 0 with a monthly cost of
$12. $62 so if you're not sure how to
make sense of all the pricing go here
and play around and you will get a clear
picture of what you're going to spend on
Azure so I just wanted to show you the
pricing calculator so if you just went
to Google and typed in Azure pricing
calculator you should be able to make
your way to this page
and so down below we have a bunch of
products we also have example scenarios
which is uh uh very nice to see here um
so let's say we wanted a cicd pipeline
here and we said add to estimate we
could get that information for all these
components I'm just going to go to
single products because it's a bit
easier to uh view so let's say we want
to determine our cost for storage so
let's just go to storage
here and uh we will try storage
accounts and and then down below uh
We've now added storage and so we can
enter some information to try to
determine our cost so we could do blob
file storage table storage I'm going to
go with file
storage um actually no I'm going to go
with blob it's just easier to calculate
and so we're going to have the
performance tier to premium redundancy
lrs um and we're going to be e uh East
usest and so if we had a th000 gigabytes
I guess it's a terabyte that's
$150 uh if we had x amount of right
operations x amount of list and create
container operations read operations and
here we'd have $150 as a monthly cost so
here you just have to tweak it based on
your uh consumptions um and then
generally they'll show you like purchase
options but really this just means like
go sign up for an Azure account uh but I
just wanted to show you what that looks
like and just so that you know that you
can go explore any cost and try to
calculate something before you use
[Music]
it hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at Azure cost
management and so this service allows
you to perform cost analysis so you can
visualize the spending of your Azure
Cloud resources but you can also create
a budget under the service so when you
set a budget you're going to you're
going to Define a threshold and you're
going to be alerted when you're
approaching or you've exceeded that
threshold uh and so just to give you a
visual uh representation there that is
for the cost analysis so you can see you
get beautiful graphs and you can drill
down and filter that stuff out to really
understand how you are spending stuff on
azure so definitely check it out and
there you
[Music]
go let's take a look at the concept of
resource tags are just sometimes known
as a tag and this is a key and value
pair that you can assign to Azure
resources so generally when you are
launching a new resource you're going to
have a uh a tags page and this is where
you can uh apply that key and value name
and just to give you some examples of
tags you might want to apply you might
want to have a department and then the
type of Department status approved uh a
team an environment or the project or
the
location and so you have a lot of uh
tags that you can apply and tags allow
you to organize your resources in the
following ways you can organize them in
your uh via Resource Management so
that's where you are specifying uh
workloads environments like developer
environments uh there's cost management
and optimization so cost tracking
budgets and alerts operation management
so uh that could be uh business
commitments to SLA operations so uh you
might want to tag services that are
considered Mission critical Services uh
there's security so that's
classification of data and security
impact so if there's uh certain
databases that have uh very specific
compliance rules you might want to do
that as well which I think is the next
example here um or maybe you're defining
uh services that are used for automation
or or services are for workload
optimization so there's a lot to do with
tags uh and even even though I don't use
them uh frequently in my follow alongs
it's definitely something uh is a good
habit to do and uh you should do in your
production
[Music]
workloads hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam Pro and we're talking about
Microsoft pview information protection
also known as Microsoft information
protection and this is a collection of
features within Microsoft pview formerly
Microsoft 365 compliance to help you
discover classify and protect sensitive
information wherever lives or travels so
the idea here is that we have this
diagram and we have four specific
domains that are information protection
capabilities around our data and so the
first is know your data the second is
protect your data the third is prevent
data loss and the fourth is govern your
data so we'll be going over all these
sections in the next few slides taking a
look at the four domains here for the
Microsoft purview information protection
these are features found within
Microsoft perview so the first is know
your data understand your data landscape
and identify important data dat across
your hybrid environment so one feature
would be sensitive information types
this identifies sensitive data by using
built-in or custom regular expressions
or a function it provides corroborative
evidence includes keywords confidence
levels and proximity we have built in
sensitive labels and you have custom
ones as well so then there's trainable
classifiers this identifies sensitive
data by using examples of the data
you're interested and rather than
identifying elements in the item so
pattern matching and you can use
built-in classifiers or train a
classifier with your own content so you
have trainable classifiers here for data
classification this is a graphical
identification of items in your
organization that have a sensitive label
a retention label or have been
classified you can also use this
information to gain insights into the
actions that your users are taking on
these items so that's the context
Explorer and the activity Explorer the
second part is protect your data so
apply flexible protection actions that
include encryption access restrictions
and visual markings so you have sens
sensitivity labels Azure information
protection unified labeling client
double key encryption Office 365 message
encryption service encryption with
customer key SharePoint information
Rights Management Rights Management
connector Azure information protection
unified labeling scanner Microsoft
Defender for cloud apps and Microsoft
information protection SDK most of these
you won't need to know but we'll
definitely cover sensitivity labels then
we have prevent data loss so this
prevents accidental oversharing of
sensitive information
here you have Microsoft perview data
loss prevention and point data loss
prevention Microsoft compliance
extension there's a Chrome extension
that does compliance for you so it's
built in your browser there's the
Microsoft purview data loss prevention
on premises scanner and protect
sensitive information in Microsoft teams
chat and channel messages we'll
definitely take a closer look at
Microsoft perview data loss prevention
later next we have Microsoft perview
data life cycle management formerly
Microsoft information governance which
is a collection of features to govern
your data for compliance or regulatory
so for Microsoft perview data life cycle
management it keeps what you need and
deletes what you don't we have retention
policies and retention labels inactive
mailboxes archive mailboxes import
service for pstd files and for Microsoft
perview records management it manages
high value items for business legal or
regulatory recordkeeping requirements
you have file plan retention labels for
individual items retention policies if
needed for Baseline retention and
disposition review and proof of
disposition so those are the four
domains in Microsoft purview information
protection govern your data is not
technically part of it as it's in the
data life cycle and record section but I
included it
anyways so Azure policies are used to
enforce organizational standards to
assess compliance at scale and policies
do not restrict access they only observe
for compliance so here on the right hand
side in the Azure policy uh port portal
uh you're going to see a big list of
policies and Azure has a bunch of
policies built in for you right away
that you can use so if you need to meet
nist or fed ramp or Hippa what you can
do is just turn those on and it's going
to check based on the categories to see
if like you're using Cosmo DB it's going
to check for that compliance and tell
you whether you're being compliant or
not and there's a bunch of components
that are involved when you're making
Azure policies so you have the policy
definition file and this is just a Json
file that describes business rules to
control access to resources you have
policy assignment this is the scope of a
policy that it can affect assigned to a
user a resource Group or Management
Group you have policy parameters these
are values you can pass into your policy
definition so your policies are more
flexible for use and you have initiative
definitions and these are an initiative
definition is a collection of policy
definitions that you can assign so it's
a group of policies to enforce some kind
of compliance like PCI uh DSS compliance
and I want you to carefully look at the
screenshot on the right hand side where
it says defin defition type and you see
policy initiative so the ones at the top
there is talking about policy
definitions and then you have initiative
definitions which are just a group of
policy definitions all
right let's take a look at resource
locks so as in a menu might have a case
where you want to lock a subcription
resource Group or resource to prevent
other users from accidentally deleting
or modifying critical resources So
within the Azure portal you can set the
following lock levels you have the
cannot delete uh which is basically uh
prevents deletion so authorized users
can still read and modify resource but
they can't delete the resource and the
other mode is readon uh so authorized
users can read a resource but they can't
delete or update the resource uh so
those are the two modes uh and that's
something uh you might be interested in
doing let's take a look at Azure
Blueprints and this is a way to enable
quick creation of govern subscriptions
the keyword there is governed so the
idea is like you can go in your account
and just create a subscription but when
it's a govern subscription that means
there's a process uh and certain
expectations on how subscription should
be set up um so the idea is you're going
to compose artifacts based on common or
organization-based patterns into
reusable Blueprints and the service is
designed to help with environment setup
so blueprints are are a declarative way
to orchestrate the deployment of various
resource templates and artifa artifacts
I want to emphasize that word
declarative declarative means that
everything is spelled out so we exactly
know what's going to be created and so
artifacts could be Ro assignments policy
assignments Azure resource manager
templates also known as arm templates
resource groups and the Azure blueprint
service is backed by the globally
distributed Azure cosmod DB blueprint
objects are replicated to multiple
regions so uh they're definitely well
backed up uh and so the main main
question people are going to ask well
what's the difference between an arm
template and an Azure blueprint because
an arm template can automate the setup
of stuff well basically nearly
everything you want to include uh for
deployment in an Azure blueprint can
technically be accomplished in an arm
template but the thing is is that an arm
template uh you you are you are storing
that either locally or in Source control
and there is no active connection or
relationship to the arm template whereas
a your blueprints the relationship
between the blueprint definition what
should be deployed and the blueprint
assignment uh what was deployed and it
can also be uh upgraded SE uh it can
also upgrade sever subscriptions at once
that are governed by the same blueprint
so uh blueprint support improve tracking
and auditing of deployments that is the
thing so they're very similar to arm
templates but generally if you have the
option you should always use as your
blueprints so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at the the Azure
portal so the Azure portal is a
web-based unified console that provides
an alternative to command line tools you
can manage your Azure subscription with
the Azure portal build manage monitor
everything from simple web apps to
complex Cloud deployments so what does
that mean it just means the browser that
you use to access Azure so anytime
you're logged into Azure uh that is the
portal that's all you need to know uh
there's another thing about Azure portal
and that's Azure preview portal so uh
the thing is is that sometimes there are
new features or new products that Azure
has made that are not necessarily
generally available but you can get a
sneak peek of them uh sooner if you use
the Azure preview portal so that could
be previews uh betas or other
pre-releases so the way you would do
that is very similar how to you how
you'd access uh the regular portal but
if you want a test preview of new
features you go to the preview. portal.
azure.com or if you're looking for
stable release and production ready
features you just use portal. azure.com
so that's all you need to know about the
Azure
portal so I just wanted to quickly show
you what the portal looks like um we are
going to show you in this course how to
create your own account and work within
the portal but I already have one set up
here and uh I'm already logged in and if
I go to the top here I actually have
this portal link now and when I go here
we can see what the portal looks like so
this is the portal uh you can see that
it's telling me about my spend but I'm
on the dashboard right now on the left
hand side we have this hamburger menu
where we can explore the services we can
go up here and search them as well so
whatever I'm looking for if it's monitor
we can go there uh and that's pretty
much it this is the portal so it's just
the browser when you're logged in and
you can interact with any Cloud
[Music]
resources so in this video I want to go
take a look at the preview portal so
that you are aware where that is uh I
know it exists I never ever ever ever
ever go to it unless there is some kind
of kind of service that I think is going
to get released and I want to teach
teach you it um and so I believe that we
just add something in front of it so I
was just looking up on the um uh like
the azures or the Microsoft Tech
Community and they're suggesting that
it's this address here I'm not really
reading it I was just looking for the
address and so if we log into here we're
now in the preview portal and so we have
access to all the preview things um that
Azure has so one thing that is in
preview right now I believe is ma uh
fabric uh Microsoft Fabric and this was
just announced I believe or was talked
about a lot at the recent Microsoft
ignite and so this is a preview feature
if we want to use it we have to be in
the preview account if we're in um Azure
here I'm not sure if it'll let us use it
so we'll go over here and just see what
happens um I have no idea what the costs
are here so you can take a look and just
not touch it but here it says uh
Microsoft fabric delivers an nend
experience create a fabric capacity and
then we'll go over here and it's also
here as well so what I'm going to do is
go ahead and see what happens if I try
to create
this so it says you cannot create a
Microsoft capacity using a personal
account you use an organization account
instead so um right now I'm still in a
free tier account and it has to be
within organization so they're not going
to let me use this which is totally fine
um but I just wanted to see what would
happen if I clicked
it and I don't know if that applies for
any other preview features as well uh I
wonder if we typed in preview if we
could see what's in preview maybe uh
there is a preview features service I've
actually never tried to look this up so
I don't know I'm just curious myself so
exploring pre-release features so yeah
it looks like we can see all the the
preview stuff here um and there's
nothing really popping out at me that we
could go take a look and take for a spin
um but it is nice to know that if you
want to see where all the preview
features are we can go ahead and look at
that um so yeah that is all good here um
and that's all I really wanted to point
out now if I could find a preview
service to launch we definitely test it
uh one thing I'm not 100% sure is how we
would go ahead and use preview features
in the CLI so just give me a second to
find out all right so uh I I wasn't
looking for this in particular but it's
worth taking a look here so here it's
suggesting that if we want to um uh
access uh preview features in our
account we can go under subscriptions
and documentation let's go check and
find out if that is the case so we'll go
over to subscriptions we'll click into
our subscription here and on the left
hand side I'm scrolling down I'm looking
for document is that what they said I
think that's what they said right no
preview features and here it is and
we'll go into
here and we'll give it a moment it might
be the same listing that we actually
looked up just a moment
ago okay and it looks like we can just
register them so this is very similar to
the the um resource providers it looks
like if we want to use them we just
register register them um but uh yeah I
guess that's all there really is to it I
was always told that the preview portal
was so that you can only use preview
features so if we can register them in
the main
one what's the point anyway in
practicality this is not something you
really have to worry about but you
should know that there are there are
things that are preview uh that you have
to do some extra work to be able to
access them and just make sure you're
not using them in your production
workloads because uh Azure might roll
back on them and uh you know I've heard
this from customers before where it's
like they've worked with Microsoft and
they worked for like six months and
implemented stuff and it really seemed
like it was going going to go through
investing a lot of money uh and it
really seemed like Azure was going to uh
stick with it and then last minute they
said oh we're not doing this anymore so
really just be very wary of preview
features you can get excited about them
but do not put them in your production
workloads but there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at Azure Cloud
shell so Azure Cloud shell is an
interactive authenticated browser
accessible shell for managing Azure
resources and so it provides the
flexibility of choosing the shell
experience that best suits the way you
work so you can either use bash or
Powershell we just talked about
Powershell and this is the place where
you could use it in Azure so uh just to
give you a visual uh if you ever want to
access the cloud shell it's all the way
up in the header there in the portal and
so you click that button it opens up
Powershell or it will depends on what
you choose but it will open it up down
below uh and then you'll be able to use
um Powershell right away and also the
CLI right away which we'll talk about
[Music]
next all right so what I want to do in
this video is to introduce you to Cloud
shell so um Microsoft Azure has a portal
which is what we're looking at uh and
and and it basically has uh different
Services where we're going to have user
interfaces so if we want to say launch a
virtual machine they have uh this really
nice I don't know why it's asking me to
log in again but that's okay but it has
this really nice uh UI so that if I want
to launch a virtual machine I can just
do some click Ops click Ops is when we
perform operations through clicking of
the Mouse um but in practice a lot of
the times especially if you're working
in devops uh or other roles is you're
going to be Pro programmatically
creating resources because it's more
efficient or there are cases in Azure
where there is no UI and you have to do
it programmatically uh this happens
especially with newer services or Cloud
native Services um so just be aware that
you cannot avoid doing some basic
scripting programming or uh terminal
usage so the nice thing about Azure and
most providers have this uh uh now but
they have a a way of launching a a a
cloud shell a terminal so that you can
programmatically enter in commands and
so that's what I want to show you in
this video so in the top right corner
you're going to see um a bunch of little
icons here and the first one uh and
hover over to make sure that it is what
we think it is but it's called Cloud
shell and if we go ahead and click that
what we're going to get is this um dark
box that's appearing below and it's
going to say welcome to Azure Cloud
shell uh select either bash or pow shell
so um there are two uh very popular um
scripting languages one is called bash
it's also the terminal itself it's not
just uh the scripting language but bash
is what is used on Linux Powershell is
what is used on Windows machines and so
this is a a way to Pro programmatically
um interact with uh machines and
programs and so uh we should take a look
at both of them but I'm going to first
take a look at bash of course we are in
the U Windows uh Microsoft ecosystem so
Powershell is going to be what is uh
probably preferred when we're using
Azure but anyway the first thing it's
going to tell you if this is the first
time you ever launched it it's going to
say you do not have uh uh a storage
account so the idea is that um this bash
terminal needs to store some data and so
it's going to spin up a storage account
and we'll talk about that later in the
course uh in order to store some of the
information here and so this should be
uh pretty low cost to no cost so just go
ahead and create that
resource and uh we'll just give it a
moment
here
and I just want you to know that uh it's
still taking time for uh for me to
create so uh if it's taking uh quite a
few minutes do not stress out uh just
keep waiting and we'll see what happens
okay I'm just going to pause and and uh
speed this up but actually there it is
it's done so it took about I don't know
3 minutes for this to uh create that
storage account so while this is
spinning up a lot of times in Azure they
will uh show up in the notifications
recent actions and it's not showing up
here might be this tab
nope but normally when resources are
ready or being created they will uh they
will show up in the notifications not
exactly sure why I'm not seeing it here
but I'm going to go ahead and right
click and just take a look at
notifications and it really keeps asking
me to log in not sure why today um but
uh yeah if we go here uh we can see uh
things that are happening so it started
it created subcription that was the
start of our account so this I just
recently created this account and then
it performed a generate
not exactly sure what that was for um
that's for subscription so totally um
not important but I thought we would see
and hear things like created a storage
account but we don't and that's totally
fine so we'll come back over here and
going to carefully read here so it says
storage file share subscription is not
registered to Microsoft cloud shell
namespace please follow these
instructions to register in future unex
unregistered subscriptions will have
restricted access to Cloud Shell service
so what I'll do is I'll go ahead and
copy this
link okay and we'll just enter this in
here and it's giving us instructions
about getting started with Cloud shell
so what it's probably asking us to do is
enable um uh enable Cloud shell so this
is again another thing that we have to
understand about Azure is that we need
to uh register particular services so
this is normally done under your
subscription so what we're going to do
is we're going to go over back to our
subscription so let's just type
subscription
here and we'll click into our
subscription and I want to show you on
the left hand side there's a tab called
resource providers this is something
you're going to be going to a lot and
you'll see me go here a lot but the idea
is that Azure is made up of a bunch of
different services and you have to
register or permit uh the access of
these services so uh in this tutorial
it's saying make sure that Microsoft
cloud shell is registered and if I go
over here here it is registered so I'm
thinking what it did is it did it for us
so it said hey it wasn't registered but
we did it for you okay and so now we're
able to use it but uh you will again see
me in many videos at the start of it
making sure that we have those resources
so um anyway we have this
open and uh this is running Linux as far
as I'm aware of and so we can run some
Linux commands for fun so the first I'm
going to type is PWD which is print
working directory and then LS to list
out the directory and you can see that
uh we are getting some input what I want
to do is just make this a bit larger
it's a bit hard on the eyes and let's
see if this Cog here uh will allow us to
change the font so yes we can so that's
the largest I can make it I apologize if
it is uh not better but anyway uh the
great thing about these Cloud shells is
that they're normally loaded up with um
clis uh for um the particular provider
so uh Azure has a CLI called Azure CLI
and in order to to use it you can type
the command AZ so if we type in AZ and
hit enter it should uh tell us a bunch
of stuff on how to use
this and I'm just going to go ahead and
hit this maximize button so we have our
full screen here and so the idea here is
that uh in order to use the Azure CLI we
can go ahead and start typing things in
so maybe we want to find something about
our Azure subscription so I can go down
here below and type in AZ subscription
or sorry
account and we'll go ahead and hit enter
and right away it's going to complain
because most commands are going to have
a command and then a sub command so uh
here I'm going to go ahead and type in a
account list as it's suggesting uh
things that we can
do and so what it's doing here is it's
returning back to us um uh some
information on our account so in this
video all I wanted to do was show you
how to open up cloudshell um in uh
another video we'll talk a little bit
more about the uh Azure CLI and and
Powershell and and this other stuff but
yeah that's about it here when we're
done with Cloud shell we can go ahead
and hit the X and close that off and we
can just forget about it so it's as easy
as that and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
one hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at Powershell for
Azure so first of off what is Powershell
so Powershell is a task Automation and
configuration management tool um but an
easier way to think of it is just it's a
command line shell and it's also a
scripting language and so when I say a
command line shell I mean this thing
this blue thing and so if you have a
Windows machine you can actually you'd
have to I think have Windows
Professional uh but you can go ahead and
install this and it's uh allows you to
automate things using its scripting
language as well as in this uh this uh
program now uh powershell's available on
Azure as well and we'll get to that in a
moment let's just talk about the
benefits of Powershell over traditional
um uh traditional shells so a shell
could be something like bash or zsh uh
which would accept and return tax but
Powers shell is built on top of the net
common language runtime so CLR uh and it
accepts and returns net objects so those
objects make it a lot easier to automate
scripting and so Powershell is available
on Azure and it's known as Azure
Powershell and so we have a set of
command uh commandlets for managing
Azure resources directly from the
Powershell command line and if you're
wondering how You' access Powershell you
could use um Cloud shell which we'll
talk about here uh in a
moment okay so I just wanted to quickly
show you a Powershell I'm on my Windows
computer right now and this is natively
installed on my uh my Windows 10
computer and I can type in commands here
and so this is just giving me a list of
all my um my my the directories in in
this current uh folder but I just also
want to show you that we have Powershell
here in the Azure portal so I'm using
the cloud shell up here and I've chosen
to use Powershell and you can see it's
pretty much the same experience um with
some extra things that make it easier to
work on cloud so that's
[Music]
it all right so in this video what I
want to do is show you Powershell so
Powershell is kind of like bash except
it's for Windows um and uh it's it looks
different so uh that's the easiest way
to describe it but let's go ahead and
get some experience with it so in the
top right corner we're going to go ahead
and open Cloud shell I'm expand expand
this open so it's nice and big going to
make sure my font is nice and big and uh
notice right away that it launched and
Bash uh it's whatever you had open up
last you can restart Cloud Shell by
clicking this button I'm just going to
drop down and click on par shell and
just confirm and it will go ahead and
open it
up so uh notice that Powershell is nice
and blue most Windows computers should
have Powershell installed I can't
remember remember you have to have
Windows Professional or not so I could
technically open up Powershell on my
computer here not going to do that but
notice that this is spun up and so now
we can go ahead and use Powershell and
Powershell has its own syntax and its
own way of working um it's a really
powerful tool and very efficient when
you are working as a systems
administrator um but what we'll do is go
ahead and ask chat jpt um the same thing
we did before but we'll say let's use
Powershell Azure
Powershell and one thing I want to say
about Azure uh or Powershell is that
Powershell the Azure package or Plugin
takes forever to
install so I really uh am not looking
forward to the time I I'll have to show
you in a future course um installing
that because it just takes forever um I
don't know why it's always uh it's like
that but it's always taken a very very
long time I just want to point that out
so here it's very similar it's saying
okay the first time you use power shell
you're gonna use connect hyphen a
account um the thing is is that uh we
don't need to do this because we're
already logged in because Cloud shell
will do that for us automatically if
we're installing this locally the
process would be a little bit different
and so the thing is is that Parell is
going to follow uh this very interesting
convention in terms of how they uh name
their stuff so here it's new new hyphen
a a resource Group uh and so there is a
way of learning um uh that syntax so I I
I'm not I don't use Powershell lot I'm
very I'm comfortable using it but um uh
I just don't use Powershell because I
prefer bash but let's go see if there is
a Powershell asure uh uh reference
documentation because that's what we
would uh expect to look for so we'll go
over here and I would imagine it's very
similar um so yeah commandlet
reference maybe it's under
here and I said plugin but yeah they're
called commandlets uh that's uh and
commandlets contain modules so in here
we're looking for the module for let's
say the resource Group so we'll go here
and look for Resource
Group if it's not called that let's go
take a look oh AZ Resource
Group maybe it's a
resources and we'll go ahead and type in
Resource
Group there it is so the modules aren't
always named exactly the same but uh
anyway if you remember our bash video
very similar we're going to go look up
that
documentation and uh you know it looks
kind of similar um so we can go down
here and I'm not noticing shorter Flags
but um I'm pretty sure that Powershell
autocompletes so we'll find out here but
I'm going to type in new yes it does and
so that's one of the nice things about
Powershell at least working on Azure is
that they really want to make everything
really easy for you so as soon as I
started typing new it already started
autocomp completing and so I can go
ahead and hit tab
here and uh I don't know why I didn't
take the whole thing but maybe
oops and it's not taking the whole thing
but we'll keep typing
here group and so I can do hyphen name
and so uh we'll call this um probably
singles I'll stick with singles I can't
remember if it takes doubles but we'll
say my uh
Powershell RG and then we'll do
location and here it's saying Central
us so even notice like remember like we
typed in Us East lowercase and the
syntax was different so understand that
things going to be different it's still
suggesting more stuff um that is good
enough so I'll go ahead and hit
enter and so um we get that back there
we'll go ahead and go to the next
command so it's going to be new a
storage account so we'll go back here we
could also search it here we'll go ahead
and just just look it
up and we'll click on that one there and
so we have a bunch of commands um but
you know we just did this so we're
already familiar with the the um the
inputs that we're going to go into this
so we'll type in new and we're going to
say
a uh storage
account and so we need our Resource
Group
name and this one is going to be my par
shell uh whoops my tab nope it's not
letting me tab that sometimes it lets
you Tab and other times it doesn't my
Powershell
RG and we're going to name
this again these names have to be very
unique it's showing that the name is
title case so maybe we can name it
whatever we want I thought it had to be
lower case because azure's really picky
again about
naming it's very hard to remember
because it's so different so I'm going
to just double check here we'll go over
to storage
accounts and take a
look if I click onto
this and I click on here uh the name
must be unique across all Sorge account
names it must be uh 3 to 24 characters
long and can contain only lower case
letters and numbers and I go over here
and look it's showing me title case so I
feel like it's lying to me so I'm I'm
going to ignore it I don't believe it uh
unless it's going to normalize it for me
which I don't know um but you know what
let's just let's try to put it with
title cases because it's not supposed to
work but we'll see what happens so I'm
going to just say my
whoops my uh Resource Group or sorry
storage account storage account I'm
going to put a bunch of random numbers
here and then my
initials okay we'll choose the same
location as our Resource Group so we'll
just say
Central us
and
um we should
specify the kind of storage it might
default to something so we might not
even have to um set one
here and what what did we have to do for
that it was kind so we'll go here and
look up
kind yeah here it says blob storage so
um it's not saying the flag here
directly well we'll just do storage
version two it's
fine so we'll go here and just say um
kind
storage version two it's interesting
that this doesn't require notice here
it's not indicating single quotations I
would assume that it would want it
everywhere but we'll go ahead and hit
enter and see what happens and so it
says commandlet new a storage account at
pipeline position one failed um and so
it's saying that the SQ SQ name was not
supplied I'm going to do control C on my
keyboard uh to just ignore that but it's
trying to prompt me to say hey you got
to fill that one in so I thought we
could get away without it so I'll go
back and hit up on my keyboard and I'm
going to type in hyphen I'm going to say
SKU
name and we'll go with standard lrs
because that sounds like the default to
be honest and we'll go ahead and hit
enter and right away we're getting a
problem and it's saying my storage
account Etc is not a valid storage
account name that's because it lied to
us it was Auto autocompleting with title
case and I knew I knew for sure that
wasn't right so I'm going to hit up on
my keyboard and scroll on back and I'm
going just take out those uh those
capitals here
okay oh and it's there's still a mistake
we got to get rid of that capital S
there and it still doesn't like it it
might be suggesting the name is too long
um storage count must be three letters
and length lowercase only I'll just take
some letters out here like
that what does it not like oh you know
what AB is and caps that's why so go
ahead and do
that I notice it's talking about up
upcoming breaking changes so it's even
suggesting things that might
change and so uh you know uh B who's the
other Andrew that is at exam Pro my
co-founder he loves Powershell and he
always tells me like how awesome it is
that it gives consistent output it's
very good at chaining programs together
his background was managing Windows
machines for years I more on the the
Linux side so um you know I'm going to
be more biased for that but uh a
Powershell is a very very powerful Tool
uh we're definitely not even coming
close to tapping uh all the power of it
right here but notice that it created
that storage account we're going to go
back over to uh our our portal and we're
going to go into storage accounts if you
don't see it there you can just search
it and well actually I don't want to go
here I actually want to go to Resource
groups and what we'll do is we'll go
ahead and just clean this up because
we're totally done with it make sure
it's my power shell RG not this one
that's your Cloud shell that we're we're
using right now we're going to go ahead
and delete that Resource Group and I'm
going to go ahead and copy it and paste
it down below we'll go ahead and delete
it we can go back over here close that
out and uh yeah just make sure that that
does delete but um there you go so now
you got some exposure to bash and
Powershell so you're on your way of
getting some good programming skills
there okay
[Music]
ciao hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we are looking at Azure CLI so
what is a CLI well CLI stands for
command line interface and it processes
commands to a computer program in the
form of lines of text and the operating
system implements a command line
interface in a shell or
terminal so we saw a shell earlier which
was power shell
um but uh we'll look at what uh CLI
commands look like here in a moment so
the Azure CLI can be installed on
Windows Mac and Linux once it's
installed you would type A Z followed by
other commands to create update delete
View and manage your Azure resources and
so to really show you what that code
looks like down below we have a bash
script but this could easily be
Powershell and you have the commands AZ
and then you would have what it is that
you want to do so if you want to create
a group you type a group create and you
provide the name and the location or
let's say you wanted to launch a virtual
machine which is a server you do asvm
create uh and then provide those other
parameters so that is how you would
pragmatically create um Azure resources
and there's tons and tons of CLI
commands uh for Azure so you basically
anything you're looking at pretty much
can be created with the CLI Pro
[Music]
programmatically all right so in this
video what I want to to do is get you
more familiar with Azure CLI um it's
very very very very very important that
you get some scripting programming any
kind of exposure to that because most
technical roles in Cloud require you to
touch some kind of cod like thing um and
again Azure uh doesn't always let you do
click offs with all their services and
sometimes you'll be copy and pasting
command so it's important we get
comfortable with that as soon as
possible so what I'm going to do is go
in the top right corner and open up
cloudshell we learned how to do this uh
previously so watch the cloud shell
video if this is the first time you're
launching it I'm going to go ahead and
increase my font size to large we're
going to wait for this terminal to start
um I just recently had cloud cloud shell
open so it opened up very quickly for
you it might take longer and I want to
remind people that the Azure CLI is
pre-installed on here so if we type in
AZ um we should get back some um output
just understand that sometimes there are
uh Network latencies so you have to be
patient but we're getting stuff back so
uh what would be really interesting is
to go ahead and launch something
anything here uh via the CLI and so
before we do that I just want to show
you how would you find out CLI commands
of course we can uh type in a and see
them here another way that we can look
at Azure commands is by looking it up so
we can say Azure CLI reference
documentation because that's often what
CLI um interfaces will have is they'll
have a reference
documentation and carefully looking here
this is at the learn website which is
fine uh we'll try the first one here and
what I'm looking for here is the
reference so here it says Azure CLI
reference and I'll click reference A to
Z I personally don't like the way that
Azure lays out their docs for the CLI I
definitely prefer uh the way Google or
um AWS does it but we got what we got
and so uh here we have a bunch of
different commands and uh they are going
to correspond to different things so
let's say we want to launch a storage
account which is something that is very
common for us to do I'm going to type in
storage which is one option um and we're
going to go here and just expand it and
we'll look at summary and so we have
some options here um one thing I want to
point out with the documentation is the
status so the status indicates whether
these CLI commands are are going to are
are going to be supported or whether
they uh might be uh gone in the future
so ga stands for uh General availability
meaning that Azure has decided that they
like this uh feature and they're going
to keep it uh preview means that um
they're very likely to um they might uh
bring this feature to all customers and
Azure likes to have a preview and a
gener general available um I think it's
a subcription or something somewhere
there's a way to access it or the portal
is different I always forget but my
point is is that um if you want to
utilize uh preview features in Azure uh
you have to go some somewhere else to do
that um and so if you try to use a
preview feature and it doesn't work it's
probably because you're not in the
whatever preview setting I'll do another
video on that so that's very clear but
my point is is that always stick to the
ga do not touch preview do not touch
experimental because if they do uh get
rid of those things and you rely on them
you're going to run into trouble but
anyway I'm interested in a storage so
I'm going to go ahead and click in Click
into here and notice that when I clicked
into storage we have a big drop down of
a bunch of stuff
and again notice um where it says where
it says type core so it's a core command
or some some are extensions stick to
core stick to GA and they just have a
lot and a lot of CLI commands other
providers like adab us and gcp do not
have this many commands um for whatever
reason Azure likes to take uh uh uh take
their services and put them under
umbrellas uh and they also uh like to
just keep adding stuff uh and so you
might have um CLI commands that do
exactly the same thing and so there are
a lot here and it can be really hard to
figure out what to do so I'm going to go
over to chat jpt and we're going to get
its help to kind of narrow down what it
is that we want to do so I'm going to
say I want to create a um blob storage
account via the Azure
CLI and we'll go ahead and narrow down
the commands it's going to provide us
now chachy BT can go out to the internet
and it can bring us back stuff but we
have to double triple check it because
it's not intelligent uh despite it be
calling AI but it can give us an idea of
where to get started so the first thing
it's telling us to do is to do a login
and that's great but um we don't have to
do a login because when we use cloud
shell we're already logged in if we were
to install the CLI on our local computer
we would have to uh utilize ay login in
order to First gain access so we can
skip that step the next thing it's just
uh saying is to create an Azure Resource
Group which that makes sense uh we
always need to create a resource Group
so let's go ahead and see what we can do
and I want you to follow along and do
this in your own account okay so the
first thing we want to create is an
Azure Resource Group um and so we'll
just quickly talk about that here I'm
going to open a new
tab and every time I do that it wants me
to log in totally fine and if we type in
the top here uh a resource Group is a
way of grouping together resources and
um uh it's different like if you come
from ads everything is with an account
if you're in uh a gcp everything's
within a project and in Azure everything
is within a resource Group um and so
before you create any resources you need
to put them in a resource Group and
often you need to create a resource
Group so that's what we're going to do
we're going to go back here and this
command is a group create so let's go
take a look for that command over here
and find it so I'm going to type in
resource not very useful so what I'll do
is just search for it man manually and
we have resource manager that's probably
what it
is and here we have a group I think
that's the command it's asking us to do
we'll go ahead here and we have create
so we'll go ahead and look at this and
we can see it requires some parameters
it wants the location so that is
something it might want it says that's a
required parameter uh there is the name
that's a required parameter then we have
some op optional parameters and we can
do some tags so
uh here it's saying Resource Group and
location and so the the the location is
going to be a Azure region and then the
resource Group is going to be the name
so let's go ahead and start typing that
in here so I'm going to say
AZ
group um create and then we'll
do sorry for the little popup there it
gets into the way I'm going to expand
this to make our lives a bit easier I'm
going to put in here um we had a short
flag so we have the long flag or the
short flag FL I'm going to use the
shorter one CU it's a bit easier to look
at we'll do L and we probably can do us
East
one uh or east us that's what it is I'm
thinking about AWS right now that's my
problem and um the other thing is the
name so that's a hyphen n apparently it
can be hyphen G as well which is fine so
we do that and I'm just going to say um
Azure
CLI and this will be blob because we're
going to create a a blob storage
account and so what what that's going to
do is it's going to go ahead and create
it and so notice we got Jason back
that's usually a good indicator that it
is working correctly notice that the
provisioning state is succeeded
sometimes this will come back and say
it's creating um but resource groups
create basically instantly let's go over
to our Resource Group uh Tab and we'll
give it a refresh I want to point out
that um sometimes Azure is very very
slow in showing you what you've done um
azure's uh portal is one of the most
robust portals uh compared to every
other provider and that is great but the
disadvantage to it is it's very hard for
Azure to propagate that information uh
to us and so sometimes you will do
something and you won't see it and
you'll think that you did it wrong or
you didn't create it but all you got to
do is wait around so just have a lot of
patience when you create something you
don't see it and double triple check
with Azure so here we can see we've
created our azure CLI blob so that is
there I'm going to go back over to our
instructions and we're going to look at
the next one so here it's saying AZ
storage account create and it wants the
name and the resource Group and the
location the SKU and the kind so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to go over
here and we're going to look for
storage okay and again I just really
want to point out that if you're going
to use any generative AI don't blindly
follow it double check the docs always
double check it so here um I think we're
doing a storage account create yes we
are and in here I'm going to search for
create here it is good I notice it has a
lot of flags so there is a lot here um
I'm not sure exactly what uh we'll need
for this but I'm pretty sure we can do
these basic ones and it'll be fine so
I'm going to go back over here and type
in a storage account create and then
let's take a look at the flags it wants
so it wants the resource
Group so let's go over here and take a
look at the flag so Resource Group can
be a hyphen G I think I like that so
we'll do hyphen G and it wants it to be
the name of the resource Group we name
this Azure CLI blob so we go ahead and
paste that on in here good we'll go next
back over to here it wants a name we
know that we can put hyphen n for name
here and notice that um the resource
Group allowed us use the hyphen G or
hyphen n flag to name the name but in
this one hyphen g means the resource
Group and hyphen N means the storage
account name so uh there might not be
consistency in terms of the flags uh uh
between like short Flags between
different commands so again just always
double triple check and don't just
assume we'll go here to the right we
have our location so we'll go here and
do uh well we got to give a name for the
storage account now storage accounts I
believe have to have um all the
everything lowercase no spaces uh Azure
is notorious for having crazy naming for
every service they're all different and
I think it's treated like a URL like a
domain name so you have to make it uh
unique so I'm going to say here
my uh storage
account and I'm going to just put uh a
number in here so I'm going to put 1 two
3 4 and I'll say AB for my initials you
make it very unique so that you don't
run into any troubles we're still not
hitting enter we'll go back over here um
did we do the location so do hyphen L
East
us and we'll go back over here
again and then there's the SKU the kind
so I know the storage is going to be
version two that sounds good to me so um
I'm going to double check and look for
the short flag as I prefer
those so we'll go hyphen hyen kind
here and so we have a few options blob
storage um blob block storage file
storage Storage storage version two so
um I believe that we can do blob storage
under storage version two so we can do
either or um so I'm going to just stick
with storage version two because it's
totally
fine and
uh it's this one doesn't have a short
flag so we'll have to do it in full also
note that if we're using the CLI we're
programmatically doing stuff um it's not
going to warn us about free tier stuff
uh when you use click offs you get a lot
more information through the portal when
you're using the CLI it's just
programming so it's not going to give us
the same amount of
stuff so we'll go back over here and we
need the SKU so let's go take a look at
what it wants for the SKU the storage
account SKU so this is going to
determine
um uh the the replication of resources
and so I I just want to go with the
standard one now notice it says a
default value so sometimes if there's a
default value if we if we don't include
it it will default to it so I'm hoping
that's what's going to happen I'm going
to purposely leave out the
SKU I'm going to go ahead and hit enter
and see what
happens okay and so it's creating it or
running it
and we'll just give a moment and see
what happens
okay all right so um we got a bunch of
uh output back and it looks like it was
successful um so what we'll do is we'll
double check we'll go to the top here to
micros Azure we'll type in storage
accounts and we can see that we have our
storage account so we've done something
Pro programmatically there is for stuff
that we can do here we can go ahead and
create our blob we can uh list the
containers I don't want to do all those
things right now I just wanted to get
you a little bit experience working with
the CLI um and uh being comfortable with
that another thing I can uh say is that
the CLI will allow you to Output to
different formats um it might be hyphen
o or something I'm not sure if it will
show it here because that's kind of a
global
flag so yeah it's hyphen o and so let's
say we wanted data in a different format
we could choose something instead of
Json we could get table yaml or
something else um so I'm going to go
here and just say uh here it says Azure
storage list I want I just want to list
um all the accounts I'm going to see if
uh that works here I'm going just say a
I'm just guessing but I think it's a
storage account list and will that list
out storage accounts for us notice it
came back as Json so if we wanted to
change the output we can give it a
hyphen o flag and uh the the output
format probably will vary per um command
so don't expect the output format to be
for all them this is defaulted Json uh
let's take a look at yaml and type that
in
here there we go so that looks uh a lot
more readable and I I really do like
yaml uh we could also try table format
so let's do that that's a very common
one when you're in the
terminal okay there you go so kind of
looks like a table it's a lot of
information so maybe not as nice as we'd
like it to be but that's the basics of
uh working with Azure CLI it definitely
gets a lot more complex than that but
again I just wanted to give you
confidence with it so now that we are
done with that resource I just want to
go ahead and delete it uh so I'm just
going to go ahead and close out
cloudshell and we're going to make our
way over to Resource groups so I'll type
in resource groups at the top
here and on the left hand side I'm going
to Azure CLI blob here is that resource
that we created I'm going to go ahead
and hit delete res Resource Group and um
I'm going to go and enter the name I
like how they say enter the name but you
can go ahead and copy paste it the idea
to type it in is to make sure that you
are you know what you are deleting but
uh they've even uh expediated that so
that is deleting and that's all I really
wanted to show you um with the um Azure
CLI okay so we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
ciao hey this is Andrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're looking at Visual Studio
code so visual studio code is a free
source code editor meaning it edits code
made by Microsoft uh for Windows Linux
and Mac OS and you can even run it in
the cloud and if you're wondering what
it looks like this is the editor and
this is not to be confused with visual
studio so visual studio is an IDE uh and
it is also for programming but it has a
lot of functionality built in here um is
Visual Studio code op Source well they
say that it is but I don't know to what
degree I don't know if it's 100% open
Source but this is the most popular um
um text editor or code editor um out
right now and Microsoft has or sorry
Azure has a service called it's like
Visual Studio workspaces that's on Azure
and it allows you to spin up these
developer environments using this editor
right in the cloud I don't think it's
going to be on your exam but I just
thought it was cool to mention uh and if
you don't have a a code editor I
strongly recommend downloading this one
for your computer because it is great so
I just wanted to quick show off visual
studio code here um so if you wanted to
go download yourself you just type in
Visual Studio code into Google and you
should end up here and you can download
a version it's for Windows uh Mac and
Linux so you can download for anything
and you can run it in the cloud uh on
Azure or even launch your own server on
other other on other uh Cloud providers
I just have happen to have Visual Studio
code open here with an open source
project um just to show you what it
looks like the the thing that people
really like about it is just it looks
great and it has really good plugins so
if just go to extensions here you can
anything you need uh you can add it and
enhance uh this editor here if you don't
have a code editor I strongly recommend
downloading this and I just wanted to
make make you uh um familiar with this
editor
[Music]
here all right so in this video I want
to introduce you to um Visual Studio
code and maybe we can go ahead and use a
bit of azure SDK um in order to Pro
programmatically uh set up a resource so
this is very similar to how we use the
bash CLI or P Powershell CLI we're going
to use a programming language to do it
and um again I really believe that you
should learn this as soon as possible
because uh very quickly you end up
having to touch code or scripting or
something so get comfortable with it
right away here um so what you're going
to need to do is install in Visual
Studio code I'm not going to show you
how to install that it's not that hard
to learn uh but you're going to go look
for visual studio code you're going to
install it this is a free and open open
source um um uh coder or code editor and
once it's installed we can get go ahead
and start utilizing it so you go ahead
and install it I already got installed
in fact I got a project open here not
the project we're going to use but this
is actually how I um Stitch uh the big
video when I send it over to free Cod
Camp so I have a bunch of scripts here
but uh what I want to do is once you
have it installed we're going to go
ahead and create a new um a new folder
so on my desktop I'm going to go do that
so let me just make some room on my
desktop to here okay all right so I got
some nice room on my desktop I'm going
to make a new folder here and I'm just
going to call it um Azure uh because we
keep doing things with the storage
bucket so we'll just say Azure SDK
example uh you can name it title case
lowercase however you want to name it
but uh just make sure there's no spaces
in it I know that's a bit hard to read
on my background here but we now have a
folder and that's just going to give us
a place to start working with so I'm
going to go ahead and say file open
folder and this is point to my sites
directory so I'm going to go back and
I'm going to say
desktop I think that's we have a desktop
there
right and um I'm going to say show local
so it'll just open it up here make our
lives a little bit easier I'll click on
desktop here I'm going to choose Azure
SDK example select that folder and so
it's going to open that folder up and
it's opening up my whole desktop which
is really not what I wanted to do um
that is totally wrong so give me two
seconds okay all right so what I'm
thinking is what we'll have to do is try
this again so we'll say open
folder and we'll go to desktop and we'll
double click into that folder make sure
we're double clicked into it and say
select
folder there we go so we're in that
folder looks like we're not in there but
it's here uh in the top and you know
again I'm not going to go super heavy
into this because this is a completely
separate discipline but do your best to
follow along so we want to create a new
file you can do that by going to file
new text file up here you can also click
this little icon here to do that so
we'll go ahead and say new text file and
the question is is what are we going to
write our code in because um we're going
to need to uh write this in some kind of
language and so I'm just trying to
decide what we can use here um so that
is a another question as well so just
give me a second to think about it okay
you know instead of thinking about it
what I want to do is I'm just going to
go ask
um go ahead and take a look quickly so
we'll say it's probably in the slides
but I you know I can't remember all
these things off the top of my head AZ
dek
languages and so we'll go here and we'll
take a look and we have uh Android C go
C C++ iOS Java JavaScript python no Ruby
which I mean I think there's Ruby
somewhere but uh they haven't been
maintaining it very well so we do have a
few options here uh the question is
which one do we want to use uh I don't
really like any of these languages um
but but we're going to have to make a
choice and so I guess we could use
C so maybe what we'll do is go ahead and
use
C I almost feel like I'm going to regret
using that so um all right so anyway
what I want to show you here is
um yeah we'll write some C code and
actually we're going to cheat we're
going to go use chat GPT because I
really don't want to uh spend forever uh
figuring how to do it so we'll say uh um
using the Azure SDK for
C uh let's deploy a new Resource Group
or a new storage account in a new
Resource
Group group for blob
storage okay so we'll go ahead and hit
enter and we'll see what it
produces deploy a new aure storage
account for blob storage in a new
Resource Group using Azure SDK you're
going to need the following so it's
going to say install the Azure
SDK okay and so we'll just give it a
moment to uh uh spit out some stuff all
right so it's produced some code here
and so just taking a look here we have
our code example it's explaining
everything here but I don't need that
and so the idea here is that we first
are doing our Imports most programming
languages are going to have you require
import resources um so obviously
resource manager for uh uh uh creating
the resource and then we need storage
for storage accounts um identity for
probably connecting to Azure um that's
most likely what it is system is for
system stuff so maybe for doing outputs
and things like that and right away we
can see that we need to create our uh
credentials and then from there it's
saying initialize the arm client so arm
stands for Azure resource manager so I
imagine um that has something to do with
um maybe resource grips we'll see here
in a moment so we create the Azure
resource manager client and from there
we can get our default subscription that
makes sense and from the subscription
we'll get our resource groups and we'll
create or update a new one here and so
here it looks like it's going to create
our Resource Group the next we have um
our storage management client so it
looks like that's how we create our
storage account or at least it's the the
manager for it anyway and then um create
we're creating our storage account okay
that makes sense if this looks very
verbose and uh tricky it is um it's just
the nature of c c is a great language um
but I'm just going to say that the way
they choose to name things here I even
find a bit confusing and I work with
every single programming language but we
do have some code here and so the idea
is that we can go ahead and copy this
code and I'm going to go ahead and paste
this into Visual Studio code now I do
want to point out that um in order to
run this program we actually have to
have C installed and I'm not even sure
if I actually have that installed on
this computer um so we're going to have
to see what we can do uh there so I'm
going to go ahead and just save this
file and I'm just going to name it uh
we'll just say storage new storage
account uh. CS because that is the
extension for C and so it says do you
want to install the recommended C
extension for the language we'll say
install so the thing is is that Visual
Studio code on the left hand side they
have extensions and they have extensions
for
everything and and I just want to point
out that Azure because uh Microsoft
created this project and Microsoft owns
GitHub and all this stuff is uh Visual
Studio code has tons of synergies with
um with Azure and in fact you can create
resources and other things uh via uh
Visual Studio code directly um so here
it says the net cor SDK could not be
located um and so we can go here and say
get the SDK says do you want to uh uh
want to code to open the external
website yes and it's complaining because
it's saying hey you don't have this
installed it's not going to work and so
we could go ahead and install it here
that is one way to do it um but the
thing is it really depends on what kind
of machine you're on if you're on
Windows or Linux or Mac OS it's going to
be a different installation process so
we can do it this way but there's
another option and the other option that
um I'm going to recommend is to not do
it locally but do it in a cloud
developer environment now most um um
cloud service providers have have a
cloud developer environment uh adab us
has Cloud9 gcp has um I forget what it's
called project idx and they even have
one built into their uh their platform
but for whatever reason all we get is
cloud shell in Azure so um I like to
think of github's code spaces as azure's
um Cloud developer environment why it's
not directly integrated with Azure I
have no idea so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go over to GitHub and you
are going to have to create a GitHub
account and they're free and you should
absolutely have one because every person
that's working in Tech should have a
GitHub account but I'm going to go ahead
and log into mine I'll be back here in
just a moment and if you don't have one
go ahead and create yourself a GitHub
all right so I'm in my GitHub account
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
create myself a new
repository uh and again don't worry if
you don't know all of this just do your
best to follow along um because there is
a lot to learn here and I'm not trying
to overwhelm you but let's go ahead I'm
going to choose um the owner is myself
so you would have chosen a username when
when you signed up mine is Omen King I
also have like another account called
exam Pro Co I probably should use that
one and we're going to just say Azure
SDK C example uh so you can name it
exactly the same uh these are you uh you
can have the same name for repo that
someone else has because it's going to
be based on the scope of your name here
we can make it private or public I'm
going to make it public uh that that way
everyone's going to see it I'm going to
add a read me here as well and we're
going to go ahead and create this
repository so go ahead and create that
and we'll just give it a
moment and so now that that's been
created um you're not going to have this
get pod button here but what I'm going
to do is drop this
down and it's sorry code I want the code
button here and we have this option
called code spaces and so here um code
spaces does have a free tier or they
should have a free tier anyway yeah up
here and the free tier is going to let
us run for a short period of time I'm
not going to get fully into that because
because we're not going to be doing
enough coding to even worry about that
but we're going to go ahead and create
ourselves a code space on Main and U
honestly I actually prefer git pod for
cloud developer environments the reason
I'm using codes spaces is because um
Visual Studio code has a Marketplace so
if we go ahead and type in Visual Studio
code
Marketplace and um these are extensions
for visual studio code it's when we're
over here on the Le hand side and we're
installing uh fun plugins or extensions
they're coming from this Marketplace and
even though I prefer git pod um uh this
portal this is or this Marketplace is
provided by Microsoft and it's a
proprietary um Marketplace so all of the
official Microsoft Integrations are here
and if you use um uh a git pod you're
not going to be able to access the full
Suite of these you could technically use
them if you opened G pod within local
Visual Studio code I'm not going to do
that here today we're going to just go
ahead and use um code spaces and I don't
use code spaces that often but we're
going to use it here the first thing I
want to do is change the theme because I
do not want to look at white so I'm
going to go all the way down to the
bottom to this Cog here and I'm going to
go and go to settings or themes here we
go and we'll choose color theme and I'm
just going to go and say dark Visual
Studio code and now my eyes are thanking
me for uh putting that effort in and so
what I want to do is create a new file
so we can upload new files here by
dragging them so on our desktop here uh
we have this folder uh and this file so
I'm going to go ahead and just drag this
file on
over okay and the thing about uh codes
spaces and and G pod is that they should
have a lot of these things pre-installed
so down below here it says do you want
to install the recommended C dev kit yes
please I would love to have the dev kit
so the devkit helps you manage your code
with a Solutions Explorer and test your
code sounds great to me and we're going
to go Ahad ahead and let that install
now I want to point out that the way
these Cloud developer environments work
is as long as you are running them they
are consuming spend so if you are trying
to walk away and go get coffee or or
food please please please make sure you
close the tab um so that it's not just
running and you're uh exped uh utilizing
uh credits or usage uh again you're on a
free tier but let's make sure we don't
use up all that free tier so I think
that extension is now
installed and so uh we should start to
be able to use uh C so what we'll do is
go back over here and we have our new
file and it's right here uh and so we
have our program uh and so we should be
able to run it so there's a few values
we need we need our subscription ID our
Resource Group name our storage account
our location okay so these are the few
things we're going to want to fill out
um so I'm going to go here and yeah I'll
take West us I don't care it doesn't
matter we'll say West us then we have
our storage account name remember that
has to be very unique so I'm just going
to say hello world and I'm going to put
a bunch of numbers here and I'm going to
say AB remember to keep it lowercase and
not any trouble here and here for the
resource resource Group we're going to
say my um SDK did we already create
one no we didn't so we'll say my
SDK
um RG and then we need our subscription
ID so we'll go over here subscription ID
is is going to be um if we click uh into
our
subscriptions it's right here so we'll
go ahead and copy that
in okay and we'll make our way back over
to here I'm going to go ahead and paste
that
in we'll say allow good we'll click oops
try not to add any additional characters
by accident be very careful but yeah
that looks fine to me and so I filled in
all the things that it's say saying that
I need I also want to point out that you
know chat chapt generated the code but
it doesn't always give you good code so
just understand that we could run this
and it it could possibly not work um and
it might even give us things that we
don't want so always make sure you can
understand what you're reading so here
it's saying it's using the standard lrs
which is good it's using storage version
two so everything that we've been doing
up to this point and so now I want to
run this code um so uh again I don't run
C code a lot but sometimes it uses mono
sometimes it uses um different engines
for running but let's go take a look at
our extensions and we'll click into this
one and see if there's any options to
start running it so it does say there's
like build and run options
here um so it says command
shift net build so it's possibly we can
build it that way and that's probably
the way I'd like to build it so we'll go
back over here and the thing is that we
have haven't logged into anything so
it's my assumption that this isn't going
to work okay so what I want to do is I
want to open up the command pallet so I
believe we go down here to the bottom
left corner click the Cog if we do if we
type in shift uh uh control shift p or
click this button it'll open the command
pallet and what we're looking for is
that net build so I'm going to go ahead
and do net build and see if that
works I did click it we'll try this
again command
pallet says we used itm
build and I'm not seeing anything
happening so did it build I'm not sure
so give me just a moment all right so I
went over and I asked chbt how can I
just run it and it was not helpful
whatsoever um it did tell us that we
should probably have the a uh the um the
Azure seall which I absolutely agree so
this is a great opportunity for us to uh
do that here in fact it might already
pre be pre-installed so if we just type
in a is it here here no it does not um
so maybe that's something we can go do
so I'm going to go type in AZ CLI
install and we'll go get the
instructions for
that and so I want to install this for
Linux uh we're probably on Ubuntu or
Debian so I'm going to go ahead and
click that and I'm going to go to
install Azure
C and so we want this on line command
I've done this a lot of time so I know
it's this on line command so we'll go
ahead and copy that and we'll go back
over to GitHub code spaces and we'll go
and paste that in there now I realize
this font might be a little bit small so
while that is installing I'm going to go
ahead and increase our
font so I'll go ahead and increase our
font size I'm going to type in here
terminal and if you're finding that I'm
going really fast the great thing is you
can always go back and watch the video I
really do encourage you to try to work
through the steps and try to figure out
what it is that I'm doing um of course I
could go a little bit slower but
um the best learning is the part where
you're going to go out and uh you know
try to really figure out what it is that
I'm doing here so that's why I'm not
being super super detailed and slow with
these steps um but uh you know just be
aware of that so I'm just typing
terminal font in here because I want to
increase that
font uh there it is and so we'll just
say 24 there we
go that might be a little bit too big
we'll go down to
20 okay and so the CLI is now installed
so if we type in AZ
um it will now should prompt us and so
now the next thing we want to do is log
in so I'm going to type in a login and
so what it did is it as soon as we typed
in a login it popped up a new browser
window and it's allowing us to connect
to Microsoft
Azure so I click this and uh even though
it's not going anywhere that's totally
okay we'll go back over here and it
didn't work because we are not doing
this on our local machine we are doing
this within a browser so it says if uh
if no browser is available or if the web
browser fails to open use the device
code below so that's what we're going to
do we're going to actually do that
instead so I'm going to type in a login
hyphen hyphen user device code and hit
enter okay and we're going to give it a
moment here oh and then it says copy
this link so we're going to go to this
link
here and hit
enter and it's going to say enter this
code in and so we'll go
ahead and enter in this code that it
want okay and we'll hit next and then
we'll pick our account are you trying to
log with the a CLI we absolutely
are we'll go back over to
here and it now gives us output so we
are now logged into Azure CLI so now
that the CLI is installed um we're in
better
shape the thing is when you when you log
into the Azure CLI uh I don't know where
it is but it's probably dumping some
kind of file locally onto this
computer onto this workspace if I type
in LS so somewhere in here I'm not sure
where but somewhere in the in the in
this on the storage of this workspace in
the cloud it's storing the credentials
to log Us in so we don't have to pass in
or we shouldn't have to pass in
credentials here and when we run the
script it's going to rely on that local
file uh and it should pull it from these
default credentials so the next thing I
want to do is run this program
and it really did not tell us how to do
that so um I I should know how because I
do have uh my own uh unpublished thing
so I'm going to go take a look and find
those instructions all right so I just
want to point out that you will not have
access to this this is totally private
but I'm just trying to find notes from
it and I also wanted to prove that I
actually do know all the programming
languages for cloud um but knowing them
uh when I say I know them I mean like
I've used them all and I've made really
good notes notes and so when I need to
go back to them I can always look it up
and so somewhere here we should have
some notes for
c um and because there's a few different
ways we can run it there's a program
called CSC uh which is the turbo
compiler um so it depends on what we
want to
utilize and we could use
nougat we could have also created a net
uh a net project that's probably what we
should have done um so that's probably
what we should have done is we probably
should have created ourselves a net
project because now that I'm um
remembering that's pretty much the way
that we do it okay and that's going to
make our life a lot easier for um
utilizing so what I'm going to do is
just take a look here and let's go back
to chat 2bt and say okay um how do we
use the Azure SDK C and we create a new
new uh
uhet
project okay and so this should be more
in line in terms of what we want so chbt
is only good if you know what to ask it
and it's talking about new get packages
and that definitely is what it looks
like I was doing there before so we'll
give it a moment here to help us uh see
what's going
on I just want those
commands
and it's asking us to do this through
it's it's like telling us to click
through it's going it's saying like go
up here and click click click like
create a new create a new project in
there but that's not how I want to do it
I want to do it via the um the CLI and
all I wanted to know was whoops I just
closed that tab we actually needed that
tab um but what I wanted to know was
what framework version does it want us
to use because uh that could matter
right and that's what we're not getting
answer uh for so that's kind of
important so we'll go back over to
here and it's really really really not
helping
us this is not helpful whatsoever so I'm
just going to tell it to stop talking
because I know it's not helping us and
I'm just going to pull up that example
again just give me a moment all right so
I have this pulled up again I'm going to
go back to my hello world again you're
not going to have this you don't need
you don't need to have direct access to
this it's fine um and then down below
there is the thing here so we need to
create ourselves a new project we're
going to say new console because it's a
console project and we're going to want
to have that package so I'm just going
to drag this off screen so I can see it
and type it and then you'll just have to
follow along here with me okay just give
me just two
seconds to be able to see this
here
and okay so what we're going to do is go
back over to
here to our project and and I'm going to
try this I'm going to typee in new new
console hyphen n we're going to say
package. net and we're going to try
framework net 60 even if there was a
newer version of the framework we could
use for um C or for net sometimes it
doesn't like the latest version um so
even over here like I made a note I said
even though net is the latest neither
fake nor bogus works with net 7.0 so you
know I'm going to try to use seven and
hopefully we're not going to run into
issues
here and so it did a bunch of stuff and
it created this uh package over here so
it actually created a folder called
package. net if we open it up uh we have
a program and so that's where our code
has to go so I'm going to go ahead and I
know this is a bit of a mess but I'm
going to go ahead and copy this over
here and I'm going to take all of this
and we're going to cut this we're go
over this program and we're we're going
to paste it into here okay and I'll
delete the old file
here so now we have um our package um
and we're in better shape so now we can
probably use those net commands to um
build the package that's probably what
we can do here so that's what I would
like to do next so I have to find that
command um I believe it's just net run
so if we type in
netrun um that should probably do it
couldn't find a project so we probably
have to CD into that folder so I'll type
in CD package
h.net enter I'm going to type in LS to
see what's in there I'm going to type in
cleer clear to clear the
screen I'm going to go ahead and type
Inn net
run okay and hopefully it's just going
to run it now we didn't install any uh
packages for it so I don't know how we
would know how to run these it looks
like it's actually complaining it's
saying uh the typer namespace name Azure
could not be found it's talking about
this up here so normally you like in
programming languages you have to
install packages or libraries and every
single um programming language usually
has its own package manager and I
believe the one for
um uh net or the the one for that one is
called nougat n u g so there's probably
a way to add it and it's actually
probably part of because I'm looking at
my commands here it's probably part of
um uh n get's probably part of net so
I'm going to type in net add package and
we need to figure out what the package
name is so I'm going just type in Azure
because it's probably what it is I'm
going to go ahead and hit enter and uh
we have to actually spell net correctly
for that to work again this is just me
totally guessing but I believe that's
what's going to work and so I go up here
and it looks like it's trying to install
something it's talking about this
falling back here and then it says error
there is no version available for the
package Azure so clearly there is uh
something more to this here so
Azure
uh
net net n get package and version so
that's what I'm looking for
here
okay and I'm just trying to
find what it is so I don't want to
search the internet for that so I want
to install the Azure SDK via
net add package what is the
command okay once you know
programming chat GPT is great because
you can narrow it down and help you save
you some time but uh it's not always
easy and sometimes it just doesn't tell
you what you want to hear right away so
here it's saying Azure identity ah so it
looks like we might have to do do them
individually okay so let's go give that
a try so I'm going to go back over to uh
GitHub uh in our uh code spaces now
let's try each of these individually so
I'm hitting up I'm going to try
identity let's see what
happens it looks like it's installing
that looks great okay great so we're on
to something here excellent so we have
that one the next one is resource
manager so I'll paste that in there
enter
just going to bring this over here um I
don't know if we need to specify these
individually underneath so I'm just
going to copy them anyway and just try
them again I don't know if we have to do
that often when you have the top level
one you get them all but since um doing
the top level Azure didn't work I don't
trust it and it did install something so
that looked like that work we'll do
storage
next and these two are not going to do
because these are buil-in packages we
don't have to go ahead and and install
them very common for most languages so
I'm going to type in clear here to clear
on our screen I'm going to hit up up up
till we get back to that run command and
we're going to try
that it says there is no given argument
that corresponds to the required
parameter data um here and it's saying
on line 2490 so we're going to go down
below and look at line
24 and it's complaining about this uh
saying something about data so there's
no argument given that responds to the
required parameter
data um and so probably what might be
happening here is either well chbt gave
us bad code um or it it's looking at Old
documentation so it's not that it
purposely gave us bad code it just
doesn't know what's the latest there's a
few other errors here like the name s s
KU name does not exist in the current
context the kind does not exist in the
current context and it's talking about
this here so it really looks like
like um uh chat GPT lied to us okay so
what we can do is we can just go ahead
and paste this into chat GPT and see if
it can try to solve it for us if not we
can go look it up ourselves uh we get
the following errors uh from the code
provided earlier in this
chat okay so uh for me like I would just
go out to the documentation go fix it um
I'm trying to show you how you would do
this if you don't have the same kind of
uh programming skills so here it's
saying the errors you encountered uh
project suggest some issues great so
it's just going to tell us what problems
it had and then we're going to wait just
a moment and find out um what it
is make sure you have the latest
packages well we just installed them so
it should be
correct okay well the other thing is
that we don't know what
versions uh Azure was using right so
that might be the
issue check the latest SDK
documentation of
course yeah so it's okay the suggest
code
changes like come on you're not really
helping me today chat
GPT
all right and we'll take a look here at
what it's
saying so looking at this very
carefully here it says uh new Resource
Group data and then this one here is
saying create or
async um so it looks slightly different
the meth seems to require additional
parameter okay it's guessing it doesn't
know what it's doing so I really don't
trust it anymore and so what we'll do is
we'll go back here and take a look at
our code the first one it failed on was
line
24 all right and so that's on here so
um we need to go figure this out I'm
going to close some of these tabs
because we're kind of getting
overwhelmed with tabs
here and I'm going to go type in Azure
SDK
C and we'll go over
here uh we'll say storage
accounts
and we're going to try to figure out if
we can find some official
docs okay ay login we've already done
this here they're using visual studio
we're not using uh well this this is how
it did it over here which is
fine um but we just want to see the
reference docs so yeah it's talking
about blob storage which is great let's
go to reference
Azure uh it might be whoops might be
over
here Azure
SDK C reference
documentation we'll go over here and uh
we're looking for these commands so the
first one it it mucked up on was line 24
so I believe this one's
okay uh this is for creating a resource
Group
so we'll go here and I'm going to search
Resource
Group it's probably under resource
manager
and here showing that we add that net
package so that makes sense uh and so we
have this line here so if we go back to
our code do we have that line Looks like
we do right new arm client uh yeah it's
down here sorry new arm client so that's
right now we get a resource Group
collection
so this one's slightly different it's
trying to do it all in one go um which
that's one way of coding it but I
actually kind of prefer what they're
doing here in the documentation so I'm
going to go ahead and grab this so that
we assign this to its own
variable okay in coding you can do
things uh multiple ways so um you know
one code can do the exact same thing as
something else and be written
differently that can make it very
confusing if you don't know what you're
looking at we'll go ahead and paste this
one NE uh in next so uh looks like I cut
off a bit of that code
there okay and so this is now the
equivalent of this so that gets that
part and then this is equivalent of that
so that's that part and so next thing we
need to do is this create or async thing
so we'll go to the next
step
and we already have uh these two things
set up here as
strings this one set as an Azure
location
so we probably want to do what they're
doing here
too okay so I'm going to go up here and
paste this in like this
instead
okay um and it really depends on what
the thing wants so maybe in the older
the older SDK it took a string but now
it looks like it takes a a variable data
type of azure location that's why I'm
doing it this way okay um so that looks
fine there the next part is Resource
Group data
so that looks very similar to our code
here notice it's not doing a create or
async update I mean that's probably one
way of doing it and probably a good way
of doing it make sure you put these
semicolons on the end here um C really
likes these some languages don't care
but this one does and then it does it on
the next step here so it does it
here okay so it's still doing that
operation so we'll paste that
in and I don't know where it went didn't
really go where I wanted to go we'll go
ahead and paste that in again here and
we'll hit
enter so we have arm operation uh I
don't feel like explaining this part but
that's a feature of C coding uh that's
like an interface I believe I think
that's what they call it uh so we have
to create or upsate uh update or async
so wait until it's done uh pass in the
resource Group name which is that up
here and then pass in the resource Group
data which is that here and so that
takes care of this part okay so we've
now replaced that part of the code um so
that is fine that will create our
Resource Group and the next thing we
need to do is uh create our storage um
our storage account so to be honest
because this code is so hard to do I'm
going to make it a lot easier for us I'm
just going to wipe this part out because
if we can just make a resource Group
we've kind of done enough coding here
but uh the whole process we went through
in terms of of uh you know think like
starting with a single file and having
to work with it and then we moved over
to the CD uh um uh uh GitHub codes
spaces which is a cloud developer
environment and we had to do some
research this is totally normal this is
what happens every single day so I'm
really happy that we're able to uh show
that even if it is a bit of a mess but
let's go ahead and see if uh this works
um the only thing I'm wondering is about
this Azure location how does it know
about it because we didn't have any
requirement up here but we'll go ahead
and we'll try to do a net run and it
might complain about that so it says the
variable subscription ID is assigned but
the value is never used and that's true
we don't actually ever use it anywhere
here the variable storage name account
is a sign but it's the value is never
used and that's because we don't ever
use these so um these are warnings
they're not errors but I'm going to go
ahead and delete this one up because
we're actually not using a storage
account name whoops that's a bit too
much and we should probably be using a
description ID but for the time being
I'm going to comment that out I'm going
to assume that it can in uh infer the
subcription ID based on when we did the
a login so we're going to go and go up
here a bit it says the typ or name space
aure location could not be found that's
what I I thought was going to
happen so how would we include that in
here um we already have resource manager
in here right we do and we're not really
using these other ones anymore um so
this one I'm not 100% sure so we'll
say add meure
location and we'll go back over to here
because they this is the thing with
tutorials they don't always tell you all
of the code they're sometimes missing
something so uh we need to go figure
that out and I'm going to go back over
here okay so it cannot be found and
we'll use y old Google for this because
it should be smart enough to do
this
it's not telling us here so we'll go and
try chat
GPT um Azure location is not found uh in
my C script what package do I need to
install you'd think it'd be the resource
manager
one okay just tell me what I want to
install
it does say Azure resource
manager so coming back over to here in
our code we have it right
here and we have those two there
yep I mean I'm pretty sure we installed
that uh we probably still need the re
resources one in so I'm going to bring
that
back whoops whoops whoops
whoops and we'll go ahead and paste that
in we'll save that
um yeah this one's quite the pickle
so the Azure location does not exist in
the current
context all right let me go figure it
out okay all right so I'm not getting uh
much luck here but I imagine that this
might be actually olving as a string
anyway I'm not 100% sure so I'm going to
try to cheat and I'm going to try to
make this a string and see what happens
and it might work uh but I'm not 100%
sure so I'm going to go ahead and just
say um West us here I'm going to go
ahead and comment this out and fingers
crossed that it's going to let us do
this programming is not always easy um
it's it's sometimes like this it says
the client does not exist in the current
context the the name name wait until
does not exist in the current context
wow it's really making our lives super
super super difficult here it's talking
about
these
um and it's frustrating because it's not
showing us in this code
example all the stuff so I'm going to go
ahead and copy this code example go back
to chat gbt um
uh uh can you show me what
using
statements are missing and should be
added to get this code to
work very very often programs do not
show you all those things and it drives
me
crazy okay and it could be because like
if you're using visual uh Visual Studio
which is not the same thing as Visual
Studio code it would automatically add
those in
there okay and so here it's saying okay
we got to use models for Azure
location okay but what
about but what about um some of these
other ones like well anyway we're going
to go ahead and copy them in and we're
going to give it a go we didn't have
this Azure core here before that
probably is very important so we go
ahead and paste that in and I'm going to
go ahead and uh do net uh
package uh was it new or install or it's
add Azure core we'll do that
you know what if we did python or
JavaScript we have been done this a long
time ago but uh you know I would say
that getting exposure to net is probably
the best one for uh working with Azure
here so I don't know if it installed all
of these we'll try resources we probably
don't need the model
part um oh sorry this is resource
manager
resources
and then we'll go here and we'll say
resources models again I don't know if
we really need all the the end ones like
that I don't think so yeah there's no
versions of it so probably the upper
ones is the one that works we'll go
ahead and try this again please please
please work or give me something
different the name client does not exist
in the current context it is killing me
this program client where is that here
let's search for that let's look for
that
client right here
client um well maybe it's because this
one's named a bit differently so we're
coming back to code this one's called
client right here this one is called arm
client so we'll just change this to
client okay we'll save that we'll hit up
please please
work getting closer we have this wait
until say what about wait
until see if you figures that one
out
and it's telling me to use Azure in the
top level that seems kind of uh
exhaustive the wait until uh you need to
include Azure name space okay I mean
that doesn't sound right to me but we'll
go ahead and do that anyway unless it's
saying I mean if it's in that Nam space
couldn't we just say Azure do wait until
I'm not really sure but we'll go ahead
people that are probably like better C
programmers than me are just cringing
watching me do this but go ahead and uh
try to see if that we get that working
here we still say
run please tell me you don't need me to
install Azure as well because we have it
installed like 10 different ways please
please please
work it's taking time so I mean that's
probably a good indication oh it worked
okay so I'm going to go back over here I
cannot believe that worked that was so
so hard and we never even created a
storage count within it so this one's
called my SDK RG
um so what we're going to
do why does it say St oh because the
comment still says that down here below
so just say uh Resource Group
here and for all our hard work let's
save that so um we never have to look
for that again it's trying to include a
lot of junk in here um so I don't want
all this stuff otherwise uh that'd be
too much to commit so I'm going to go
here and make a new dog ignore file dog
ignore okay and I want to ignore this uh
Bin directory and this probably object
directory no just the bin directory um
make sure we spell this right
dotg
ignore and in here I'm going to say
ignore I want to ignore package. net
bin uh and then Aster so it should
ignore that entire directory if we go
over here and we give this a
refresh um just going to make sure this
is all correct
here
there's a lot of stuff in here I don't
think we should be seeing that much so
I'm going to go here and do
package. net for SL obj debug so I have
a feeling that it's trying to include
all this stuff in
here there we go and so this looks a lot
more manageable to me I don't know if we
want to
include uh this file this looks like it
should be in there yeah I'm going to go
ahead and just go ahead and add this
code and we'll just say uh create an
measure Resource
Group using the C SDK if you were able
to get to the end here pat yourself on
the back because that was uh quite the
challenge uh if you're just able to
watch the video that's totally fine as
well um here it should commit and push
so I've pushed my code I'm going to go
back over to
um uh the the repo in GitHub so go back
over
here and I'm going to search for
Azure what do we call this this is under
exam Pro for you you it might be
different I called it this here Azure
SDK C I just want to make sure my code
is here it is if you are trying to do
this and you do not want to struggle you
can go find my code and copy it here but
again I'm just trying to get you
exposure to this stuff I'm not trying to
make you super programmers so it's not a
big deal um we're done with this uh code
space so I do want to shut it down and I
don't do this very often with code
spaces let's see if there's like shut
down
close stop okay here it is code spaces
stop current codes space I'm going to go
ahead and click that and notice that is
now stopping the workspace that's going
to stop the
spend all right we're going to go over
here this Resource Group has nothing in
it but we'll go ahead and delete
it and there there we go we'll go ahead
and delete that and we're finally done I
really didn't think it would take this
long but anyway we are done and I'll see
you in the next one
[Music]
okay all right so let's take a quick
introduction into Azure resource manager
which is short for arm and is a service
that allows you to manage Azure
resources and one thing that really
confused me about the service when I
first sted using Azure was that you
couldn't just type in Azure resource
manager and the reason why is because
it's actually a collection of services
and it makes up what we call this
management layer it allows you to do
things like create update delete
resources apply management features such
as access controls locks and tags uh
writing infrastructure is code via Json
templates and there are very specific
features we're going to be looking at
that make up the armed layer and it's
going to be the following so you're
going to be looking at subscriptions
management groups resource groups uh
resource providers resource locks Azure
blueprints resource tags access control
so also known as IM uh Ro base access
controls Azure policies and arm
templates uh I don't know why I don't
have tenant in there I might have in
another slide but it's not a big deal
but that is what we're going to be
covering in this Azure resource manager
section all
[Music]
right so let's take a quick look at uh
the use case for Azure resource manager
and this is just to kind of give you a
visualization because it is an abstract
thing so I just want you to have some
kind of picture in your head of what it
is so here I have this diagram and just
to follow up with this Tech think of
azure resource manager as a gatekeeper
and all requests flow through arm and it
decides whether that request can be
performed on a resource and so on the
left hand side you have your requests
and so requests could be happening in
the Azure portal VI the Azure Powershell
the CLI or the rest client which would
be the API uh and then you can see the
two middle ones would use the Azure SDK
and in the middle that's the gatekeeper
and so we have Azure resource manager
that's going to work in conjunction with
your authentication uh authentication
which generally should be active
directory I don't think you can swap
that out for anything else and then on
the right hand side you're going to get
access to resources so this could be
virtual machines containers databases
and storage there's obviously a lot of
uh Azure services but that is what it is
in a
[Music]
snapshot so let's understand understand
the concept of scoping because this is
going to help you understand all the
components that are involved with azurus
resource manager so what is a scope a
scope is a boundary of control for Azure
resources and it is a way to govern your
resources by placing resources within a
logical grouping applying logical
restrictions in the form of rules uh and
so let's now go break down um what uh
these Scopes are and so the first scope
we're going to talk about is management
groups and this is a logical grouping of
multiple subscriptions uh just because
you can have a lot of subscriptions in
your account and you might want a
subscription to um a collection of
subscriptions to belong to some kind of
domain so maybe it's for development or
business or uh data Sciences whatever
you want then you have a subscription
and this grants you access to Azure
Services based on a billing and support
agreement um so the idea is that uh when
you launch resources you're going to
choose what subscription to go under
it's just going to determine the billing
okay under that um things you're going
to pay for uh then you have re groups
this is a logical grouping of multiple
resources within a subscription then you
have resources this is um the actual
service itself like Azure virtual
machine and I just want you to know that
we're going to revisit the scope when we
go look at ro-based access controls
because that's going to really help it
uh make a lot more sense okay but uh
let's just go jump into some of these
Scopes in specific and talk about them a
bit
[Music]
more so let's take a look at arm
templates uh and before we jump into it
let's just make sure we're familiar with
infrastructure is code cuz that's what
arm templates are all about and this is
the process of managing and provisioning
computer center uh data centers such as
Azure through machine readable
definition files such as adjacent file
and in this case an arm template because
that's all it is ajason file and rather
than physical Hardware configuration or
interactive configuration tools and just
to simplify that even further basically
you're writing a script that's going to
set up your cloud services for you and
with iac's they usually come in two
different flavors we have declarative
that's where uh exactly what you write
is what you get and imperative so you're
going to generally Define what you want
and then the service will guess uh what
you want it's going to fill in the
blanks to save you a lot of time writing
those scripts uh and so uh arm templates
are Json files that are def that Define
Azure resources that you want to
provision uh and Azure services that you
want to configure and with arm templates
they are going to be declarative so you
get exactly what you define uh they're
going to stand end up tear down or share
entire architectures in minutes and
they're going to reduce configuration
mistakes and you know exactly what you
have defined for a stack to establish an
architectural Baseline for compliance so
you definitely want to use Arm templates
or IAC whenever you can and try to avoid
using the console unless you're doing
development or test workloads but let's
just run through the big list of what
you can do with an arm template I know
this is a big boring list but let's just
get it uh get through it as quickly as
possible just so we know what we can do
with armed templates so with armed
templates that are declarative so what
you see is what you get you can stand up
tear down share entire environment
minutes you can reduce configuration
mistakes you can establish an
architectural Baseline for compliance
there uh modular so you can break up
your architecture in multiple files and
reuse them they're extendable so you can
add Powershell and Bash scripts to your
templates uh it has testing so you can
use the arm ttk uh to test make sure
exactly what uh what you've deployed is
what you wanted
um you have preview changes so before uh
you create infrastructure via templates
you see what it will create built-in
validation so it will only deploy your
template if it passes track deployments
keep track of changes to your
architecture over time policy is code so
apply Azure policies to ensure you you
remain compliant uh and then you have
Microsoft blueprints which we we did
Cover here uh which establishes
relationships between resources and
templates so it's just one step further
where arm templates don't have any
relationship with the resources where
blueprints like a better version of arm
templates and then you have cicd
integration exportable code so exporting
the current state of the resource groups
and resources uh authoring tools I
believe is the last on our list here so
you can use Visual Studio code that has
advanced features for authoring arm
templates makes it a lot easier to write
them so there you
[Music]
go okay so now what I want to do is
cover infrastructure as code for Azure
so there are two uh primary ways of
doing infrastructures code we have arm
templates the arm stands for Azure
resource manager and the other one is
azure biceps we're going to focus on the
first one uh infrastructure as a code is
the concept of um uh defining all your
infrastructure as code uh and that might
be confusing because that might sound
like s the SDK or the CLI and uh it is
confusing until you start working with
it but the key difference is that when
you use the CLI or the SDK uh to
programmatically create resources they
don't keep uh track of the State uh and
so that is the key difference between
that whereas if you ran a CLI command to
create uh let's say a virtual machine
and you ran it again with the same
parameters and the same name it would
attempt to create a second um virtual
machine whereas with infrastructure as
code if it's already there it's going to
either update it or say hey you can't
update it there's already one that
exists so the idea is that um uh it's
different in that process or in that
sense uh there is a word for it um I
believe the word is IDP poent uh I
always have a hard time saying it but um
that is the key difference between those
programming methods and iic so what I
want to show you is uh arm templates and
um arm again stands for Azure resource
manager it's part of resource groups so
if we type in arm here we're not going
to really get uh a service or anything
like that we say azure or as your
resource
manager okay you're just not going to uh
exactly get that because um it is it is
something that's there but it really is
talking about resource groups so when
you deploy a resource Group it will
always create an arm template for you no
matter if you do click Ops um you'll
always get an arm template and this is
something that is very different from
other providers so like when you use ads
or
gcp um when you launch a resource it
doesn't necessarily will produce a uh a
template for you but Azure is very
unique in that sense that they will do
that so what I want to do is I want to
go ahead and explore some things with
arm templates so you're very aware of
how they work and I believe that uh
there is a way to uh deploy if we type
in template here there should be
something like deploy a custom template
whoops and that's how you would go about
deploying a custom template and they
actually already have some common
templates here so maybe we can uh take a
look at one as a quick start and try to
understand uh what the templates look
like another key difference between
other cloud service providers is that
it's not very common to write arm
templates by hand um in fact it's very
tedious and you would not necessarily
want to do it as opposed to ads where
you have cloud formation it's totally
normal to do and that's why um having a
layer on top of uh arm makes it so much
easier like using again Azure bicep or
terraform let's go ahead and create a
Linux virtual machine here and notice
that I select the template and it has
some options here so um what I want to
show you here this looks like the usual
process for setting up a um a virtual
machine but if we go here we can edit
the template and then it's going to
allow us to see what this template looks
like so arm templates this is what it
looks like and I believe that uh they're
only Jason I kind of
forget Let's go ask chat GPT so are arm
templates uh in Azure only Jason or can
they also be yaml the reason why I I
don't remember is because I work with a
lot of cloud service providers usually
they'll provide both options um but
generally uh I always remember that arm
templates are only Json so there is no
yaml support for it but of course you
could use yaml locally and then convert
it over back to Json but anyway so if we
look at this here we have some things we
have the schema that describes what the
format of this Json should be um we have
some metadata which probably gets
autogenerated or is additional U
information to attach the template we uh
we have parameters so these are going to
be values that we're inputting that
allow us to uh make our template
reusable and if we scroll on down um
yeah we got variables which is
probably um the modification of
parameters and then we have our
resources down below here and you know
again if you've seen cloud formation
templates or uh deployment manager gcp
deployment uh scripts these are going to
look very very similar so we we Define
the type for the res ource uh we have a
name for it then it has its properties
uh and then it can depend on other
resources to say what order uh they're
performed in but anyway my point is is
that uh this is a template and we can go
ahead and actually uh deploy this
template but I'm not that interested in
that part of it because this is not that
exciting what's more exciting is what
happens when you do click offs so I'm
going to go over uh over here and uh
deploy a virtual
machine m
yeah I mean we could do virtual machine
I'm just trying to think what's easier
maybe we'll go ahead and actually do
I've changed my mind we're going to
actually go ahead and do uh storage
accounts again I'm still in the free
tier and I'm just trying to make things
easy for you as well um and virtu
virtual machines will spin up a lot of
resources so maybe I don't want
something that complicated uh for this
example but what I want to do is I want
to launch a virtual uh a storage account
and then I want to see how we can look
at the template and maybe we'll attempt
to repport the template at at and then
delete the storage account and recreate
it so go here and I'm going to hit
create and we're going to create
ourselves a new Resource Group I'm going
to call this Resource Group
um uh
my uh arm RG so arm for Azure resource
manager and today it's really thinking I
don't know if I'm having internet issues
here or if it's just really complaining
or if Azure slow Azure uh sometimes
their UI is not always responsive and we
have to give this a name of course we
have to make sure this is very unique so
I'm going say my um storage account a
bunch of numbers and then my
initials and it probably has too many
letters so it's complaining there we go
and I'll just let it choose whatever
region wants we'll have it on standard
that's totally fine I'm going to go
ahead and go to review where we can see
all of our options looks fine to me
we'll go down the bottom hit create and
we'll give it a moment here to create so
I'll be back in just a second
all right so that deployment is complete
and what I'm interested in is checking
out uh the resource Group but notice
that when we've deployed this we have
our inputs it shows us what we've
inputed and we looked at the uh
parameters of a template before so it is
creating literally an arm template and
then inputting the parameters it's
showing this the outputs of uh that arm
template and then here's the template
itself so every time you deploy as your
resources it is creating uh these IAC
code for you and that is one of the
greatest advantages of azure as much as
I complain about Azure this is one of
their really really good features and
there's a few things you can do like it
looks like we can add this to our
library we can download this we can
deploy it again let's go ahead I usually
don't uh fiddle with these too much but
we can um import this template and I can
say uh my Resource Group but just
remember you could have a lot of
resources and really make that uh uh ret
templated I'm going to choose the same
um area here and this will just be
version 1.0.0 down here I'm going to go
to next it shows me the template next uh
we can do some tagging I'm going to
ignore that for now review and
create and so now we have our own uh
template so that's kind of cool um if we
go back to here I'm not exactly sure
where they oh we have to hit create
maybe first it's not super clear but uh
so that is now uh template has been
saved but where did it save to uh just
says it's a template
spec it is really taking its time to
load
here okay and so we have our template
here I'm not sure if we if we typed in
templates here if they'd show up here
they I guess they show up under template
specs uh we'll refresh this not sure why
it doesn't show up we know that we
created it and you know I've said this
in other videos where Azure doesn't
always propagate things right away and
you have to wait so you have to have
confidence in waiting for things to show
up an Azure so even though it's not here
I know I created one okay so we go over
here it says template spec succeeded so
it really really I think it would show
up here um and I I really want to prove
that it will show up here eventually so
what I'm going to do is just take a
break and I'm going to give it like 10
15 minutes I'm going to give it a good
chunk of time here and we'll come back
and see if it appears um just to give
you validation and confidence that
patience always uh pays off here in
Azure okay all right so I've waited a
good chunk of time was just talking to
Bo and um so I'm now I'm back and let's
see if it is here we're going to give a
refresh and look it's here so I told you
you got to be really really patient with
Azure it is really known for being slow
for uh some particular
resources and I when I say some I mean a
lot so you know just have that patience
there but anyway what I want to do is
I'm going to open up another tab we're
going to go back over every time I open
that new tab and wants me log in that's
great um but what I want to do is go
over to our resource groups and we're
going to go into that new one that we
created and what I want to do is I just
want to delete this resource here um and
I want to see what happens if we attempt
to redeploy our uh template there I
assume we're going to have
to I mean we don't have to delete this
one but um I just want to remve it
completely and just try utilizing an arm
template so we'll give it a moment there
and oh notice we have an upgrade button
this is uh definitely new we might be
going through
our not sure why it's uh appearing all
of a sudden I've actually never seen
that button before so it's really
interesting and NOP I guess it's just
maybe after a while they just kind of
poke you and over here we're getting our
prompt so um it looks like we're
starting to get some spend and you know
I said earlier that Azure is really good
about telling us about um alerts and
things like that much better than other
providers um and so you know here it's
showing in Canadian dollars that uh
we've already uh consumed half our spend
not sure how I did that because I
haven't really done a whole lot
but um what we'll do is we'll try to
figure out where that that uh free spend
has been going um still again that's a
lot um so maybe it's overestimating that
or I left something running maybe that
Kuan a cluster is still running I don't
think so let's go double
check and but anyway I wanted that to
happen so I could go back and show a
video of of that kind of stuff because
all we created is a couple virtual
machines and some other things yeah we
don't have anything else running that
should be costing us spend but we'll go
take a look there and see what we can
figure out so anyway I'm going to go
back here give this a
refresh and um that resource is gone
what's interesting is it also got rid of
the template why did it get rid of the
template that that was something we
created
separately and so I guess it was linked
to the resource Group and so that kind
of defeats the purpose of us uploading
our arm template so that's a shame um I
guess what we could do is we could go
and M
I don't know we could go and use the
custom provider and launch a template
but there's not much interest in that so
uh I'm not really interested in doing
that yeah I think we're pretty much done
here I think we've we've proved the
point that Azure is really good at
producing These Arm templates you're not
going to want to write them by hand um
you could ask CH PT to do it but I again
I would probably not do that myself but
I think that satisfies this video for
arm templates so we'll see you in the
next one okay
[Music]
all right so we looked at uh utilizing
arm templates and I think it' also be
really great to look at Azure bicep um
because that is a more productive way to
write infrastructure as code um and
honestly I really like Azure bicep I
think it's really really cool uh so what
I want to do is I want to go ahead and
go over back to GitHub we looked at
creating a GitHub or creating a repoing
GitHub uh back in our SDK video that was
a really messy video I'm really hoping
that it's not as crazy as that one but I
don't like editing out any of the
challenges uh here cuz I want to give
you uh the full idea of of what it looks
like when trying to work through these
things what I'm going to do is go over
to GitHub and you should of course go
ahead and create yourself a GitHub
account has a free tier uh and once you
have your GitHub account we'll make a
new repo I'm going to uh drop down uh
here and go to exam Pro and of course
you'll just have one name here if I have
multiple accounts so there's a lot for
me to create stuff in and what I'm going
to do is make a new repo called um Azure
bicep example you can call yours
whatever you like I'm going to make this
public so that you can see the code uh
you can make yours private if uh private
is available to you there but I'm going
to make it public because if you want to
go find this repo at exampro here and
copy it and work with it you can so
we're going to go ahead and use code
spaces and codes spaces does have uh
free credit usage you could do this
locally um on your local computer but
you'd have to install a bunch of stuff
uh I like using Cloud developer
environments and Azure does not have one
built into their portal um most other
ones do but I think the reason why Azure
doesn't is because Microsoft owns GitHub
and so you could just go over here and
use code spaces instead so this to me is
like using Azure okay so we're going to
go ahead and create a uh code spaces on
Main here and understand as long as the
code space is running we are consuming
uh so if you want to stop it you could
always go up to to the command pallet
here and we can just say uh stop
or uh it's code
spaces it should be there should be
something here called
stop um shut
down I did this the other uh the other
day when we did did that yeah it is code
spaces whoops it's loading so it's it's
bumping things out here but if we go
code spaces there is an option to stop
the current Works uh code space so I'm
not doing that right now uh I want my
theme to be dark so I'm going to go to
this Cog down here go to themes go to
color and we'll switch to um GitHub
dark and we'll give it a moment to think
because it's a bit slower loading I
greatly greatly prefer git pod the
reason I'm using Code spaces is because
um the extensions are going to use the
official ones with Microsoft and it's
just going to be easier to show you this
here in most other courses I use git
pod um
so anyway once that is loaded and we
have changed our theme if that matters
to you uh we're going to want to do some
Azure bicep stuff so on the left hand
side I want you to go to extensions and
we're going to search Azure bicep I
don't use Azure bicep a lot but I
definitely know how to use it when we
need to so I know they have a really
good extension for it and it's like it
writes code for you it was it's the
nicest experience I've ever had with a
um an i
tool and this is the thing because
Microsoft um built Visual Studio code
and you know their they own GitHub they
can have really amazing synergies for
developers um so a lot of times I find
it easier to work in vs code and use
their extensions to interact with Azure
than it is to use Azure portal itself
and there are specific services like
Azure functions where you really have to
use Visual Studio code so it's essential
that you get used to using uh Visual
Studio code whether it's local or in a
cloud developer environment so I'm
installing that this Azure bicep um
extension and this thing will help us
write a lot of uh code um uh and it has
like templates and other stuff like that
so that's what I want to uh take
advantage of it um I don't remember the
extension for Azure bicep file so we'll
just go to the Azure bicep website I'm
sure they'll have like a quick start and
we'll work through it here
together so I want to go here and I just
want to know what the extension is it's
bicep so that's what it is so we're
going to go here and make a new file
we're going to call it main.
bicep and something we didn't do before
and this is what I wanted to do in the
SDK one but we didn't actually have a
use for it is there's probably like an
Azure um like kit Azure tools there we
go and this is something you might want
to install a lot of these down below
here see how there's like one for
databases resources functions if you
install tools it installs all these
other ones you even have one for C tools
and and um it's possible that uh yeah
see like this this one will autocomplete
Azure commands it'll do all sorts of fun
stuff even for Azure storage and
everything there's something but the
reason we want Azure tools is because we
can install Azure accounts and this will
allow us to quickly log in to our Azure
account remember before we typed in a
login and then we had to get a device
code and plug that in uh well if we have
this installed uh we can just use the
command pallet and log in very quickly
and that's what I want to do here so I'm
going to go to the bottom left corner
I'm going to pull up command pallet and
we'll try to do Azure
signin now to be fair I mean this is not
going to do much difference down here
but I think it installed the um the CLI
for us because before we had to manually
install it right so we'll go here and
we're going to have to choose device
code we have signed into Azure Cloud
let's try this one first see if that
works and then we're going to say uh
just so you know Azure has different
ones there like Azure China Azure
Germany Azure US Government so generally
we always want to choose Azure unless
you live in one of these other regions
and you have to use that one and this is
going to open up and we will sign in we
can now close this
window and I believe we are now logged
into Azure also notice on the leth hand
side we have this little Azure icon here
on the left hand side it will allow us
to see our resources we can also sign in
from here we should be signed in maybe
it didn't work I'll try this one more
time extension as your resources wants
to sign in we'll say allow maybe it has
to sign in separately I don't know we'll
close
this there we are so now we see our
subscription we are in here which is
great and we can see a bunch of our
services um so you know if we had
storage accounts and we do have some
storage accounts we can see them here
this one I think is for our uh Cloud
shell that's why it starts with cs and
it has a random number afterwards if we
had virtual machines and other things we
could see them here but yeah working
with functions you often use them here
um we could also probably right click
this and create a resource and so here
there's a lot of ways to uh create some
stuff we create a resource Group and and
some other particular
things but uh yeah that's that's
interesting I also wonder if like these
are these are obviously uh things that
were installed there could be other
extensions that we didn't install like
Azure uh machine learning service or
other stuff that could end up showing up
there on the left hand
side so I'm just kind of scrolling
through here seeing what might not be
installed so Azure container apps was
not
installed or maybe it was and it's these
other ones that have these little
install words on
here but
anyway enough about that let's stay on
track here and let's write some Azure
biceps so now that we have uh that
installed we want to start writing it so
I just need to see a little bit of code
to get a reminder here um so yeah if we
start typing it should start suggesting
and this is what we want to do is make a
storage account so let's go ahead and
start typing that in so I'm going to
type in resource uh and so already
notice that it is autocom completing and
then uh let's just go check here so the
next thing is going to be storage
account and it should
autocomplete so yeah I remember this
being really good at autoc completing
just give me two seconds and let's go
figure that out one sec yeah so I'm
looking at it here and it's supposed to
just start autoc completing when we type
so I'm not sure why it's not exact doing
that we'll go back here sometimes Visual
Studio code doesn't do what we want it
to do which is totally fine storage
account and it's not really autocom
completing so I'm going to go ahead and
save this for a
second well there it's autoc completing
so
resource storage am I typing it wrong is
it supposed to be uh with the resources
no no it's this so it's really
interesting that it's not Auto
completing but we could just copy this
in
here
okay I just wanted to show you how
powerful it was cuz I was so impressed
the first time I I saw it uh writing all
the code for me which is um not what the
other ones do that's for sure so we'll
just paste this in here
and if I put a period
here yeah I guess I was expecting a
little bit more from it um but uh
whatever I guess we'd have to work with
it a bit more to find out
again I don't work with it every single
day but I am always very excited to use
it um but you know the thing that I want
to uh take a look at is let's look at
where the actual reference documentation
is and so we'll go to Resource reference
here on the left hand side and I'm
really interested to
see uh where everything is so if you
know the resource type you can just type
it here in the Le hand side that's fine
so we have all our resources here on the
left and so we are trying to create a
storage
account so we can go over here
here and look for storage account so
that be storage and storage
accounts and so here it says to create a
uh to create a resource add the folling
to your Azure bicep so um just kind of
getting familiar with it it looks like
this is going to be its logical name and
this is actually going to define the
resource itself and these are all its
properties and it looks like there are
some that are required and some that are
not so it looks like I
think that if we can find this tab back
I think we can name this whatever we
want here this doesn't actually have to
be called storage account so we can go
here it's just a logical name that we
reference within this resource so I can
go here and say like storage account AB
it shouldn't
matter um what's really interesting up
here is that it's going to looks like
it's going to grab the resource Group ID
and then what does it do here creates a
deterministic hash based on the string
so it uses the resource ID to make a
random string and then it's going to say
toy launch in the front of it so I don't
want toy launch I'm just going to put in
here bicep and so um I think we can do
hyphens actually I don't think we can
and so we should get an Azure storage
account that's going to be bicep and
some random value after this and then up
here this is going to pull in the
resource Group now what's interesting is
we haven't created a resource Group it
says return the current Resource Group
scope so I'm not sure how this is going
to work if we don't have an existing
Resource Group but anyway we've written
our Azure bicep and we probably want to
go ahead and uh deploy this now so we
could probably just type in bicep down
below that's probably what the command
is nope that's not what it
is um maybe it's what is it I don't know
so let's go over to um back over here
for a second and let's see what the CLI
commands
are oh boy we'll say bicep
CLI
what is the commands just tell me what
the commands are please we could use the
command pallet because they're probably
all there like if we're if we were to go
into the command pallet and type in
bicep like we get all those commands but
I I really want to know what the um CLI
commands are I really thought it would
be bicep it is a z bicep of course so
looks like we can do um a bicep and then
just specify the template probably main
is the default so if we do nothing or
probably will pick that up I'm going to
go ahead and type in that and so it's
interesting we installed the extension
and we were able to log in but we still
don't actually have uh the CLI so it
looks like we do actually have to
install the Azure CLI in here which is
fine it's always great to get more
practice so we'll go ahead and type in
Azure CLI install we'll go to the
Microsoft learn website we will scroll
to Linux we'll go to auntu Debian um
because that's generally what G pod or
code space is or what have you will be
using we'll go down look for that one
liner and we'll copy it we'll go back
over to um code spaces we'll paste this
in hit enter and that'll go ahead and
install the uh Azure C now we are logged
in in this um uh invidual Studio code
and it could be storing the same
credential files wherever on the local
machine um so maybe we don't have to
necessarily log in twice it might be
also interesting to see where that um
that file is so maybe we can go ask chat
gbt where does um where does okay so
when you log into the Azure CLI where
does it store the
credentials what folder and file on the
Linux
machine that's what we want to
know
MH and the only thing I don't like about
ch BT is that you can't go away from uh
this tab while it's
generating and then sometimes it just uh
gets a bit slow but it goes out to the
Internet so I think that's the reason
why it's uh been slower than previous I
like previous models where it wasn't out
on the internet because it could
generate out
faster but
uh yeah this one's hanging on me so
let's
go to 3.5 let's just ask this one I want
it
fast okay so it's saying it's in the
Azure folder so that's something that we
might want to take a quick look at the
Azure CLI is installed I'm going to just
type in a um
account um account list and see if we
can list our
accounts okay so we are not logged in so
us logging in here uh wherever it's
storing it's definitely not storing in
the same place but let's go take a look
at that Azure profile directory so I'm
going to bump up the font a bit I
realized it's really small and I'm going
to go ahead and say CD and then
make a Tilda that is above your tab key
and you have to press shift to make it
it's called a Tilda it's like a little
squiggly we'll do a for slash I'm going
to do period for a hidden folder and
we're start start typing Azure and so
that folder is there we'll hit enter I'm
going to do LS to list out the contents
and we have stuff here I can do LS
hyphen LA to list it in a nice beautiful
list and uh if we don't want no that
looks fine and so I'm kind of interested
where it's storing uh that configuration
probably in the config directory so I'm
going to just CD into
config uh oh maybe it's not a folder I
thought that was a folder it is not a
folder okay so let's do cat to print out
the
contents cat stands for C Cate I think
and so that doesn't store it does a does
the a uh Jason file have it no that
doesn't have it but to be fair we
haven't logged in yet so maybe the file
will appear after after we log in so
that's okay what I'm going to do is go
ahead and type in a login and we'll say
use device code because I believe that's
the flag we have to use and we'll go
ahead and copy this link we'll go to the
top here and paste it in to one of our
available tabs we have to go back and uh
provide this
code and we'll go click next and we'll
click on our account we'll say continue
we'll go back over to here and we'll
give it a moment to think there we go we
are logged in so now what I want to do
is type in LS and looks like there's
more stuff there it looks like there is
and did we have this
before
um let's see here one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 yeah there's
definitely more stuff here um the new
thing that's here is Cloud's config so
I'm just going to cat that let's see
what's in there so least tells us this
is our default subscription so we at
least know where that's coming from
let's cat the config let's see if
anything's changed in there that's the
same let's cat a Json
Json there's still nothing in
there so it'd be really nice to know
exactly where it is normally other ones
will tell you exactly where they are uh
and you can literally open them up and
see see the information there I guess we
could also just cat out the session no
nothing so anyway it is stored
somewhere where it is I don't know does
it really matter no but it's nice to
know exactly where it is so that uh
let's say you wanted to delete it off
your computer or something but it's
stored somewhere anyway um we are we
should now be logged into Azure so we'll
go ahead and type in Azure a bicep I
still feel like it should have told us
the commands even if we weren't logged
in and I was hoping that it would print
us out the sub commands let's try to do
help and see if it actually does that
okay so it does you just have to give it
the help flag and so we have a few
options we can do build a bicep
file um build the bicep pramp file
decompile so if we already had an arm
template we could turn it back into a
bicep file that sounds really cool I
like that idea format a bicep file you
know if there's something wrong with it
it could tell us as the format's correct
install uh the bicep CLI which I thought
it already was installed let's go ahead
and try that first because maybe that's
why I couldn't just type in
bicep okay so now what happens if I type
in
bicep no so why did I install it if it
was already like that um bicep I'm
hitting tab to autocomplete to see if
anything's there bicep
CLI well whatever I mean we kind of
still already have it so that's totally
fine so we'll go ahead and type in bicep
a uh uh AZ bicep
build and and it wants a file totally
fine so we're going to give it a file um
build the file build a file and print
all of its outputs to SD
out I don't think it matters if we print
them out so before we do that I just did
control C to uh break that we need to
get back to our main folder so I'm doing
CD dot dot and I'm doing
LS where is this
folder CD for uh Aster for uh for slash
I'm so used to using git pod I can't
remember where uh this directory is I'm
just going to scroll up here and take a
look it is workspaces okay so to get
back to this
folder okay we're going to go to CD slw
workspaces I'm hitting tab to
autocomplete and then this one's called
Azure
bicep
um is really not autoc completing here
today oh I spelled Azure wrong okay that
explains that I'll go fix that in the um
the git pod I'll just rename it but now
we're back into here so um typing clear
so we're going to go Azure bicep file
and we're going to provide it main TF or
I'm thinking terraform bicep we'll hit
enter and so that's going to go ahead
and build it um is misspelled or does
not recognize is not recognized by the
system um okay we'll type in LS I mean
it's right there let's go back and and
take a look at the documentation and see
what it wants sometimes it might want um
uh like the file information but I don't
think so it just shows main
bicep I'll copy this
command oh I forgot the word build up
here that's why so um it looks like it's
now built and so we now have a main Json
we'll take a look here it's generated us
an arm
template at least that's what it looks
like y yep that's what it is so that
looks pretty good um I'm noticing
that yeah we have parameters up here so
now we can go ahead and deploy
this so it builds
it see here uh we can build our build
pram file not interested in that
generate
prams and install the commands to your
CLI oh publish maybe that's it the
publish command adds a module to the
registry the Azure container registry
exists I'm not sure if that's useful I
think that's if we want to reuse a
template for later kind of like how we
had those template specs I
think okay so if asure bicep just
generates out the files I'd imagine that
we just probably deploy it the regular
way using arm templates so I'll be back
in just a moment most other I tools like
they'll let you build and deploy but
maybe Azure bicep just compiles out
templates just give me a moment yeah so
I just quickly asked um chat gbt and yes
it did confirm it I my suspicions were
correct as your bicep is just draining
out the resource template and it looks
like we're going to have to deploy it
the regular uh or oldfashioned way here
um so now here's a question could we
actually use um Visual Studio code to
deploy this so if I right click
this could we deploy somewhere with this
so that's what I'm really curious
about let me go find all right so I
believe there's a few ways we can do
this of course we could go and just
deploy it the uh the oldfashioned way by
using this AZ deployment group um I was
looking around myself and I just typed
in bicep here and I also noticed that
they had
um uh a deploy step so maybe it can do a
direct deploy not maybe not through the
CLI but maybe it can do it through
Visual Studio code there should be one
for arm templates in here it's not
showing up I mean chat TBT seems to
think that it can but maybe there is a
another extension we're missing so let's
type in uh
Azure so we have Azure tools is there
one for
developer um let's go back here and take
a
look so there's one here it says Azure
resource manager oh it's an extens well
I thought that be installed ready then
that would be a really useful one to
have here so we'll say Azure resource
manager I thought it was there but I
didn't see it on the side so this seems
like a really good plugin this is
probably something I'd want to have
let's go ahead and install this one 1.5
million views yeah I believe so it's by
Microsoft I'm surprised it doesn't get
installed with the tools oh it's in
preview okay so I imagine when this is
out of preview I bet when you install
Azure tools it will uh be installed
there now I've said previously if
there's a preview tool you should should
try to avoid it because it might not be
there in the future um this one I think
we can kind of get away with utilizing
it it might be the future and it's no
longer in preview so we'll go over back
over to
here and do we have any changes
here no but if we go into our Command
pallet let's type in arm deploy
now it was saying that uh that something
we could do as your resource manager
uh install this
extension type in arm deploy in our
Command pallet we did
that yeah so it doesn't show up so you
know preview feature uh chbt might be
telling us something else we are using
3.5 so it might not be telling us the
full truth there and and I don't really
see any changes on here so I guess we're
not going to worry about that but I
would like to try the um the bicep
deploy so we'll type in just deploy
here and scroll on down we have deploy
bicep file let's see what happens if we
do
that and
so please enter the name of the
deployment sure we have to name the
deployment good um create a resource
Group because remember that we didn't
specify Resource Group so we'll have to
create one on the Fly here so let's do
that we'll call this my bicep RG RG for
Resource Group it's now going to go
ahead and deploy that it says deploy
failed uh provider subcription does not
have the resource type resource
groups
okay that is something I was not
expecting let's
go let's go ask Chach BT and try to save
us some
time
says check your bicep template file
ensure that you have defined the
resources correctly that is not
useful um maybe it's because it's not
registered so maybe when we use the CL
uh when we use the the UI it will
automatically register things when we
use it but we create resource groups all
the time so it's kind of surprising if
that wouldn't be registered so we'll go
over to our
subscription and I'm just going to
double check this here but I'm not sure
if it's going to make a difference we'll
over to
our yeah we're in our
subscription I'm looking
for
providers there it is resource providers
sometimes there's like another extra um
blade they call these blades over here
by the way and so I was getting a bit
confused and so Chachi BT is
suggesting maybe resources is not
registered which to me seems czy
crazy oh it is it's right there uh so
I'm not exactly sure what it's
complaining about the other thing is
that maybe Azure bicep isn't logged in
so I mean that seems like a possible
option so maybe we'll just go stick with
uh the usual way which is using the
Azure um the this Azure deploy method so
I'm going to scroll back up here and we
have this command now we did install in
here uh in extensions or I think it it
came installed was the Azure CLI and and
what that will do is it when we write it
out Azure CLI commands I believe it will
autocomplete for
us so here's scrapbooks for developing
running commands with a CLI create an
Azure CLI files and use the following
features oh okay so there's actually a
thing called an Azure CLI file that's
new to
me um but what we'll do is we'll go
ahead and we'll just say um new file so
we'll just say
commands and I'll just put that there
rename that like that that's what it's
saying to do and you'll say uh deploy an
arm
template and we'll go back over here and
we'll see if it starts to autocomplete
so we have AZ uh
deploy it's not really completing
correctly as just
demonstrated we'll go back over here and
take a look at that again
so yeah this one says demo. asli they're
making a comment
so Intel sense for commands and their
arguments stiip and
commands scrapbooks for uh developing
running commands in the Azure
CLI okay then work properly please maybe
it's not
installed oh we have to install it sorry
I thought we already had it installed
that's why so we'll go back over here
and so now our common is showing up so
we'll type a
deployment um
I mean we probably want to create
right it will have to have a name so
we'll just say my RG my
bicep um
deployment we'll probably have to have a
location so let's just
say probably should place it in the same
place as this one this does not have a
particular location so probably default
to wherever the resource Group is yep so
we'll say um it's East us there we go
there's probably something else we need
uh I'm not really sure let's go back and
see what chat GPT was asking for uh the
template of
course um we'll say
template and it technically is a
file so we'll go here and say main J
Json and by the way we could bring these
down onto new lines with this backslash
that allows us to have multiple lines in
our bash
terminal okay and it also probably wants
the resource Group so we'll go here and
type in
resource it can't do
multi-line it is not autocomp
completing
anymore Resource Group maybe we just hit
the limit of it
there
uh so I I assume that it could handle
multi-line but I guess when we're doing
multi-line then uh the Intel sense the
auto completion is it can't handle it so
we'll go back over to here and I just
forgot what we called that Resource
Group we actually did create one uh but
Azure bicep did fail the deploy because
of some kind of permissions or settings
so I just want to go quickly find that
name again notice that sometimes an
Azure you have to be patient super super
super common uh to wait around for for
Azure um because of propagations in
their UI super
common my internet's totally fine it's
it's Azure and it's back here says an
error occurred when trying to fetch
resources additional details from the
underlying API might be helpful are we
having an issue with
service so sometimes that happens so we
go like uh Microsoft status
page sometimes that happens and I got to
walk away come back to my
computer
but uh maybe it's not because my
internet seems to be funny
so but if that's the case
then oh yeah it's me I'll be back in a
moment all right so uh my internet
should be back here I'm just reopening
my connection here to my code spaces and
I'm going to go back over to here and
we'll give it a refresh and so I guess
that Resource Group did not create so we
do definitely have to create a resource
group first otherwise it's not going to
know what to deploy
into and I'm hoping that this uh
reconnects or it's still
running so but uh what I'll do here
while we're waiting is I'm going to
create a new Resource Group I'm going to
call this one my
bicep
RG and we'll go ahead and review and
create and we'll go ahead and create
that we'll go back over to our other tab
here I would really like it to reopen
here um not sure what it's doing to
figure this out going to go at the top
just type in
that previously working code space
environment so it's here it is active
I'm going to go back and say
open in the browser notice you can
launch this in Visual Studio code
locally or if you want to use Jupiter
Labs let's say you're doing something
with AI or something or machine learning
you could do that so this should open
back up our environment there we go
that's
great and um so we created that new
Resource Group that's called this here
so I'm going to go ahead and copy that
and I'm going to paste it into here
sometimes it's good to put double
quotations around these things I'm not
doing that unless that gives us problems
so I think this is everything we need we
need to know um the resource Group uh
it's probably recommended to provideed a
name we'll have our location and our
template file so I'm going to go ahead
and copy this and fingers crossed this
works uh of course we didn't really look
anything up um oh this one says a
deployment group create so maybe we
should make sure that's
correct but it did autocomplete create
so maybe
maybe that's okay well wait why is one
deployment group wouldn't that create
hold on we can hover over here and get
some stuff manage the a your resource
template uh deployment at the resource
Group
okay oh that's really cool if you hover
over it tells you everything
there well what happens if I take this
name out then does this still
complete starts a deployment at the
subscription scope so maybe both both
Works let's just see what happens it's
really nice that it shows everything
like that I really like that we'll go
ahead and paste that in we'll hit
enter and um it's showing we're missing
an argument Resource Group arguments it
doesn't like that
one starts a deployment creates a
deployment the resource
Group okay so here we have a create and
then we have starts a deployment the
subscription scope creates a deployment
at the resource Group from a local file
template so it looks like if we already
have one maybe this one would have
created a resource Group for us so what
I'm going to do is take this one out as
I really thought we needed to have it
but I'm going to go and see what happens
if we do
this the template resource location at
line 12 uh line 17 is not is invalid the
template function Resource Group is not
expected at this
location um okay it's it's not there I
didn't put it in the
template
so okay well what I'm going to do is
undo and type in group so I guess you
got to be really careful when entering
stuff in because it's going to give you
some trouble and this one looks a little
bit more normal with the group create so
we have template file Resource Group I
don't know if it needs a
name so maybe I'll just take the name
out and then we'll try this
one and we'll hit enter
and unrecognized arguments no
location well I mean this one has it and
this one doesn't okay we'll take the
location out we'll try this well I guess
we don't have to specify a location
because we've already created the
resource Group that's why so we'll try
this again makeing a lot of trouble
here but it's a good way to learn this
is how you should learn and this is this
is what Cloud's like just moing around
till get till we get it to work and then
hopefully it's it's the right way um so
this is going to go ahead and run and
we'll wait here I'm not going to make
you uh watch watch it here I'll be back
uh here in a moment okay all right after
a little bit of waiting um our terminal
has produced some stuff for us so it's
suggesting it probably created the
resource so we're in good shape let's go
back over to Azure and we're going to go
into our bicep RG and we now have our
resource so we've success successfully
used um as your biceps so let's go ahead
and delete this Resource Group we are
all done here um we're going to go ahead
and commit what we have so that uh any
future folks that are trying to do the
same thing as us can just go get that
code base uh good stuff here go ahead
hit commit sync the changes we'll say
okay that will push the changes
excellent and I'm going to want to stop
this workspace we'll open up the command
pallet we'll say
stop uh so say code spaces stop Cod C
spaces stop current workspace there we
go and that will stop the current
workspace so that is all good right
there um and I'm going to fix the name
here because it really should be named
correctly so that you can easily find it
in the
future just be more patient and make
sure you don't make mistakes and try to
fix them the best you can but yeah that
is azure bicep and we'll see you in the
next one
okay
[Music]
all right so we are back we showed you
how to uh utilize an arm template as
your bicep I want to show you another
way to do infrastructures code that's
very popular and it's with a uh
third-party um uh technology called
terraform super popular because
terraform can work with every single
cloud provider and it's simply the most
popular I tool um and it doesn't get a
whole lot of attention with Azure so I
figured we should throw that in in here
because you're most likely to encounter
it uh on the job as Azure bicep and arm
templates aren't as used as much as
terraform surprisingly so what I want to
do is go over to um GitHub and we're
going to make another
repo if it will let me see where that
button is sometimes it's a bit funny so
I'll go to the top right corner create a
new repo there's lots of ways to create
repos in here going to go to exam Pro
I'm going to make sure I type Azure
right this time we'll say Azure
terraform example I'm making mine public
you can make yours private um again it's
better for you to make it private
because that way you might uh you won't
expose information by accident and not
sure why this looks a little bit
different maybe GitHub just changed
something on me but what we'll
do because there used to be like a a
code button here maybe because I didn't
create the read me that's
why normally supposed to have a readme
I'm going to go ahead and just click
that button to create the read me commit
that and
oh unexpected what are you talking about
well now it is here so I think GitHub is
just having some hiccups anyway we have
a code code button here we'll go ahead
and create our code
spaces and we'll launch that up and
we're going to have to go install the
terraform CLI so I'm going to look up
terraform CLI
install and we'll go to the hashy cor
website hash car is what makes terraform
and somewhere in here they'll have one
for Linux we'll go over here and we need
to follow these commands here very
straightforward not a a oneline command
but they have additional commands here
for security
purposes so uh this environment's
opening let's go to the bottom left
corner and we'll pick out a nicer theme
we'll choose a uh GitHub
dark I'll just bump up the font a little
bit and we'll go back over to
here and we'll copy the installation
command so we're uh uh copying the first
one
here we say
allow okay we'll try this
again and is not letting me copy paste
sometimes you got to go up to this
clipboard make sure it
allows it is on
continue
copy right click there we go and this is
going to install um usually it's good
practice to do an update on your
packages we didn't do that for the other
the Azure CLI but very common practice
on Linux do that so that's what they're
doing first then we'll go over here and
we will grab the gpg key um gpg is a
security key that does something this
output is normal you should be seeing
this why it prints it like that I don't
know but I know it's okay you can ignore
it we will paste in the next one and
that one was weird that didn't look
right so I'll try this one more
time paste it again hit
enter oh I had to hit control C when you
see this like this here it usually means
it's expecting more input so I had to do
um contr C on my keyboard that's when
that shows up so I'm going to try that
one more time I think what it did was
when I hit up it it broughten that stuff
so we'll go back over
here I know it's a bit finicky it's a
bit frustrating and so this looks normal
this is what I want it's confirming the
key so verify the so download the key
and then verify it's
fingerprint and then the next thing we
can do is this will install the source
for hashy Corp so it can actually
install the p
package and notice that sometimes when
you copy paste you get some funny stuff
so you got to be really careful with
your copy
paste okay I'm just going to type clear
here I'm going to try this
again copy right click paste there we go
okay so now it's acting
normally you know I've been coding for
20 years and copy and paste gets me all
the
time it's uh not much you can do about
it now we can go ahead and install it so
I know that's a lot of steps we probably
could have just ran this and it probably
would have worked okay also knows here
it accidentally downloaded this weird
file I'm going to go ahead and delete
that not sure why it did that but make
sure you don't end up with junk files by
accident so now terraform is installed
so uh terraform the way it works is you
have the terraform command we hit hit
enter here I recently did a terraform
boot camp so terraform is fresh in my
mind whereas you notice Azure bicep was
a bit more Rusty but we'll go ahead and
make a main.tf file that is how we
create a terraform file we'll go to
extensions on the left hand side there's
probably a terraform
extension and here is one um this
there's this one and this
one this one is by Anton and I know
Anton he's super nice and then we also
have uh the official one we'll go the
official one here today sorry Anton
don't get upset with me they're both
great I just chose the official one for
this uh video demonstration Anton's um
maintains uh the terraform modules for
ads and a lot of other stuff so he he's
very good at terraform but now that we
have this installed it should gives us
some syntax highlighting and autoc
completion um and so uh what we need to
do is we need to get some code now the
reason I like Azure bicep is because it
really does generate everything in place
but with terraform you have to do a
little bit of work
we're going to type in terraform
registry and this is where um we can
find everything so here it's the
registry. terraform doio and we're going
to go to Providers providers is our
established connection to our specific
provider we're going to choose Azure and
in here in the top right corner they
have this purple button and it's going
to give us the code that we need to
start working with we're going to go
ahead and copy this and we're going to
go over here back to our code we'll
paste it into our main TF file so what
this is going to do it's going to say
install the the uh the ads or sorry the
Azure RM provider so that we can
interact with Azure through terraform
and then we can configure Azure down
here below normally the way it works for
uh configuration if we go to
documentation it will tell us in the
first page how do we establish a
connection so we can authenticate using
the Azure CLI which is something that we
have done we can also use a manage
service or a service principle um so I
mean the the azure C is the easiest way
to do it at some point you will have to
learn how to create a service principle
so I kind of want to do that like that's
kind of what I'm preferred to do at this
at this stage
here um but uh I have to make sure that
this makes sense so service principal
and client secret so this would be with
a password so let's click into this
one and I'm just trying to see where the
syntax is here I'm just looking at the
code so first log into here
here create
rbac no no I'll just do it the easy way
I won't make it too complicated for
everybody here I'll just use the Azure U
the Azure CLI so what we'll do is we'll
need to go ahead and install the Azure
CLI so you probably know by this routine
now so we'll go Azure CLI install and
we'll go over here and we'll go down
we'll go to the Ubuntu Debian and we'll
scroll on down grab the single line go
back over to code spaces which is here
we'll drag this up we'll go ahead and
paste this in and we'll hit enter and
that will install us the Azure
CLI won't take too long but it will get
installed here in a moment and so I'm
thinking that if the CLI is installed it
should automatically or uh it should
already know how to
deploy um so while that is installing
let's go back over to uh the terraform
registry and we'll look at um uh trying
to launch something in Azure so if we
click
back and we go back to the documentation
it has all the resources here on the uh
uh left hand side so we've been doing
storage accounts quite a bit here so I'm
just going to look for that on the left
hand side there so we'll type in
storage here and we'll go into
storage and in here I'm looking for a
storage account so it's right here and
we have some example code so this is
going to create
us a resource Group and then a storage
account so we'll copy this code and
we'll bring it on
over to here and we'll just paste it on
below I'm going to have to jump this
down a couple sizes here so I can see
what I'm doing and so we'll paste that
on in there and so now we have our uh
Resource Group with a logical name of
example um I'm going to rename this to
be something other than this so we'll
say uh
my uh terraform RG I don't want West EUR
Europe I want uh something in North
America
West us is that what it would
be I'm not sure if this will actually
autocomplete for me if it messes up
it'll throw an error we need to give
this a name so we will provide uh some
name here we're not doing complex
terraform of course you can pass in
parameters with separate files and
variables we didn't do that with uh
bicep either um that's something we
would do at a more advanced level but
let's go ahead and change this name here
and we'll put something else in so we'll
say um uh my storage account bunch of
numbers and then AB okay so this should
work replication doesn't need to be on
RGS but that's still fine it's a
standard that's fine I guess we have
some tags we don't need tags but that's
fine so now what we'll want to do is go
down below here and we'll have to do an
ay
login sorry I meant to say ay login
hyphen hyen Ed device code
okay and so we'll have to go to this
address down
below and we'll open
it on one of these other tabs we don't
care about and we'll go back here and
grab the
code we'll say
next and we'll click this we'll say
continue great we'll go back over to
here and so we have ADD your Cloud we
are now logged in so we should be able
to deploy to terraform it should know
that we're going to deploy to that
subscription remember earlier we checked
the um that Azure file uh in our uh
Azure config I'm just going to show you
really quickly Tilda sl. aure tab tab
tab and we're going to look in the
config directory it wasn't that one
maybe it was something else Cloud's
config and that's how it knows what
subscription is going to Target where
those credential files are somewhere in
that folder we still don't know and uh
the terminal's kind of messing up here
there we go I had to just kind of wiggle
it to get it to act normally and so what
I want to do is type A terraform and nit
so that's going to install the terraform
plugins the actual Azure provider for us
to establish connection I'm going to
type a terraform plan that's how you um
determine if your plan will work it says
insufficient feature blocks at least one
features block are required what the
heck is a features block I don't I don't
remember there being one there uh there
before maybe it just wants us to remove
the configuration complet
completely let's see if that
works um no it wants it so we'll go back
here I don't remember there being a
features block before but again things
change all the time on uh on me here and
so we'll go back to the provider it
doesn't show anything here go back to
the
documentation
features the features block allow
configuration behavior for the a
provider for more information go to the
dedicated page sounds good to me and
here it says uh this allows different
users to select behaviors they require
for example some users may wish to use
the OS dis virtual machine While others
might want to do other stuff so here
looks like you're supposed to have a
features block and then there are some
settings you can
set um additional settings so that's
kind of cool uh I don't remember that
before but let's just give it empty
features because I don't really want to
uh do anything
fancy okay we'll go ahead and save and
we'll say terraform
plan we'll give it a moment here it's
thinking it's really thinking that's a
good thing
right and usually doesn't take this
long
um what is going on here I'll be back in
a moment okay all right so I thought
there might be an issue with it but we
had to wait a very long time and it says
insufficient feature blocks um so at
least one features blocks are required
so I guess there's no way around it we
have to include a feature so I guess
I'll carefully look here and figure out
what it
wants um so here's all
possible uh
features they say they're all optional
then why do I have to why do I have to
provide one if if they're all
optional okay well if there was one that
we're going to do let's go ahead and
grab the resource Group because we are
using it we are technically creating a
resource Group um so maybe that's a good
idea to um have that one in
there really surprised that we have to
but
whatever so it says prevent deletion if
contains
resource
uh false I mean you might want it true
but the thing is we're doing this
temporarily and I want to be able to
tear things down and I don't want to
have any prevention on so we'll go ahead
and try terraform plan again maybe it'll
be faster that'd be really
nice and we did do what it asked us to
do
so and again I'm going to spare you the
waiting I'm just going to uh pause oh no
there we go so what it's done is it's
saying um and I'll just zoom out a bit
more so it's a bit easier or Zoom back
so the way it works is when you run it
it's going to say yeah we are going to
create these resources to see those
pluses that's what it's going to go
ahead and
create and there might be even more than
what you expect there to be um but nope
it's it's good so now that we're ready
we can go ahead and do a terraform
apply terraform
apply it's going to ask us to confirm
it'll say like yes or no we'll
definitely say yes we'll give it a
moment
okay other providers like adus and gcp
are a lot more responsive I think it's
just the time it takes to go talk to
Azure we'll type in
yes we'll give it a moment here again
it's thinking it's
thinking and it's creating the resources
great so I'll be back here when it's
done it might just take a couple minutes
might take 30 seconds but I'll be back
when it is uh created all right so like
about a minute took to create um so what
we'll do is we'll go take a look at and
by the way we really don't want to um um
we really don't want to uh leave this
you really want to stick with this and
uh after we deploy it so we can tear it
down because the state file is all here
so when you use um uh arm uh as your arm
templates and bicep with which just
produces arm templates the state of the
the infrastructure is on the cloud
provider so Azure has uh the Azure
resource manager and it stores some kind
of state file you don't see it we don't
know what format it's in um uh but with
terraform because it is an agnostic
provider uh it stores the state file
here now we could use ter from cloud
which has a free tier and we could put
it up there but uh for our purpose we
just have it in here you do not want to
commit this ever to your repo it could
have sensitive information in it so just
be aware of that in fact we should have
an ignore file in here so that we not
running into problems so I'm going to go
ahead here and just type in get ignore
it's probably the first thing we should
have done but uh you know sometimes we
do things out of order here get ignore
uh terraform so we'll just go grab that
because it'll give us the best stuff
GitHub has a um a recommended ignore
file we'll go ahead and copy
that and we'll go back here and paste
this in here and Save it and that way um
that state file will not be part of the
source code so notice it's not going to
commit it but the lock file will be
there which is fine let's go over to uh
Azure and make sure that that resource
was created so if we go to storage
accounts we have an additional one there
my uh storage account Etc it's there so
um it's there so if we were to lose that
state file we would actually have to
manually delete the resource Group
because it would no longer be able to
track it but we do have the state file
here and so we can go ahead and delete
those resources so we'll go ahead and
type in terraform
destroy and we'll hit enter and that
will um tear down terraform
okay we'll give it a moment it's just
thinking it is thinking real
hard there we go we'll type in yes and
we'll have to wait for it to destroy the
resource I'll see you back here when
it's done destroying okay all right so
after a short little wait there uh that
stuff has been torn down I'm going to go
ahead and commit these files so uh
changes we'll just make a quick commit
message there we'll sync those changes
we'll say okay make sure those changes
get pushed if you need to look at my
code it's going to be in that repo so
just go back and look for it on the
GitHub exam proo aure bicep
example um yeah we're good there let's
make sure we just
uh turn off this workspace here so we'll
say
stop
okay and we have now stopped this
workspace we are in good shape and we'll
see you in the next one
[Music]
okay all right so um I've been in the
free tier here and I've been Gathering a
bit of spend while just clicking through
resources I was actually surprised how
much spend uh has occurred considering I
haven't really done anything but let's
go take a look at in our subscription
and see if we can figure out what's
going on with our spend here uh of
course you know if you are in your paid
tier that could be problematic uh but
I'm hopefully you are utilizing the free
tier just as I am um and also we might
be bringing through the free tier
quicker because they're not treating um
not giving us the free uh the free tier
usage and they're just treating
everything as as if it's it's fully paid
so here it says we have2 200 remaining
out our $500 still I find that kind of
crazy we have spending rate and forecast
uh cost of course we have no cost so
we're probably more interested in usage
but let's go take a look and see what's
been causing this issue so we'll go into
uh here into our cost
analysis and there is there is really no
real cost it's more just like us using
uh resources so I'm trying to make sense
of this it Mak it's a lot easier when
it's real money and not uh pretend money
so we'll have to see here we'll go cost
by
resource let's see if we can make sense
of this
breakdown and uh I mean these are all
under a dollar so I'm not exactly sure
what it means here so this is not going
to be very useful in our free tier maybe
what we can do is go over uh
to back over to uh our subscriptions
here because really we shouldn't really
have any kind of spend it's uh I think
it's Azure tricking us
because I know all the resources we've
been spitting up and they're not uh we
have not had them up for very long and
there's no way they could be uh uh as
much as it's reporting here so maybe a
better thing might be usage uh if usage
gives us some indication
here I rarely ever have free tier so
it's not always very clear to me uh
what's going on here and so what we're
seeing here is this is the um uh the
quotas or usage of resources so if you
were to exceed this you might have to uh
request a a quot increase so this is not
uh that useful uh this is more about
current usage and usage there so yeah
I'm not 100% sure where um uh free spend
occurs so just give me a moment and I'll
go find out okay all right so um
Microsoft is suggesting some things here
I don't necessarily mean that I believe
that this is where it is but let's go
take a look and see if they're being
honest with us here so we're in our
subscription and it's suggesting that we
go over to where um spending r forecast
so that's what we were on earlier if we
go back over to the right tab it was we
go back over to overview it was this
here we go to view
details and I was trying to break it
down a different
way okay so we'll go back over here cost
by resource show the cost of individual
resources uh top free services by
usage uh this only uh this area only
appears for free count so if you don't
have a free count the isn't shown well
I'd love to see that that sounds very
useful to me so let's see if we can I'm
going to close this tab it keeps messing
me up if we can see that
[Music]
here I mean I'm not
really seeing that
here all right let me really carefully
read it okay all right I think what it's
saying is that on that overview page
it'll have that on the right hand side I
don't think I saw saw that but I was
going pretty darn quick so to be fair it
could be my fault and we're just going
to go back to subscriptions here on our
overview it's over here so we'll view
all free uh uh Services they say this
only is provided in our free services
for 12 months so no this is talking
about all usage over uh over 12 months
and uh we can sort this based on usage I
suppose and we're only seeing usage here
so you can see that we're not really uh
utilizing much like Cosmos DB has a free
tier that's something we spun up earlier
virtual machines has a free tier I don't
think AKs has a free tier but where is
all this money going that's what I want
to know how do we go from $500 to $200
in a day uh it's oh your remaining $200
of free credits expire in ETC maybe we
only get 200 free maybe it's not $500
and I'm just I'm just crazy um let's go
ask
chbt how many credits do I get in Azure
for the first 30
days maybe it's just
200 I mean that sounds more reasonable
than 500 I think I'm just uh kind of
forgetting I remember gcp once had like
a lot of free credits like
thousands and uh chat GPT is really
taking their time here so let's go out
to the internet and oh no here we
go it's $200 okay so all right our spend
isn't crazy it's just down by a little a
little amount of money it's still not
showing us what is fully
outstanding again it's so hard to see
this when the spend is so low so I guess
we really are not spending a whole lot
there we can go back to notifications
and see it uh I mean it did show up here
notifications and notifications is
taking time here to today that's
great come on notifications you can do
it it's really not appearing here today
and I can't go
back there we go yeah so I guess maybe
it wouldn't show up there maybe it would
show up in the advisory so um uh most
providers have advisories and that's
maybe where that popup came from so
we'll go back to subscriptions I think I
saw it here on the left hand side we had
like uh ad
recommendations and we have none right
now okay so that's okay um all I wanted
to know was do we know where we can see
our spend and apparently in the free
tier we can go over here uh and see
stuff since we're not in the pay tier
there's not a whole lot of information
that is interesting that we can see but
maybe make note of this that when you
want when you are in your first 12
months of your account go over here and
check and just uh see what your
utilization is looking at and just be
very aware of what you have access to so
clearly we have Cosmos DB we have
storage we have some virtual Machines of
very particular sizing we get some SQL
database which is really nice uh public
IP addresses this is something that was
not charged for uh previously I don't
know when Azure started charging for it
but all providers now charge for
ipv4 uh addresses um so that's another
additional uh expense cognitive Services
which we do a lot in the AI 900 so
that's a lot of AI stuff you got a load
balancer for free which is nice um um
and a bunch of databases down here below
and more virtual machines so one's
probably L Linux one's probably windows
so a lot of fun stuff there but anyway
hopefully that gives you an idea of
spend a little bit more but of course
it' look a lot nicer if we had more
spend and maybe I'll make a separate
video showing uh more spend okay see you
in the next one
ciao so asure monitor is uh quite a
beefy service there's a lot going on in
it and so it's a comprehensive solution
for collecting analyzing acting on tele
data from your cloud and on- premise
environment so here's an example of one
of the things it can do which is provide
you a visual dashboard but it can create
smart alerts automate actions log
monitoring and a lot of different things
and many Azure Services by default are
already sending their data to Azure
monitor so you can use it right
away now I just want to introduce you to
the concept of the pillars of
observability this isn't a thing
specific to Azure but it's something
that in devops that you need to
understand and it's just going to help
you contextualize the offerings of azure
Monitor and other cloud service
providers so what is observability that
is the ability to measure and understand
how internal systems work in order to
answer questions regarding performance
tolerance security and faults with a
system and application and in order to
uh obtain observability you need three
things you need metrics logs and traces
uh and you have to use them together
using them in isolate does not gain you
a observability so let's go Define those
three things the first thing is metrics
and that is a number that that is
measured over a period of time if we
measured the CPU usage and aggregated it
over a period of time then we would have
the average CPU metric then you have
logs these are text files where each
line contains event data about what
happened at a certain time and then you
have um traces and this is a history of
requests that is that is uh that travels
through multiple apps and services so we
can pinpoint performance or failures and
I like to make the joke that it looks
kind of like the Triforce observability
once you've constructed it there at the
end
[Music]
let's look at the anatomy of azure
monitor which is a little bit complex
but I'm sure we can work our way through
it so the first thing is that we need uh
sources of data so these this is what uh
what data can be sent into Azure so you
probably want application data operating
system data uh data from Azure resources
at your subscription level your tenant
level which is going to be associated
with active directory and custom sources
and once you get those into Azure
monitor you have to store them somewhere
you're going to put them in logs and
monitors and these are just data stores
that are within Azure monitor that
you're going to be able to work with and
once you have that data in there you're
going to be able to leverage different
services that do different things um and
so we will call these functions so you
can perform insights uh visualizations
uh analysis uh response and integration
so what we' look at insights uh we're
getting insights into our virtual
machines our containers our applications
uh for visualization you might be making
d dashboards uh you could be using
powerbi or creating workbooks for
analysis you might be using the log
analysis or the metrical analysis tools
for responses uh you might want to
create alerts or start Auto scaling and
for Integrations you might want to use
logic apps or export apis to connect
things up so there you
go I want to quickly touch on log
analytics uh and so this is a tool used
to edit and run queries within Azure
monitor logs and and so the idea is it
kind of looks like um something you use
to connect to a database cuz it really
is structured like a database with
tables and columns and things like that
and it has this uh its own query
language called kql and the idea is that
you input uh um your queries and it's
going to Output results for you and
that's something we're going to look uh
in Greater detail is that uh kql
language so that we know how to use that
panel let's go talk about
[Music]
workspaces so um when you use log
analytics you're going to probably want
a workspace and this is a unique
environment uh for Azure monitor log
data each workspace has its own data
repository and configuration and data
sources and solutions and are configured
to store their data in a particular
workspace so it's really interesting
because if you go over to Azure monitor
you can use uh uh log analytics without
creating a workspace but I believe that
if you want to um uh isolate a lot of
your data and uh install like maybe like
collect data outside of a your services
for other things you're going to need a
workspace and it's going to also have a
lot more robust options so that's
something you're going to end up doing
is uh creating work spaces and it's a
good habit to do um but there's not a
lot to talk about there but let's move
on to actual the query language which is
really the meat of log
analytics let's take a look here at
Azure alerts and this helps us uh be
notified when there are issues found
within the infrastructure or application
and this allows us to identify and
address is before the users of your
system notice them and so they come in
three flavors we got metric alerts log
alerts and activity log alerts and when
alert is triggered you can be notified
or have it take action so here is kind
of the anatomy of an alert and we have
the alert rule this defines who we
should monitor like the the service and
uh like the the definition of when it is
triggered which is going to be the next
part here so a resource such as a
virtual machine uh designated as a
Target resource will emit signals so
it's going to be em emitting a data
payload and it could be of the following
types it could be a metric a log
activity log application insights you
can kind of see how that ties to the
types of alerts then you have the
criteria or logical uh tests this gets
evaluated and determines are we in a
triggered state it could be like
percentage CPU greater than 70% then you
have your Action Group which contains
actions um and those actions uh will be
uh performed when it is triggered and
actions could be things like run uh run
an automation run book use Azure
functions itsm logic app web hooks or
secure web hook on the other side there
we have um this box over here and this
is all about the state of your alert and
so we have monitor condition Al Alert
state so monitor condition is set by the
system and Alert state is set by the
user but the idea that is there is so
you can Define where it is because you
might want to uh have a history of
saying okay I've resolved this issue so
I'm marking this as closed and that' be
like an alert State there um and so
there you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at application
insights and this is an application
Performance Management Service so it's
an APM and it's a subservice of azure
monitor let's talk about what apms are
so these are monitoring and and um uh
they do monitoring and management of
performance and availability for
software apps APM strives to detect
diagnosed complex application
performance problems to maintain an
expected level of performance so why use
application insights will automatically
text performance anomalies and includes
powerful analytics tools to help you
diagnose issues and to understand what
users do with your app designed to help
you continuously improve performance and
usability works for apps for.net node GS
Java python hosted on on premise hybrid
or any uh public cloud and I know that
it works for uh other ones that are not
part of the supported languages so
there's one for Ruby but the thing is is
like um Azure is only providing official
support for a bunch of languages but you
might still have libraries out there for
them and it integrates with your devops
processes and can monitor analyze uh
Telemetry from mobile apps by
integrating with visual studio app
center and if you're running an app you
definitely want to have an APM installed
if you ever use data dog or Skylight or
New Relic that's what apms are or what
those um providers offer but let's take
a closer look here and this is kind of
an example of uh an application and what
you're going to see is that we have a
front end a backend and workers just to
kind of represent uh how you can
instrument your applications and when we
say instrument it just means install
like this piece of code that runs on it
to send data back to uh application
insights uh and the idea is that when
you instrument it you're just installing
the instrument uh package STK or in some
cases you can just turn it on where it's
supported so you don't necessarily uh
have to install it an app you might just
press a button and it will uh install it
within uh Azure services and there's
many ways that you can view your
telemetry data so the idea is that the
agent send that information to
application insights and then you're
going to be able to leverage that in
alerts powerbi Visual Studio rest API
continuous exports a lot of a lot of
services can ingest application sit so
apps can be instrumented from anywhere
so if if you running on AWS you can
install it on your servers there when
you set up application sites monitoring
for your web apps you create an
application site resource in Microsoft
Azure so it's a physical resource and
you open this resource in the Azure
portal in order to see and analyze
Telemetry collected from your app and
the resources identified by the
instrumentation key also known as the I
key and I just got a big old list here
just to tell you all the things you can
do with it so what does application
Insight monitor well request rates
response time failure rates dependency
rates response times failure rates
exceptions page views load performance
Ajax calls user and sessions count
performance counters host Diagnostics
diagnostic Trace uh logs custom events
metrics uh uh so there you go that's a
big old list and on the right hand side
is where can I see my Telemetry and we
saw a little list but let's go through
the big list and that's uh smart
detection manual alerts application map
profiler user uh usage analysis
diagnostic search for instance data
metrics Explorer for aggregated data
dashboards live metric streams analytics
Visual Studio snapshot debugger powerbi
rest API continuous export and there you
go so you can see that it can collect
and you can use it in a lot of places
definitely definitely install if you're
using or you running a web application